time and again
in fact 20 times
ministers promised an employment bill
that would protect workers and put an
end to warehouses run like victorian
workhouses
they then promised they would make it
illegal for bosses to suck a long
standing staff members and then rehire
them on worst pay and hours to rev avoid
a repeat of the p l scandal
they promised that enhanced rights and
protections were just around the corner
well madame deputy speaker manana manana
manana
20 times ministers have stood at that
dispatch box and said that we should
await the employment bill
and await we did
where
is it three years now and we're still
waiting
but now we can see that they were never
going to come up and become good on that
pledge
the promise to introduce a single
enforcement body and take action on tips
and sick pay
gone
the promise to consult on making
flexible work in the default without
good reason not to ditched the promise
to introduce extended leave for neonatal
care
dropped the promise to make it easier
for fathers to take paternity leave
disappeared the promise to extend the
entitlement to leave for unpaid carers
to a week abandoned the promise to
create a preventative duty against
sexual harassment is missing the promise
to extend redundancy protection for
pregnant women
nowhere to be seen and the promise to
end the cruel practice of fire and
rehire up in smoke
the truth is madam deputy speaker this
government is presiding over a bonfire
of workers rights and breaking their
promises left right and centre
they pledged to enhance rights and
protections at work but yet again they
have failed to deliver
and if the conservatives
were serious about spreading opportunity
prosperity and power across the country
they would start by introducing plans to
pay people a fair day to pay for a fair
day's work
but this government
has yet again failed to make the choices
required to stand up for working people
because they are not on working people's
side so while prices continue to
skyrocket we see no plans no plans to
tackle the cost of living crisis the
prime minister says more help is on its
way
and then his own spokespeople and his
absent neighbor in number 11 furiously
deny it while ministers take to the
airways to put on silly voices and mock
those who are struggling this is not a
serious government
they continue to try and pull the wool
over our eyes madame deputy speaker
telling us that these skyrocketing
prices are just a global problem that
offering people help is somehow silly
that nothing can be done
but here's the problem madam deputy
speaker
while bill saw across britain the prime
minister
enforced tax hiking budget the only
leader across the g7 to do so
the prime minister
and his chancellor
chose chose to hike taxes on working
people at the worst possible time and
chose not to introduce a windfall tax on
energy companies to help people with
their energy bills
we need an emergency budget now to sort
out this mess and tackle the cost of
living crisis
i get constant mail
from my constituents struggling to make
a paycheck last until the end of the
month they all deserve better
a decent wage that is enough to raise
the family on and to afford bread and
yes some roses too
better pay would end the self-defeating
low-wage low investment and low
productivity cycle that the country has
been trapped in for the last decade
boosting people's income isn't just the
right thing to do for them but it's the
right thing to do for our economy
the fact is that right now people don't
have
the money to spend in our shops and our
businesses and our local economies
so high streets are suffering places
that were once a great source of great
pride are now a source of great sadness
as independent
businesses are replaced with plywood
shutters
and britain's insecure work epidemic
isn't just punishing workers and
communities he's starving the public
finances too
new research from the tuc this week
shows that insecure work low paid work
costs the treasury 10 billion pounds a
year in lost tax revenues and by pushing
up social security payments
and that madam deputy speaker means less
funding
for our cash-strapped hospitals care
homes and schools
and you know that is a choice
it's a government's choice
and under this government the people
that work to rebuild this country have
been forgotten
in towns up and down this country people
are working harder and paying more but
getting less every year
in places where i like where i grew up
in stockport families are suffering
while traveling across the country
during the local election campaign i saw
firsthand how the conservatives have
frozen wages overseeing widespread
inequality and increased poverty from
berry to bletchley and barnet to burnley
the people and the places that once
proudly powered britain
that made their contribution to our
economy have been rewarded by low wages
and insecure
work underpaid
under appreciated and undervalued
and it is high time
that the key workers
who got us through this pandemic and all
of our working people are given the
dignity
and security at work that they deserve
but under the conservatives work doesn't
mean security anymore and it doesn't
mean fairness either
that's why we've proposed a new deal for
working people within the first hundred
days of a labour government we would
legislate to introduce fair pay
agreements bringing together workers and
employers to agree the terms in the each
sector starting in social care we're
ambitious
for our country and our ambitions don't
stop there labor will strengthen the
protections afforded to our workers by
ending qualifying periods for basic
rights which leave working people
waiting up to two years for their basic
protections
labor will end this arbitrary system and
scrap qualifying times for basic rights
such as unfair dismissal sick pay and
paternity pay
with a labour government
working people will have rights at work
from day one
but this is not just about workers madam
deputy speakers so many businesses play
by the rules and try to do the right
thing but are undercut by the offshore
and the unscrupulous many of them small
and medium-sized businesses who are the
backbone of our local and regional
economies they deserve better too and we
would scrap business rates to help our
high streets flourish and just today
we see the delivery and gmb union's
groundbreaking agreement that shows how
innovation and advice at work can go
hand in hand
it is good that there are successful
businesses who understand the value of
trade unions in the modern economy
this government
could also learn a lesson or two about
the role of women in our economy having
been a single parent myself madam deputy
speaker i know only too well the
challenges of trying to balance work
with being a good mum running from work
to the school gates and missing out on
parents evening
rather than stacking the odds against
working parents labour would deliver
stronger family-friendly rights we'll
extend statutory maternity and paternity
leave introducing the right to
bereavement leave and strengthening
protections for pregnant women
labor will ensure that all workers have
the right to flexible working as a
default from day one
so many workers shown how flexible they
could be during the pandemic we should
build on that flexibility we are
committed
to extending statutory maternity and
paternity leave introducing the rights
of bereavement leave and strengthening
protections for pregnant women by making
it unlawful to dismiss a woman who is
pregnant for six months after her return
as default
labor will set stronger family friendly
in stone
and we will also put mental health on a
par with physical health in our
workplaces and this week is mental
health awareness week and ministers
would do well to remember it labor will
also act to close gender disability and
ethnicity pay gaps
this government's programme
is completely lacking in any plans to
tackle the inequalities facing black
asian and minority ethnic people so
visibly exposed by the covid 19 pandemic
yet again
the government has renewed on its
promise
to introduce the ethnicity pay gap
reporting ignoring calls from both the
cbi and the t.u.c
happily yeah
i'm very grateful to my friend for
giving away she made a fantastic speech
would she share with me my sense of
admiration for baroness mcgregor smith
and the word that she did in persuading
many companies who wanted to embrace the
agenda around pay gap reporting only to
be thwarted by the the ventures opposite
isn't it a sad indictment that business
and tuc and everybody else is we're head
of the government on this issue
i thank my honorable friend for the work
that he's done on both the labour's plan
for our employment but also for the
point that he makes which is absolutely
crucial this government's pattern of
behavior is not to work and not to
listen to anybody it seems at the moment
it's all about rhetoric rather than
about actually working collaboratively
to make things better for the people of
this country and it seems nobody's
immune to that these days whereas it was
once just a select few that they felt
were
parties on in their views but actually
quite a lot of people is frozen out with
their ideas and it seems that this
government is not willing to listen
our country
is riven with inequalities which these
benches are focused on fixing to ensure
that working people who create our
nation's wealth get their fair share of
it meanwhile
they propose a procurement bill
that looks increasingly unworthy of the
name we need a bill that allows us to
use government contracts to support
british businesses so we can make and
buy and sell more in britain
as we recover from the pandemic we have
a chance to seize the new opportunities
to shape a new future for britain
opportunities to give people new skills
and jobs here in the uk to invest in
local businesses and help our high
streets thrive again
a labour government would ask every
public body to give more contracts to
british businesses using social
environmental and labor clauses in
contract design we'd work with colleague
colleges and universities to make sure
that we're honing the skills and
apprenticeships that we need for the
jobs of the future
where the tories have cynically
cynically abused procurement rules and
have handed out
millions of pounds of public money to
their mates
labor will use public procurement to
support good work and good british
businesses
from good green jobs in tidal power and
offshore wind to fintech media and film
we must grow modern industries to build
a long-term economy that provides good
jobs and is fit for the future
did she agree with me
that
to close down by selling off um channel
4 in leeds will be a mortal blow to the
creative industries in the north of
england
absolutely i absolutely agree with my
honorable friend and the frustration is
is that people in the north and in the
midlands and in areas where i represent
have been told levelling up leveling up
leveling up and yet the first sign of
any sort of sprig of help with our
economy they trash it by taking away the
support that's there and doing something
that really does not seem to add up in
terms of leveling up and supporting our
great industries in the north and in the
midlands
sure i thank my unison comrade for
giving me she makes that an excellent
point now um doesn't that also apply to
the government's
ludicrous decision to close
dwp offices and now closing insolvency
services offices across the uk
i thank my unison colleague and friend
who we've known for many years and have
fought for working people for many years
and for great public services and again
yes i absolutely agree with my honorable
friend on this point it doesn't make
sense and it's a theme that i said
throughout what my opening speech here
is that the government says one thing
but it's always jammed tomorrow and
their actions are completely divorced
from the what's happening on the ground
and their actions and what they do the
conservatives have had 12
long years to make the changes our
country desperately needs to secure our
future but they have failed
and all the while
we've seen the watering down of workers
rights and rogue bosses like piano take
advantage of our lacks rules while
ministers stand by idly instead of an
employment model that delivers for
working people the conservatives have
ushered in a race to the bottom on the
backs of working people outsourcing
zero hour contracts and agency work
driven down pay standards and conditions
across our whole economy for everyone
labour's approach
is to offer people real help right now
and a vision for the future of work
where working people enjoy dignity and
where they are treated with
respect this is what is missing from the
government's programme
real help right now when people need it
a vision for a better britain with a
more secure future
work should provide
not just the proper wage that people can
raise a family on but dignity
fairness and flexibility
labor will make britain work for working
people
this conservative government madam
deputy speaker haven't got a plan they
haven't got a clue
ministers claim that they are getting on
with the job
but it's they
who are failing britain's workers
and their communities today
dr liam fox
thank you madam deputy speaker it is
always a pleasure
to speak in this house but it's a
particular pleasure for me today as it's
30 years to the day since i stood in
almost the same spot to give my maiden
speech
in the house of commons and it's a
pleasure to speak in a debate about the
communities up and down our country
nothing undermines the stability of our
economy community and families more than
inflation
it inevitably hits the poorest in
society hardest and it's therefore a
moral as well as an economic hazard
as milton friedman said inflation is
taxation without legislation except that
no one wins including the treasury
as a result of the covert 19 pandemic
the global economy suffered a negative
supply shock with an initial fall in
output followed by an increase in prices
this has affected a wide range of global
commodities but nowhere has it been felt
more than in the energy sector
and the complication here is that the
current surge in prices is not the
result of a single shock of the pandemic
but a number of supply and demand
factors that have affected the market in
recent times and when i say that members
who are interested in a detailed
analysis of this subject should read the
report by carlos fernandez alvarez and
gagely monarch written and published by
the international energy agency because
it answers the questions that many of
our constituents are asking us which is
why has energy suddenly become so
expensive at the beginning of the
pandemic we saw fossil fuel prices fall
to their lowest in decades followed by a
strong rebound as the global economy
recovered this was exacerbated by a cold
winter in the northern hemisphere and
lower than average wind generation in
europe but the main driver to price
increase has come on the supply rather
than the demand side
the commodity prices collapse of 2014-15
and then 2020 resulted in diminished
investments in oil and gas increasing
the vulnerability of the sector
and governments across the world have
failed sufficiently to scale up clean
energy sources renewables and
technologies to fill the inevitable gap
these problems were exacerbated by the
recent lockdowns pushing essential
maintenance work from 2020 to 2021 which
saw restrictions on supply just as
demand was recovering quickly
as particularly true in the uk and the
norwegian sectors of the north sea
similar problems affected the gas
industry
and therefore the global economy has
seen an unavoidable inflationary shock
but
and there's a big but
we can be sure that this is not the
whole story when it comes to the price
rises being faced not only in energy but
across a range of commodities by the
british people today
how can we be so sure
because if we look across the global
economy
at the variability of inflation rates we
see a very large difference
in japan
a country that imports all of its fossil
fuels the latest inflation figure shows
a rise to 1.2 percent
china is 1.5
while in the eurozone inflation has
surged to 7.5
switzerland a european but non-eurozone
country has inflation of 2.5 percent
in the uk we're above seven in the us
8.5 and rising so something other
than energy prices
has been behind our inflationary
phenomenon
in fact we've got two different
inflationary surges
that of global commodity prices as i
mentioned
and that affects everyone
and that of monetary inflation that
afflicts those countries where central
banks have allowed persistent increases
in the amount of money in circulation
relative to existing output
the group think mentality of central
bankers in the united states the
eurozone and the uk has reinforced the
idea that they've stumbled upon some
kind of monetary alchemy but it's
possible to continually expand the money
supply unrelated to output without
creating inflation now perhaps that's an
uncharitable view and they knew all
along that they would create inflation
and they were simply responding to their
political masses but that raises
questions about the independence of the
central bank in the first place either
way it's a wholly unacceptable position
it's almost universally accepted that
the first duty of government is the
protection of its citizens and as a
former defense secretary i'm only too
aware of the many external threats
to the safety of our people and our
country
but there are other threats that i
believe we have a right to be protected
from
the debasement of our currency
the erosion of our earnings and the
devaluation of our savings
i believe it's fundamentally wrong for
governments to engage in structural
profligacy
spending excess across the economic
cycle and passing ever larger amounts of
debt onto the next generation and i
believe that it's the duty of central
banks to safeguard the value of our
money and our savings
the bank of england persisted beyond any
rational interpretation of the data to
tell us that inflation was transient
then it would peak at five percent
they have consistently underestimated
the level of the threat
so there are three things that i would
like to see
first the treasury committee should
launch an investigation into why the
bank of england so comprehensively
underestimated the inflationary threat
that the monetary policy report goes
back to being the inflation report
and that the government thinks about
what guidance might be given to the bank
of england to consider and report
monetary stability
[Applause]
now i'd like to say madame debt speaker
what about the government's forthcoming
leveling up and regeneration bill
we all understand the need
for housing targets
we must have social mobility ensuring
that the next generation can participate
in the benefits of home ownership
and we need more affordable homes to
allow young people to continue to live
in the communities in which they grew up
but targets
for housing must be just that they must
be targets for local authorities not
instructions to local authorities and
i'm delighted that the government seemed
to have changed the direction of travel
to move in a much more rational
direction than was perhaps there
previously
we also need to accept
in planning that the local authorities
uh have competing priorities to give one
example in north somerset in my own
constituency yes we accept that we need
to have more housing
and we accept that the government will
set targets but at the same time the
government says don't build on the green
belt
understandably and correctly don't build
on flood plains understandably
incorrectly but that limits the actual
space where there is to build further
housing so what i would like to hear the
government make very clear is that where
local plans are being constructed and
they have conflicting priorities being
applied to them by government that the
local authority will be the ones who get
the benefit of the doubt when it comes
to the planning inspectorate and that
brings me to that issue of greenbelt
itself according to the government's
national planning policy framework
greenbelt serves five purposes to check
the unrestricted sprawl of large
built-up areas to prevent neighbouring
towns merging into one another to assist
in safeguarding the countryside from
encroachment to preserve the setting and
special character of historic towns and
to assist in urban regeneration by
encouraging the recycling of derelict
and other urban land
i will i'll post i'm very grateful to
the right donald gentleman and
in order to secure
that supply of land uh for building the
houses that he said would he agree that
it would make sense to reform uh the
compensation act 1961
so that local authorities were able to
purchase land closer to their existing
value rather than their hope value
i think that's that's something that we
should certainly look at and i think the
passage of this village committee stage
is an opportunity for parliament to
genuinely reform
what our planning laws to make them
sensible
for a 21st century
country
we must ensure that in this bill our
green belt is not only protected but
that the government increased those
protections because once our green belt
is gone
it is gone forever
and i believe it is our duty to steward
the green spaces in our land for future
generations i'll give way to question um
is the right honourable member aware
that there are large tracts of green
belt close to outer london train
stations that are not green and are not
accessible and if developed could lead
to a million more homes precisely in the
areas where people need them
well we should be having far more
housing built in our urban areas because
one of the great uh
uh hopes i have for this bill is that we
will see housing built closer to where
people can go to work so that there is
not so much pressure on the transport uh
infrastructure
it's been our tendency in recent times
to build commuter belts that where
people therefore have to travel into our
cities getting mixed development in our
cities regenerating our cities would
take a lot of pressure off the transport
system itself and there's one other big
reform that we need to get uh finally
and that is a sorry i'm going to
i apologize to my friend
we need reform of land banking
the system that we have at the present
time where big developers buy land get
permission for 200 houses build 40 and
wait for the price to rise before they
build the rest results in planning
blight it results in big land banks for
the developers it means that people who
live in our communities don't know what
is going to happen there are a number of
solutions my preferred one would be that
if local that if developers have not
built out the permissions they have they
should not be allowed to apply for
further planning permissions in the same
local authority there are a number of
ways of doing it but we absolutely have
to deal with this problem because it
blinds communities up and down the uk um
madame deputy's book i'm aware of your
strictures on time and i'd finally say
that they're leveling up
agenda is about extending opportunity to
people in all parts of the united
kingdom and in regenerating our great
northern cities we have an opportunity
to take pressure off the overcrowded uh
south where housing and transport demand
is too high and we need to see better
employment opportunities spread across
the country in what i would call
rebalancing britain we have a great
chance to have a win-win for all parts
of the united kingdom but i say finally
to my friend that unless we're able to
tame inflation none of our ambitions
will be realized
snp spokesperson kirsty blackman
thank you very much madam deputy speaker
i appreciate you calling me to speak in
today's queen's speech
i gave some thought of what i might say
today and i wondered how many times i
could say where is the employment bill
in a speech
so but i thought about the best way that
i could say that where is the employment
bill and the best way that i could say
it was by quoting the scottish tuc who
absolutely got it right they said 20
times the tory uk government promised to
bring forward an employment bill
absolute silence in today's state
opening of parliament true to form
tories have shafted workers and armed
bad bosses devolve it already i don't
think i could say it better than that
the minister is standing there uh giving
us all sorts of promises like he's been
doing all year like many ministers have
been doing about unemployment but we
can't believe
anything that he says in relation to the
employment bill because it is not being
forthcoming he promises and promises and
promises and clearly cannot convince the
uk government to actually deliver if he
even believes it should come through at
all
there are so many reasons madam david
speaker why we need to have an
employment bill why this is absolutely
vital and why this is more vital today
than it even was when it was in the
conservative manifesto back in 2019 than
it even was when the taylor view was
published more than five years ago it is
desperate because of the cost of living
crisis that we are seeing because of the
absolute pain that our constituents are
going through and if the conservatives
want to try and rebrand this as a cost
of living crunch um that is an absolute
crisis that people are struggling with
every single day the first thing that we
would like to see in the employment bill
is a proper living wage remove the age
discrimination that there is in the
living wage have the living wage
actually be enough money for people to
live on and
why the uk government have continued to
call it a living wage it is a minimum
wage it is a minimum wage rebranded as a
pretendy living wage because you cannot
afford to live on it and we can see that
we can see that by the fact that child
poverty action group have said that 72
of families with children struggling to
afford food at least one parent works if
work pays if this government is
committed to making work pay those
people would not be going to food banks
those people would not be in poverty
while working those people would not be
having to have so many jobs
in zero hour contracts numbers of jobs
where and because they're um on having
so many jobs that are so low paid they
don't meet the thresholds for things
like auto enrollment they don't meet the
threshold for statutory sick pay they
don't get any of the benefits that you
should get with work because the work is
not there and the work is not paying the
level of stress and pain and mental
health suffering that this is causing
people if if the uk government wants to
put employers first if it decides that
employers should be ahead of employees
then surely they should recognize that
employees having no money and living
with that level of stress makes them
worse employees if that is the key thing
the uk government should be trying their
best to improve lives for employees they
should be trying their best to make sure
that work actually pays we would like to
see flexible working requests available
from day one the uk government have
promised to look at that the uk
government 29 months ago said that they
would look at neonatal leave and pay
where is this they said they would look
at making flexible work in the default
29 months ago 29 months and nothing has
happened there is nothing in the queen's
speech about this they said 43 months
ago that they would like tips to go to
workers in full where's the legislation
they said 54 months ago that they would
evaluate shared parental leave 54 months
we have been waiting for uk government
action on this and they have failed and
failed again and failed this week in the
queen's speech
they have said that they are wanting to
look at um
redundancy protections uh for women that
has been mentioned um by the deputy
leader of the the labour party and in a
very very good speech that i agreed with
the vast majority of and we need to see
new mums being given the protection we
need to see that happen having been made
redundant when i was pregnant i know
how painful and difficult that situation
is but we need to see those protections
in place for new mums the reality is
that the lack of action by this
government has enshrined the
inequalities that there are has
continued to mean that that gender pay
gap will grow has continued to mean that
the pension gender gap will grow because
people because women are more likely to
be on those low paid low hours number of
different jobs and not be put into auto
enrollment the uk government is making
things worse for this generation of
workers for future generations of
pensioners as well as for current
generations of pensioners we saw um some
action in the queen's speech in relation
to fire and rehire about um specifically
about seafloors not actually in relation
to
iron rehab but in relation to um the p o
issues that there have been um
although i welcome the bill i'm glad
that there is action being taken around
low pay for seafarers it's not a bill
for seafarers it's a bill for ferry
seafarers it only covers those people
that work on ferries it is not any
broader than that and representing a
port in my constituency i'm very keen to
hear the government explain how they are
going to indemnify ports who are having
to take action against these
large boats and large companies how is
the government going to ensure that
those ports are not put at risk and by
the action that they should be taking i
agree that action should be taken but i
don't want this to land in the lap of
the ports and for them to be left
holding all of the responsibility here
is the uk government that should be
taking action to press for changes in
maritime law to ensure that everybody
that is in a boat in a ship um within
our seas is being paid a living wage not
just those people who are on uk flag
boats
we are five years on madame deputy
speaker from the taylor review we're
five years on from the uk government
why did they bother doing the taylor
review what was the point in all of the
money and all of the time and all of the
hard work that went into the taylor
review because nothing has happened
nothing has come of this review nothing
has um changed for people who are
working in the gig economy nothing has
changed for people who are working in in
companies where they're pretending to be
self-employed these changes have not
been made people are still living with
that level of uncertainty that the
deputy leader of the labour party um
mentioned with that level of getting
texts the night before saying your
shift's been cancelled or or you're
suddenly being given an extra shift and
you've somehow got to find child care to
cover that they're still living with
that and they're still living with that
without the benefits of having a pension
of having sick pay of having all of
those things that workers should have
that workers should have in order to be
able to
live
lives and not just live to work we all
should be aspiring for our constituents
to be able to live
enjoy living and have fair work
that they can go to and i want to
mention madame david speaker the um
brexit freedoms bill the brexit freedoms
bill which has got a very hilarious name
um is about
taking back control which is quite
ironic taking back control to the uk
government taking back control away from
parliament taking back control from
having things in primary legislation
moving it to secondary legislation
ensuring that the uk government can do
what it wants in order to remove the
protections that have been put in place
by eu law the only reason
that we have got the level of workers
rights that we have the tories have been
saved that we have been saved from
tory's untrammeled reductions in workers
rights is because of eu law the brexit
freedoms bill will undo that it will
allow them the absolute power to do what
they like with our workers rights
to um to i don't know um ensure that
employers are put first rather than
employees at every possible opportunity
the government must absolutely commit
not to roll back workers not that it'll
mean anything if they do say it but you
know um it would be useful for us to be
able to repeat it back to them um to
commit that they're not going to reduce
workers right so they're actually going
to increase the protections that there
are in place for workers the promises
that they've made need to actually come
through
madame deputy speaker
we have been asking
for years
for employment law to be devolved i
would love for the labour party to back
us in this call if they don't back us in
this call it feels a bit like they're
quite willing to you know just just let
us sync with the rest of britain it
would be very nice for the scottish
parliament to have control of it because
we could make a positive difference to
workers in scotland even though we've
got a tory government even though we've
got tory government the labour party are
failing they are letting down workers in
scotland by failing to call for
employment law to be devolved we have
made these cases we've made these cases
on behalf of our constituents we've made
these cases on behalf of the people of
scotland we want employment law to be
developed the longer that this tory
government continues to refuse to
devolve employment law the longer that
they continue to dismantle the
protections that there are in place for
workers the longer that they stand on
television and say things like all
people are using food banks because they
can't budget or people should just work
a few more hours and that'll be great
that'll reduce the amount for the need
for them to
have the 20 pounds universal credit
uplift that there is in place the longer
that they continue to refuse to increase
benefits and buy anything close to
inflation scottish government has
increased benefits by almost double what
the uk government has increased them by
this year the scottish government's got
a child poverty action plan in place the
longer that the conservatives continue
this the stronger the case they are
making for independence the stronger the
case for the scottish people who can see
the two governments working on their
behalf who can see scottish government
enshrining fair work
and principles in every single thing
that we do who can see the scottish
government putting well-being putting
well-being of the population first
in every single thing we can do and can
see the tories doing everything that
they can to dismantle those protections
to reduce social security in real terms
to ensure that people don't have enough
money to live on failing to step up to
solve the energy crisis the case for
independence is getting ever stronger
madame deputy speaker and the
conservatives continued failure
is making the reality of independence
much closer every single day
thank you madam deputy speaker
this queen's speech is all about driving
growth in our economy and
although the honourable lady speaker or
the right honourable lady speaking for
the labour party may uh disagree in her
speech
that is what is best for working people
throughout the united kingdom because a
strong economy will give us secured jobs
will give us good wages and will give us
most overall
certainty for the future and i would uh
perhaps suggest to the honourable lady
speaking for the
scottish nationalist party is that when
it comes to wellbeing it being certainty
is something which is incredibly
important as well and having a strong
economy as the government is focused on
is at the heart of that but for too long
economic the economic powerhouse of the
uk has been focused on an extremely
small part of our country the south east
of england and london
and the government's leveling up mission
directly addresses this problem
uh today we've seen faster recovery
being announced in the uk uh compared
with the uh us and germany and italy but
we've got to make sure that that
recovery spreads beyond a very small
part of our recovery recover
of our geography because the cost of
living rises that have been referred to
in many speeches today affect everyone
and the government needs to
make sure that when it comes to
solutions those solutions are going to
reach everybody too now i would suggest
the government needs to heed the words
of my right honourable friend the member
for north somerset very heavily indeed
because he's right that one of the
levers that they can pull in their
response to the challenges that we face
is
around inflation and it is very much
within the government's gift to be able
to make those changes to bring inflation
more under control and i think by
looking at different countries around
europe and seeing the different
levels of inflation you can see how uh
the fiscal responses that governments
have given have driven those changes uh
inherently but the cost of living uh
problems that we are struggling with at
the moment um need to come first and
foremost into the eyes of every minister
regardless of their department i i think
the flagship bill of this queen's speech
the regeneration leveling up and
regeneration bill
um is also quite fundamental to
conservative values because it's all
about giving the opportunity to succeed
to to everybody regardless of where they
live regardless of what geography they
are
in and to spread more evenly the
prosperity of our country um is is is
crucial to our future now it isn't a new
challenge madame deputy speaker and and
i have to gently say to my on my writing
friend the minister that regional policy
has a chequered history in this country
and we need to make sure that as within
the as the bill sets out we need a
regular monitoring of the effectiveness
of leveling up now my constituency
basing stoke has been put there as one
of the 10
top 10 most leveled up boroughs in the
country and that's because we have
excellent local government in our
borough council and our county council
and we've had significant investment in
our local infrastructure our roads have
had more than 80 million pounds invested
school places have been expanded and we
have very high levels of employment but
i want more places in our country to be
like my constituency and i hope that
this bill will help that to happen and
it isn't just with uh with that you know
positive sense of wanting to
support other constituencies around the
country it's about self-interest too
because we cannot continue to over focus
the growth of our country into such a
small geography beijing stoke has built
four times more houses
over the last 40 years than other
communities across our country this
can't continue we're being asked to
build another 20 000 houses almost 20
000 houses in our next local plan
because algorithms actually punish
people who have been successful
in building new homes and and that can't
be right we need to shift growth and i
think if the government's really going
to
achieve leveling up it can't allow the
southeast to continue to be this hot
house of house building of house
building they have to make a change and
i think they need to direct planning
inspectors
to more closely look at
the challenges that over-developed areas
like mine face so that we can
deal with issues like community cohesion
which we simply don't have the time to
deal with when we're building so many
houses
but leveling up madame deputy speaker i
think the government has to appreciate
is far more than geography and indeed
fundamental to conservative values that
we give everyone the opportunity
opportunity to succeed not only because
of where they're born but also
regardless of what their parents their
gender or their disability um and i'd
just like to gently point out to my
writer more friend the minister that um
the conversations around the employment
bill cannot be dismissed there are a
number of issues
that the government understands have
been labor market failures in this
country around maternity discrimination
around the misuse of non-disclosure
agreements um indeed about the
importance of flexible working in
increasing our productivity
and the importance of unpaid carers
leave as my right honourable friend the
member for gospel talked about um
unpaid carers leave being central to our
adult social care policies but also
parental leave as well these are all
things which the government knows
through its own research are important
labour market failures that need to be
addressed um and and i need the
government to sort of set out how
they're going to be dealt with in the
absence of an employment bill
madam deputy speaker this debate is also
about stronger communities and one way
that we can strengthen our communities
is by strengthening our education system
too
and i was delighted to see that we have
within this queen speech a schools bill
and i welcome the focus on raising
standards and also specific things like
having home school children being part
of a register so that we can make sure
that every child in this country we know
that they're being cared for correctly
but could i also suggest the government
needs to take a a look again at the way
in which relationship and sex education
is being rolled out because it became
everybody's concern a few a year or so
ago when everyone's invited was a front
page news item that the culture of
sexual abuse among school-aged children
was something we were all concerned
about i i found it curious that the
government asked ofsted who are
responsible for the rollout of
relationship and sex education in our
schools to um actually investigate this
problem because indeed they should have
been monitoring the rollout of
relationships and sex education which
according to many has been much slower
and less successful than it should have
been because despite being law for three
years
uh just one in three young people in our
country have learned about how to tell
if a relationship is healthy on
including online and just one in three
have have learned about the harm of
pornography now the minister needs to
consider how we review ofsted's
effectiveness in monitoring this rollout
and whether indeed others should be
involved in that given the current
the current failures in that direction
i'm also delighted to see a draft
victims bill in the
in the queen's speech as well and i
particularly hope that recognition will
be given to the way in which the online
safety bill will be increasing the
number of victims that will be
in the
in the justice system or indeed just
outside of it and given that seismic
increase in the number of victims
we need to look for ways of ensuring
there is funding there
perhaps on a polluter pay principle from
social media companies to be able to pay
for that additional support that's
needed
i also very much welcome the modern day
slavery bill which addresses one of the
uh weaknesses of the current system uh
it inc the bill proposes to increase the
accountability of companies and
organizations driving
modern-day slavery out of supply chains
and that was one of the key
recommendations in the report that the
government commissioned from myself and
lord frank field and the noble baroness
elizabeth butler sloth when we um when
we reviewed the app three years ago in
conclusion madame deputy speaker
i very much welcome the queen's speech
bill i very much welcome the
government's focus on levelling up but
make sure that we don't
limit our ambitions by focusing in on
levelling up
around the geography of the united
kingdom you know we level up for britain
and northern ireland if we treat
everyone fairly we give everyone
opportunity to succeed regardless of
their gender their disability their
parentage or whether or not their
parents or single people and i welcome
the measures in the queen's speech but
the government needs to carefully
consider how it can deliver on the
important changes in the workplace that
my writing friend and i have spoken
about for many many months
tag pets thank you
speaker
i'm this week i want people obviously to
con
contribute about the
leveling up and regeneration build as
mentioned in speech has now been
produced and measures on social housing
which the select committee have been
very much dealing with in recent months
but first of all as a constituency mp
you know where are the measures in here
to address the cost of living crisis
that are affecting all our constituents
and again when we talk about leveling up
it's those in the greatest poverty those
who were struggling before energy bills
rose who are struggling even more now
and they look quite frankly at the
eye-watering profits announced in recent
days by bp and shell and wonder why we
aren't taxing their super profits to
help cushion the effect of rising prices
on their their bills and their
households uh the government really
hasn't given an adequate answer to that
coming back now to the uh leveling up
issues
to major concerns
first of all where's the money it's been
a challenge right the way through if
you're about leveling up you're about
leveling up government spending across
the piece
pots of money
leveling up pots high street pots
town pots are not themselves going to
make any real difference particularly in
the context of the massive cuts in local
government funding that the poorest
areas that need leveling up have seen
in the last 10 years in any case
the second state sort of got that
message
the uh minister the
member for market harbor got it when he
came to the select committee um
andy holding got it even further he
basically said we shouldn't have these
individual pots of money what we need is
proper resources proper budgets given to
our mayors combined authorities and
local authorities to spend according to
the needs of their area but i say to the
minister what does leveling up really
mean in financial terms what does it
mean
does it mean that the chancellor's got
an extra sum of money that is going to
announce
to enable the money to be spent in our
poorer areas to be brought up to those
of the richer parts of the country uh or
one particular example uh when we've
looked at the bus situation in south
yorkshire i see the only member for
barnsley uh here in his place and until
recently was of course the mayor of the
chevy city region now uh renamed south
yorkshire and i thank him for the
excellent work he's done in the last
four years on behalf of the region and
my constituents in particular but he
knows that the amount of money uh spent
on bus services is about ten times uh
per head of population in london than it
is in south yorkshire
we've got the powers
to run our bus service in the same way
but not the money and i say to the
minister either it's about a an extra
sum of money the chance is going to find
or it's rediverting money from the
richer areas to the poorer parts of the
country it has to be one or the other
how can you level up and get equality of
funding unless you either find
additional funding to bring the poorer
areas up or you transfer money from the
richer areas to the poores has to be one
or the other which is the government
going to do it currently it is really
doing neither secondly i ask about the
powers
i asked the minister earlier uh who
introduced the debate what additional
powers were in the bill uh to level up
and and give more authority to combat
authorities to mayors and to individual
local authorities he couldn't answer the
question because actually there isn't an
answer now i can't claim to have read
every single clause of the 196 in the
bill and the 17 schedules but i can't
find any mention of extra powers if i
mention of other areas which currently
haven't got combined authorities digley
county areas getting them in the future
that's welcome but i can't actually find
any additional powers the selection is
to be much more erratic what we've said
is let's look at the other way around
shouldn't all decisions be made at local
level and this is a good reason for
making them at national level when the
minister came to the select committee he
said that was a bit radical well it is
but i actually think we need a very
radical solution to deal with the fact
we're one of the most over centralized
countries uh
in in in western europe that's the
reality of the situation but there
really isn't any fundamental change
there uh to alter that and that's
something i'm sure we'll be coming back
for uh to as a committee and pressing on
planning uh ma'am that speaker uh there
was gonna be a major planning reform
wasn't there a few months ago and the
previous secretary of state announced it
uh he's going to tear up the planning
rules and start again well it's now come
to a few clauses
involved i'm not dismissing that because
i think there's actually some quite good
potential proposals in there well as a
select commission well well they are
quite good because i think the
government's come down to the view the
select committee took so that's why
they're probably quite helpful
uh right but first of all so we we've
got rid of the uh
of the three zones which are never going
to be possible to reroute every local
clan in 30 months
we've got away from that situation i
think i think we've moved to a situation
where we're going to have slim simpler
processes for local plans
and i think that's welcome we've got to
look at the detail and how they work
through to digitize them and that's
helpful and i think as well in clause 50
and clause 60
we've got to a point where in on
individual planning applications the
local plan is going to be given greater
weight and i think that's helpful as
well a degree of certainty for
communities and for developers both are
important
but what we've got to do is to get more
of the public engaged in the local plan
process so it actually means something
because currently people tend to get
engaged once a planning application
comes in for a site near them we've got
to change that and get the community to
look at where houses should be built
where other development should take
place in the area as a whole through a
local plan
and that doesn't mean helping
authorities who are being stripped of
resources in their planning departments
to
undertake more work in getting all local
plants up to date and in place
in the next couple of years i say i'm
generally not in favor of ring fence
grants but i think there is a case here
for having a one-off grant to planning
authorities to enable them to do a real
job now on getting local plans up to
date and getting their community engaged
in them to take some of the heat and
some of the contention out of the
planning process but there are a couple
of issues of slight disappointment um
one
and the other member for north somerset
mentioned it
around
the issue of build out
why are the government not taking
measures in this bill to ensure that
those who get planning permissions and
there are hundreds of thousands of them
around the country and then don't build
the houses they got permission for why
aren't we penalize them for that
ministers have argued the case for that
in the past but there's nothing in the
bill to do it why not we had the leopard
report years ago which recommended
something like this it still hasn't been
done and the thing i would say is when
we began on planning reforms with the
previous secretary state the whole idea
was to build more homes
uh that was said the planning system was
holding everything up well i think build
out is a key issue there the government
haven't addressed but where is the
hundred three hundred thousand homes a
year target gone
by the end of this parliament that was
the government's target now would the
minister like to say whether it's still
the government target to build 300 000
homes a year by the end of this
parliament yeah it seems to have fallen
off the agenda and that's really
disappointing because we do have a
housing crisis in this country to be uh
to be again complimentary to the
government i think they have listened
about the whole problem of compulsory
purchase that local authorities have
been complaining about the the very
difficult process they have to go
through and if we are going to see real
regeneration and redevelopment of our
city centers as the demand for retail
floor space drops then we're going to
need easier compulsory purchase powers i
think they're there in the act i don't
know all the details of them but at
least the government seems to have
listened and taken that seriously and
that's to be uh welcomed
as well
just finally at mundusby on social
housing welcome the the improvements to
the regulation to go because we haven't
seen all the clauses and the the
minister is coming to the select
committee on monday to talk further
about that as a committee we have seen
unheard of some appalling examples of
really awful conditions that some social
housing tenants are are living in and
the housing ombudsman has done some
excellent work around mold and dampness
in homes which every local authority
should be taking account of what i would
say is yes there's been in the past and
the grenfell inquiry has highlighted
this an attitude of social housing but
somehow they're second-class tenants in
second-class housing and we've got to do
everything we can to improve the
standard of housing but also
the idea that people didn't really want
to be social housing tenants did they so
we wouldn't build any more council
houses and housing association
properties i'm pleased the secretary of
state the other day said he wanted to
see more social housing built but again
where's the money where is the money the
government's going to have to put more
granting to get the social housing built
and if we're going to build the 300 000
homes we talked about at least 90 000 of
those probably more are going to happen
with social housing and we are nowhere
near that and i just say in passing i
hope the changes to the infrastructure
levy in the bill do not mean a reduction
in the number of social houses but by
developers with the ending of 106
agreements so that's another challenge
as well
and finally i'll say
speaker uh on uh private renting welcome
the government's commitment
yes okay we can be disappointed we
haven't actually got a commitment to
produce legislation i would have hoped
for at least a draft bill it is
complicated this issue we've got to get
it right particularly we've got to get
right the fact that landlords can't use
rent increase as a way of getting
forcing tenants out when they haven't
got station 21 powers to rely on but
also one thing we pressed was a select
committee the government hasn't
committed to and that's the idea of a
housing court a housing court for a
simplified procedure to help both the
good landlords and the good tenants the
good tenants where they're being
harassed by bad landlords and the good
landlords where their back tenants won't
pay the rent in both cases to have a
simplified way to getting redress and i
would hope the government might look at
that again so madame dr speaker uh yeah
overall um real problems on the cost of
living which simply isn't dealt with by
the government on leveling up and
regeneration i just say where are the
powers and where are the money yes some
good details in there which you want to
work through with the government on on
planning and cpo and social housing
regulation but still many challenges
that aren't addressed
in the queen speech that we'll need to
come back to
mr christopher chu
madam deputy speaker it's a pleasure to
follow the right honourable gentleman
and can i say i agree with him about one
thing and that is that the government
needs to show a lot more conviction in
expressing its opposition to windfall
taxes
they are a simplistic solution which
always end up hurting the ordinary
people who work in this population
hardest so
i'm against a full taxes and if i've got
time i will say a little bit more about
that later but
who madam deputy speaker would dare to
criticize the content of the humble
address delivered in her majesty's
platinum jubilee year
i'm certainly not going to criticize the
the humble address but i i would like to
begin uh by drawing attention to some
omissions of from it
which i uh
one of which i've referred to in an
article uh which is carried in today's
um
conservative home
it's headed up
harm from coveted vaccinations
don't leave victims behind
and it's a reference to the need for
changes to be made to the vaccine damage
payments scheme
currently the maximum payment under that
scheme is 120 000 pounds
that hasn't been increased since 2007.
by way of comparison my honourable
friend on the front bench will know this
that industrial injuries disablement
benefit
in that same period has gone up by 39
when i discussed this with the minister
for vaccines and public health
she indicated that she took the point
and understand understood that something
needed to be done i hope that in
responding to this debate uh my right
honourable friend or my boyfriend will
be able to say what is going to be done
and why the government believes it's
fair
uh that
this uh level of 120 000 pounds should
continue to remain unchanged uh since
2007.
and can i also say that
the newly formed vaccine injured
bereaved uk organization vib dot uk
which has been formed
in the last few days is also calling for
much wider changes to the vaccine damage
payment scheme which i think are
absolutely correct and in the articles
which i've already referred i explain
why i very much support
their suggestions for fundamental reform
of the scheme to make it more relevant
and flexible to the plight of those who
have suffered as a result of doing the
right thing and becoming vaccinated i
give way to the ongoing lady i've
unfortunately missed the article this
morning but i will be sure to read it
would he agree that one of the biggest
issues with the scheme is the length of
time that it takes for decisions to be
made people are waiting a significant
length of time even to get an initial
contact with the vdps would he agree
that that's one of the key things that
needs fixed
absolutely and indeed i've been
campaigning since i first raised this in
the house last september for changes and
in the article i refer to the fact that
the
meeting i had with the minister on the
21st of april at that meeting she told
me that at last a an organization has
been appointed to carry out the
administrative job of assessing the
claims they're now
i think over 1300 claims and the first
assessments have not even begun and they
but they will now begin i'm told on the
16th of may
and the new organization which has got
that contract is committed to dealing
with 1
800
such assessments each year which is an
indication madam deputy speaker of the
extent of this uh problem but as the
honourable lady absolutely rightly says
it's appalling that we've had to wait
for so long and it was only
last autumn that the prime minister was
assuring uh a a constituent
a correspondence with him that uh people
who had suffered vaccine damage
shouldn't be ignored and suffer in
silence so i i'm very much with the
honourable lady on that on that point
and i i commend again the article uh to
her another significant omission uh from
the uh the the lol address is any
reference to the promise changes from
rpi to cpi in the measure of calculating
the maximum annual increase in charges
for pitch fees for park home residents
this is an issue
which is just my heart i've been
chairman of the appg on park homes for
many years and the government has got
outstanding overdue business not just on
that aspect but also on dealing with the
issue of rogue
operators operating in that in that
field
can i
uh
also say that
when i was first elected in christchurch
25 years ago madam deputy speaker i
would never have been able to
contemplate that there will be have a
conservative government presiding over
the highest levels of taxation in a
generation and with inflation raging at
10 percent
i note from the law address that the
government will drive economic growth
to
improve living standards and i hope that
i'm right in concluding from that that
the government is not going to
have any further
tax increases
yet there's talk even from some of my
conservative colleagues about
new tax increases so-called windfall
taxes describing attacks as a windfall
tax doesn't make it any less of a tax
and i'm concerned that the government
still seems to be flirting with the idea
of ever higher taxes despite all the
evidence that windfall taxes would be a
further uh disaster
i will i will give way to the
honourable gentleman would know that
i've been in the house rather longer
than him and of course i do remember
when the first windfall tax was
introduced by
that prime minister conservative prime
minister
margaret thatcher and she made very good
use of a windfall tax on the banks and
made a very big profit and it which i
thought a very good innovation what's
wrong with factorism these days
well
well
as in with so many things about saturism
the labour party came along and tried to
copy it and when gordon brown when
gordon brown introduced a windfall tax
it was such a disaster that ever since
then
governments have decided that the
windfall taxes are a very bad
idea the justification for that windfall
tax and i wasn't in the house at the
time was that the government had pushed
up uh interest rates and in response to
rising inflation and that therefore
there was a windfall benefit that the
banks had received those arguments are
nothing like the arguments which are
prevailing at the moment where what we
need to do is we need to encourage
our oil and gas industry to invest
rather than to disinvest
in our economy and the point i would
make is that
instead of windfall taxes the government
should be talking about paying back to
the taxpayers some of the windfall
receipts of tax revenue madam deputy
speaker vat receipts are now expected to
be 47 billion pounds in the coming year
9 billion pounds more than predicted so
the case for removing vat on energy
bills completely and scrapping green
levees on energy bills is i think uh
overwhelming and could be financed from
the windfall
receipts
and can i also say that i i'm concerned
that throughout this debate there has
not been a sufficient reference or we
need hardly any reference to the issue
of
productivity that is that's absolutely
fundamental if we're going to get the
economic growth we we need but can i
congratulate the government on
it seems being on the threshold of
completing a brexit uh resolving the
issue of the northern ireland uh
protocol ensuring that all those
restrictive practices in which we
continue to sign up to after we left the
european union can be
removed and if this government is able
to finally deliver the full brexit it
will have my full support yeah
given mcdonough thank you
speaker for 30 years countdown susie
dent has admirably been the country's
dictionary and thesaurus expert
when searching for a missing word there
can be no more reliable source
and it was thanks to susie that i
recently discovered the word
snollygoster
not a character from harry potter but
rather an unprincipled person in office
motivated by personal rather than public
gain
imagine making it to downing street to
then spend your time doing anything to
dip to clutch onto power
rather than using your privileged
position to change the lives of others
out in the real world and families are
desperately worried about the cost of
living crisis and how they can possibly
stretch their salary to the next payday
they turned on the news this week to
hope that help was on the way
but madam deputy speaker
it isn't
it is the duty of a government to find
ways to help like introducing a one-off
windfall tax to those oil and gas
producers who have unashamedly declared
that they have more money than they know
what to do with
instead the prime minister focuses it on
his work on smearing his opponents
planting dead cat distractions and
proposing policies designed not to solve
problems but to sow division to make
people point at this chamber and say
we are all the same
but this is no game
around one in seven adults live in homes
where people have skipped meals reduced
real salt meal sizes or gone hungry
and that's before inflation rises even
further and energy costs seem sore even
higher in october
far from the days of dream without
intervention things can only get worse
as ever i listen particularly closely to
the housing announcements in the queen's
speech they were surprisingly prominent
but as always the devil is in the detail
despite
1.15 million households on social
housing waiting lists across our country
the secretary of state announced
yesterday
between his ridiculous impressions that
the government's manifesto commitment of
300 000 new homes per year has been
scrapped
fast forward 24 hours and number 10 says
that's not the case
so can i ask the minister to put on
record today
whether the target still stands
a cynic might link any scrapping of the
house building target with a scale of
the government's failure on this issue
with just five thousand nine hundred and
fifty five new social rent homes last
year
one of the lowest numbers on record and
at that rate it will take
192 years to house everyone on today's
waiting list
where's the ambition where is the
political well
house building commitments aside i i was
reassured to finally read of progress
from social housing tenants who are
living in disrepair battling endless
hurdles in their fight for a safe and
habitable place to live
last year my constituent quajo twinner
bower bravely partnered with journalist
daniel hewitt and itv news who reported
on the appalling conditions in which
quajo his neighbors and thousands upon
thousands of social housing tenants were
living i'm extraordinarily
extraordinarily grateful for all
involved in their determined pursuit of
progress
as it stands to make a complaint and see
it through to its conclusion
a social housing tenant requires the
patience of a saint
the tenacity of a five-star general an
endless amount of phone data a laptop to
email and a postgraduate degree in
bureaucracy
it is a world regulated by an authority
that does not even have the power to
inspect a property
or speak to a resident
all thanks to the coalition government
who completely abolished the audit
commission and the housing inspectorate
under the bonfire of the quangos so that
we all now need to talk about
reinventuring the wheel a decade on
but i am relieved that the government
has finally seen the error of its weight
a strengthened regulator does not build
a single new home but it is an important
step in finally giving a voice to some
of the most vulnerable people in our
communities
final finally madam deputy speaker
workers rights
20 times ministers promised to deliver
an employment bill to enhance workers
rights but there must have been a page
missing in the queen's speech because i
could not find a word to turn this
rhetoric into reality
just weeks ago the government told us
how shocked they were at what happened
at
piano and how this must have not happen
again
but it will
the bill's omission is all the evidence
needed so at the importance with which
the government considers this issue
because until this practice is banned
once and for all
fire and rehire will continue to be the
model template for the biggest
organizations to restructure and save
funds
it's completely naive to think otherwise
the next scandal is just around the
corner and the absence of an employment
bill plants the responsibility clearly
at the feet of this government
i draw to a close with one final word
from susie dense dictionary
perendiamate
which is the marking of time by
continually putting something off until
the day after tomorrow
but the reality for all those in
insecure work
desperately waiting on social housing
lists or choosing between heating and
eating
they simply cannot wait that long
richard drax
speaker can i return you to the
registered members interest
madam deputy speaker i welcome the
queen's speech which is a timely
intervention if ever there was one
apathy
last thursday is a warning
that many of our voters see us
rudderless and lacking ambition and
vision
it's a shame
after you led the world in fighting the
pandemic and leave the support for a
battered ukraine
i commend the prime minister for both
it was an extraordinary coincidence that
on the day all restrictions were lifted
on the 24th of february russia invaded
ukraine
since then
the world has faced soaring costs
shrinking revenues and shaky alliances
with fuel and food shortages threatening
global stability
what concerns me is that while we defend
freedom and aim for recovery
our nation struggles with ever weakening
institutions
toxic cultural wars
and citizens struggling with the
consequences of a cost of living crisis
the future
seems less certain now
our economy blighted by kobed and
lockdowns is not reignited igniting as
fast as we would like
unbelievably we the conservative party
are presiding over the steepest taxes
since the 1940s
and the highest sustained spending
levels since the 1970s
this is not
the conservative way
nor is it the way to cope with the
stumbling economy
high taxes
stifle enterprise aspiration and as
we've heard from my right old friend
productivity
and risk low growth stagnation and
unemployment
this week the bank of england warned of
impending recession and 10
interest rates driven by higher energy
prices
these are difficult times
but every cloud has a silver lining and
as conservatives this is the time to be
radical
to return to our vote-winning philosophy
of less state low taxes and sound public
finances yeah
if ever there was a time to loosen the
screws this is it and the prime minister
knows it
he said and i quote
this moment makes clear our best remedy
lies in urgently delivering on our
mission to turbo charge the economy
create jobs and spread opportunity
across the country
here here i say
so let's get on with it prime minister
the chancellor of course must fulfill
his role
the promised tax cuts in two years will
be too little
too late
we'll have lost the electorate who
burdened by high taxes and debt will
turn to a ruinous socialist government
one possibly in coalition with the snp
the ultimate nightmare scenario
i accept that legislation on its own
cannot solve the cost of living crisis
which to a large extent has been caused
by events outside the government's
control
but we do have the power to cancel the
increase in national insurance
remove the at from domestic fuel and
reduce fuel duty even further the power
to control our own economy is one of the
major reasons i back brexit
when i'm generally designed by measures
in the queen's speech to at last fully
exploit our newfound freedom
i have to say about time too
as hardcore remainers are still out
there only too eager to highlight any
difficulty we face
and while on the subject of the eu
despite the lack of a specific bill
i'm glad to hear the government will
prioritize support for the good friday
agreement and its institutions
and unless the eu compromises further we
must rewrite the northern irish protocol
to ensure that northern ireland is
genuinely and unquestionably back
in the united kingdom
the current system is not working and
endangers all that so many have worked
hard to achieve namely peace and
prosperity
i'm also relieved i think that's the
right word to at last see a bill that
aims to conclude the appalling witch
hunt of our northern ireland veterans
i don't want to commit myself any
further at this stage as the devil will
be in the detailed melon deputy speaker
while on our armed forces i be failing
in my duty not to once again warn the
government against impending cuts to the
army
regrettably ministers appear persuaded
that ukraine's success against
overwhelming odds proves what a small
flexible and maneuverable army can
achieve on the battlefield
fortunately the russians have shown how
inept they are at combined operations
and this is a false comparison
i'm told that mass is no longer
necessary
well an army of 82 000 is not massive
madame dope speaker
and for sustained operations against a
peer anniversary and god forbid what
happens or what we face in the future
numbers will count in any future
conflict
can i return
to the direction of the government's
trouble
the government's advisor said and i
quote it's time to scrape the barnacles
off the boat
and here i
have some sympathy but the opposition
benches on the lack of an employment
bill but i would just say
as an employer myself
we are already riven with legislation
from top to bottom
and their danger of imposing more is to
disincentivize
employment rather than encouraging while
quite accepting that employees should
have rights of course they should
and on one issue
flexible working
yes
if it works for the employer
the employee should be allowed to work
flexibly but it shouldn't be a right
that's all we hear so often from the
other side right right right right what
about responsibility
it is the employer who takes the risk
to employ someone to give them a life
chance a career and a salary
not the employee
so a balance should be adopted not
necessarily so much weight on one side
will you forgive me i wait because i can
apply one there are a lot of people want
to speak and i haven't got much longer
left if she will forgive me
on to the housing
situation and my writing friend from
north somerset spoke such
sense
the bill to ensure locals have more of a
say is to be welcomed i i really
am backing that
far more imagination
less density more green space and
supporting infrastructure is needed in
the planning system it is failing every
single time
and affordable homes must be affordable
i have seen examples
where developers have really gone to
take the care to build affordable
friendly
safe warm homes that look nice
all too often sadly i see larger
developers building homes that seem to
fall apart within a year
this has to be changed
the nhs there was no
mention of the nhs but as i've said
repeatedly
i do believe the nhs while it serves as
well
and i wish it to continue it does need
to be overhauled and as aster heath
points out in the recent telegraph
article he wrote which i thought was
very good
he said all reform is stymied by the lie
that any improvement is privatization by
self it is it is simply not and i'm
delighted that protesters are finally
going to be challenged from gluing
themselves to each other or roads or
anything else they can find to stop
people from going about their daily
lives jobs and medical appointments or
whatever they want to do i'm delighted
last that bill has come forward
there's much to welcome and let me just
conclude
so far as the number of bills is
concerned this point's been picked up i
don't necessarily believe that a huge
number of bills is always the right
thing to have
and my father was a great believer in
less is more it's the significance of
the bill what it delivers rather than
the number
of them having said that i do support
many of the bills that have come forward
in the queen's speech but as i
lead my end by warning the government
that we must return to our traditional
conservative philosophy if we are going
to
turn the country around
regenerate the economy and importantly
win the next election
this means giving
people more of their own money
especially during hard times
and what happened to the singapore style
low tax economy that we boasted about we
hoped for we fought for and we're
looking to deliver which will create
the wealth prosperity and jobs that we
all need it's there for the taking now
and i urge the government to grab him
barry sherman
um can i
start my remarks by saying that uh um
i've been
reminded by my staff i'm
i'm sorry that they did this that that i
have been present at 42 queen speeches
this is the 42nd um but can i say how uh
concerned i am
is that the government this government
seems to be downgrading parliament all
the time i couldn't i can never remember
being in these debates without a
secretary of state being on the front
bench defending the queen's speech and
the elements within it and you know we
have seen this downgrading of parliament
consistently and persistently and as a
long-serving member it worries me very
much indeed but can i say in terms of
this quick speech it is deeply
disappointing
in so many things have been missed out
um i
just agreed with almost everything the
honourable the honourable gentleman
has just said from south dorset
except on one thing madam deputy speaker
i'm sure you would like some bipartisan
remarks and that is about uh our the
strength of our army i have stood up in
this chamber for a long time saying it
was dangerous to have an army
armed forces lower the 100 000
personnel we're now planning to go down
to 72 000 at a time where the world is a
very worrying place and i actually think
that we have to take that very very
seriously indeed
but can i say that it's what is missing
out of this quick space what worries me
so much one of the greatest challenges
we have is the
challenge of health
and
social care and we've been promised
haven't we a
firm government action to do something
about social care and i don't know what
i'm definitely speaking about your
constituency at doncaster but mining
huddersfield you know where one of the
real problems of the health sector is
people are taken in into a e taken into
a hospital but cannot be released
because it's nowhere suitable for them
living in supportive living in our
communities and have me nothing about
social care and in terms of a housing
bill nothing about building appropriate
housing for supported living that is a
very big miss in this queen's speech
can i also say that the other big myth
is um a moral mess the fact of the
matter all of us in politics know
that our country has been in terrible
trouble
our constituents have had a tough time
they've had coded they've had
years of austerity and now they've got
higher levels of energy costs heating
their home and paying for their food to
put to to to fill their children's and
and members of families atomize
that's the truth of it true traumatic
background and i was expecting a queen
speech that said this is a national
crisis let us get together and sort it
well i tell you deputy speaker what is
missing in this debate is the honesty
the honesty where we are promised lower
taxation
all of us know in our hearts that
somebody has got to pay to put this
country right to do all the things that
we want in health and health and social
care to rebuild the welfare state that
has been found wanting as we faced
kovitt where people shocked that in this
country one of the lowest countries for
paying
a a unemployment benefit
when you know people who would never
thought they would lose their jobs or be
made unemployed realize how
how weak the support was for their
family
in a second uh but also when i'm the
empty speaker i think that what is
missing this honestly about someone i
i i mix a lot of people that are earning
pretty good money
professional people with good salaries
they tell me we should be paying more
tax they say because we want a decent
society we want to pay more tax so can
we have put that on the record let's be
honest with you with with people and
let's say if we want a decent welfare
state if we want decent services if we
want decent local government then we
must be willing to pay for them
secondly madam deputy speaker i believe
two minutes um we've also demoralized so
many of the people on the front line i
don't want to use it in a kind of
military sense but the
people on the front line our health
workers our nurses and doctors our care
workers the people working in local
authorities who you know do everything
to make our local
society and local community viable
and and decent to live in they all have
felt undervalued they have all felt that
nobody really values what the service is
that they provide whether it's emptying
out bins or running the schools all the
things when local government had decent
resources they did and we believed that
that was the right thing to do
but not even deputy speaker so we were
expecting great things from this uh from
this queen's speech and we haven't got
them could i also turn to the fact that
where
where when we have an environment a
crisis when we have had cop 26 when
we've had aspiration to say the other
great challenge apart from health is our
environment
here we have a country where many of the
communities that we represent we are
poisoning children poisoning pregnant
women poisoning our constituents with a
filthy air that they breathe
nothing in this
queen's speech will meet that
that challenge
very little at all we do touch until
little
little reference in terms of a cleaner
transport system and speaker that is not
enough when we face global warming only
reminded yesterday climate change that
we will get this increased temperature
that which would eventually destroy life
on this planet nothing in this bill
doesn't exist there's no threat so
health and social care education madame
deputy speaker if we really i went to
the london school of economics i'm very
proud that i did both as an
undergraduate and as a postgraduate and
our motto was to understand the causes
of things and when i look at the causes
of
inequality in our country i immediately
look at education i immediately look at
levels of child poverty and i know that
when i work with tony blair's
government and with tony blair in terms
of that
1997 government where the
the only
the only uh time we can remember what
what the
the main thrust of the campaign was
education education education and we've
had a system where we know that if you
want to tackle underprivileged
poor
attainment at school poor attainment in
skills you have to invest in early
education in preschool in early school
for supporting families in literacy and
numeracy and using the english language
the fact of the matter is that that'll
be nothing in this bill
about if they'd be leveling up where is
the determination to bring back
uh child
children censors where is the
the
policy that we used to have in terms of
trying to make give every child a proper
chance uh in their lives it's not their
madame independent speaker it's an
appalling uh the missed opportunity and
it's also a time management speaker and
i don't want to
go on too long with my speech because
the fact of the matter is i i think
there's some positive things
we could have in this green speech and
we've seen some unity in terms of how
we've uh
face together across party covic and
we've had cross-party cooperation in
terms of support of ukraine thank
goodness
but surely there are things that we
could have done in this if we could have
agreed we need in this country 500
sustainable towns and cities based on
the united nations sustainable
development goals that would have lifted
us up it would have given people a
chance to roll up their sleeves and
change their environment not just on the
big global level but in their
communities locally that is what is
missing this you know this vision
passion and a wonderful commitment that
we have in some areas but this queen's
speech has failed to deliver on the
environment on education or aspiration
and i am very sad that that is the case
dean russell thank you madam deputy
speaker
if i may i'm going to just pause for a
moment and i hope members will join me
madam deputy speaker that was just five
seconds
but imagine if that had been an hour
a week
a month
where you had no one to speak to and no
one to listen to you
loneliness is one of the worst parts of
injustice within our society
and we have an opportunity
as a nation and as parliamentarians to
tackle this
during the first year of the pandemic
which was such an awful time it also
brought out a lot of light during that
darkness
i was very fortunate to go out and
campaign and work with local charities
including one vision where i am now a
trustee
uh
small acts of kindness the salvation
army and many others and i found in that
first year a rather bizarre situation
that i delivered more bags of shopping
to vulnerable people than i did
political leaflets but the reason why
that was so important is because it
wasn't just taking food to people
but it was when you were knocking on
somebody's door
it was that sense that they knew
somebody cared
and for me it was about feeding the soul
and feeding their spiritual needs as
much as it was feeding their stomachs
and i know for one i uh i certainly have
one to her to feed so um but what i
would say on that is that what i saw
during that time was communities getting
on and supporting each other helping
their neighbors looking up from their
phones and seeing the doors that perhaps
they hadn't seen neighbors behind
for a long time
and that action of being able to help
each other and support each other was so
important
but it wasn't just about community
acting on behalf of government or local
government it was a community acting on
behalf of itself and i think there's a
huge role and it was i was very pleased
within the queen's speech the talk of
trying to cut more red tape so that
there's more leveling up at a local
level but also to enable communities to
have more say in what they want to do
and where they work
and one of the big aspects of that was
around mental health i was pleased
earlier in in the opening speeches that
mental health first aid in the workplace
was raised i did a 10 minute rule bill
on that a year or two ago and it's
something i've continued to lobby on and
work with government on actually to make
sure that people within the workplace
can access people just like they could
for first aid if they cut their thumb
they can actually go and speak to
somebody signpost to the right
guidance and corrective information
correct information rather to be able to
tell them how to support themselves if
they're having mental well-being issues
or even mental health issues
the reason why i think that's so
important is because as we look at the
world post-pandemic it is so important
that we start to look at the holistic
view of a person their mental health and
their physical health
and that's why when we look at the
workplace we need to make sure that
there's justice there that there's
fairness there and that's why i've been
pushing
since last year with my tips bill to
make sure that people who work in
hospitality which is a big part of my
constituency in watford can access the
the tips that they're being given fairly
by uh by people who work with who want
to thank them and not allow businesses
to take that money from them and i'll
continue to push on that and i intend to
uh to push forward with a bill again
this year a post-queen speech
but what i saw within the hospitality
sector was the real important role that
creative services have within that as
well hospitality often you'll have bars
and restaurants part of theaters and in
watford we've got fabulous theater
called the pump house which is
celebrating its 50th year and you saw
within that the creativity and young
people being given hope being given the
opportunity to unleash unleash their own
skills and level up not just because
it's about planning and building but
actually about their own future and
their own opportunities and i saw that
myself when i was growing up as a as a
kid i never thought i'd visit london i i
didn't know definitely never thought i'd
visit parliament and
definitely didn't think i'd one day be
an mp and it's kids like me that i want
to reach out to and say you know what
wherever you live in the country there's
an opportunity for you to level up
there's an opportunity for you to
unleash your potential there's an
opportunity for you to inspire others
within your community and within that
that also means the built environment
and in watford we have lots of debates
about planning and how do we how do we
make sure that we don't have too much
over development and one of the concerns
i have at all buildings and i've been
very much pushing on this with
government that local people should have
a say in what happens in their community
within their street but especially
within the heights of buildings and i
was pleased in the queen's speech that
that's that seemed to be indicated that
there's going to be more say at street
level perhaps even street votes for
people to actually say this is what i
want within my area and what what's
happening on my street and beautiful
beautifully is very much part of that
and i think within that as well that's
about tackling real serious issues and
i'm very pleased that the minister of
homelessness actually on the front bench
because it's through the work with him
that in watford we've managed to get
rough sleeping during the past two years
pretty much down to zero now there's
always a need to continue to work on
people being supported but again we want
to not just get people off the streets
but give them opportunity make sure
they're not just surviving but thriving
as they look to the future and i think
this queen speech really does offer
opportunity with that
but within the built environment when we
look to the next generation we also
think about the virtual environment and
the online safety bill was something i
was very involved in last year as part
of the joint committee working across
party and across houses to really
scrutinize and come up with suggestions
and i believe the government took on
board i think 66 different suggestions
from the report we produced and i look
forward to seeing that bill pass through
parliament because we need to make sure
when we're thinking about mental health
we're thinking about exercise we're
thinking about how people work together
as a community we look at the way the
world is traveling and the world is
traveling in a much more virtual way a
technological way and when i look at
young kids now they're not like me 30 40
years ago
they they see the world in a totally
different way than i did it wasn't just
about the community on the road that
they see now they see the whole global
community and we need to make sure
people who want to do them harm are
stopped from doing so while still
enabling innovation and opportunity as
we move forward so i would just round up
to say that there's great opportunities
here i think as we look forward within
the bill there's there's great things
that are coming forward but i really
urge the government to push forward in
my tips bill because i think that's a
great opportunity to tackle cost of
living to help people on low incomes
actually get the money that they've been
given and deserve make sure that we push
forward with mental health first aid
awareness in the workplace to make sure
people within the workplace are
supported and signposted to the right
guidance and finally to make sure that
when we look at society we look at the
entirety of communities both within the
built environment within our
neighborhoods but also online so that
people are safe they aspire to to be the
best they can be and that this
government can support them in doing it
so i support this queen speech and thank
you madam deputy speaker
yeah griffith thank you very much indeed
fairness at work should be an absolute
basic right and i'm sorry if that
offends the member for south dorset
everyone should have a fair day's pay
for a fair day's work well the
honourable gentleman didn't wish to give
way to uh the colleague from the
scottish national party so you know
perhaps he can just you know um i'm
afraid not to have that opportunity
um everyone should have a fair day's pay
for a fair day's work that is simply not
happening in britain today far too many
people are working hard often taking on
more than one job and yet still they
simply cannot make ends meet they're
constantly worrying about how they will
provide for their families and pay the
next bill indeed often having to go
short on heating or eating
furthermore and clearly linked to low
wages is the scourge of insecurity at
work
in security because of the use of zero
hours contracts at work with no
guarantee of work each week and
therefore no guarantee of income
insecurity
because of the growth of the fire and
rehire culture where it seems that even
long-standing contracts with loyal
workers can be ripped up at a moment's
notice as we've seen in the appalling p
o scandal
madam deputy speaker fairness at work is
important not only for workers but also
for responsible business owners and
companies too
no one benefits from a race to the
bottom
good firms employers who are trying to
do the right thing
should not have to worry about being
undercut by rogue companies who cut
corners who depress wages who ride
roughshod over health and safety
good companies recognize that they
benefit from fairness at work a
workforce which is treated properly and
remunerated fairly and feels secure work
will be more productive and loyal which
is good for recruitment and retention
and as it's been highlighted by others
fairness at work also saves the public
purse whether it's in health care bills
or in social security bills
so
i'm absolutely appalled that this
government has not included any form of
employment bill in this green speech
time and time and time again we've had
these promises of an employment bill
we've heard the prime minister himself
purport to condemn fire and rehire
culture and yet even after the piano
finally hire scandal which should have
been a wake-up call we have nothing in
this green speech to address the many
issues of employment law
now this government is not only showing
utter contempt for workers in this
country but is actually out of step with
those employers who want to do the right
thing absolutely right now we've seen
businesses coming up to parliament
celebrating the fact they pay the real
living wage only a couple of weeks ago
mary portis was here with businesses who
were part of the better business act
campaign and again they were keen to say
how implementing fairness at work means
they have a happy loyal workforce
now when welsh government the welsh
labor government gives support to a
business it requires businesses not only
to demonstrate prospects for growth but
also a commitment to net zero to workers
rights and to workers mental health and
well-being
and it's very difficult i think in
opposition for people sometimes to
visualize some of the things that we
propose and one of the things that we
have mentioned is a better deal for
carers well the worst labour government
is actually implementing that it was a
welsh labour party manifesto commitment
in the election last year to make sure
that by the end of this seventh term all
care workers would be receiving the real
living wage that's a real living wage
which from april this year for care
workers is nine pounds 90 and it's
absolutely right that they should be
properly paid and it's also right that
we should value the people that they are
looking after
the work that carers do
they're looking after people people who
are elderly people who have particular
difficulties children and young people
what we pay care workers is a measure of
how we as a society regard and treat
those they care for
now this is not something you can just
do overnight it has to be properly
planned for so it can be budgeted for
and of course that's not easy at a time
when the welsh labor government has been
hit year after year by cumulative real
term cuts in budgets from this tory
government but nevertheless the welsh
labor government has set to work on this
straight away working with stakeholders
to work out how it can be brought about
and has made the money available from
last month
some care workers are employed directly
by the public sector
but where services are provided by
private or third sector providers then
the welsh government has flagged up that
those commissioning them namely the
local authorities and health boards will
need to build in an uplift accordingly
now i mentioned this to show what can be
done when there really is a will to do
it this is just one example of actually
putting into practice something which
makes people's lives better and is the
right thing to do and carefully planned
with the providers recognize the
additional costs on the public purse and
properly implemented it can be done and
done well
there's a real contrast then between
what our welsh labour government is
doing
improving the wages of carers and this
story government which is not addressing
fairness at work at all
with no mention of a bill in this
queen's speech not to mention the
appalling failure to do anything to help
people with the cost of living crisis
and as my colleagues have pointed out we
have made many suggestions including
that of a windfall tax on the gas and
oil companies in order to give immediate
relief on
fuel bills to our constituents
but to get back to the fairness at work
madam deputy speaker ustil has also
shown there can be workable solutions
which give employers some flexibility
was not using zero hours contracts
they've negotiated with some employers a
guaranteed minimum number of hours per
week or per month so that workers know
at least that they will get the pay for
those hours on a regular basis
these are all practical actions which
people are taking even though we are not
in government
but what we would like to do of course
we would like to see government not only
improve workers rights not only end fire
and rehire not only have proper rights
from day one of work so that everybody
is treated properly and can't just be
thrown on the rubbish heap and not only
family friend friendly work hours and
improvement on some of the reforms that
we've had to date and stronger union
rights and proper
ways of negotiating pay and conditions
with the workforce but we also
want to see
a complete change in attitude on
procurement we want to see this
government
instead of
failing miserably with the appalling
loss of money from the public purse and
a dreadful audit report that we have
seen on this government and contrast
that with the welsh labour government
which had a clean audit report on its
purchasing during the covet crisis
not only do we want to make sure that
purchasing is done fairly
and that we have an anti-corruption
commissioner to oversee it but also
that procurement looks at the value of
the businesses and the companies that we
have in this country and does more to
make
buy and sell british we know that it was
absolutely possible even when we were in
the european union for the social
benefit
clause to be invoked when giving out
contracts for companies how much more so
is that true now even if as i say there
ever were which there were not a
restriction under eu law it's perfectly
possible to take social value into
account
and that's exactly what we should be
doing but not only that the government
needs to have an industrial strategy
which ensures that you have a supply
chain working towards your strategic
objectives so that we have an energy
policy which means that we build our own
wind turbines not have to rely on
imports because we think ahead and we
have a strategy which works and which
builds in those supply chains and then
which buys british
and by doing that
obviously we can then provide more high
quality jobs and that combination of
providing high quality jobs in a secure
economy and secure rights for the
workers in work wherever they're working
whichever company they're working in
this country in the product or the
public sector is the way forward madame
deputy speaker thank you
tom randall thank you
speaker i welcome the measures in the
queen's speech and with over 30 proposed
bills there's much to talk about but i
will this afternoon you can find my
remarks to three points about housing if
i may
um the term property owning democracy is
well known but less well-known perhaps
is the name noel skelton the
conservative mp who coined the phrase
and the underlying concept in 1923
concept that was later built upon by
surrounding eden
has eschewed the concept towards
the home rather than industrial property
but skeletons and eden's thoughts have
formed the backbone of conservative
domestic policy since and rightly say
the theme of today's debate is about
empowering communities and they are
strengthened i submit when residents are
financially and emotionally investment
vested in where they live and that is
something that home ownership achieves
but there is a tension
prices have put homes out of the reach
for many supply does not match demand
and for those on the property ladder
significant change in the form of
development threatens in their eyes to
fundamentally alter the character of the
community in which they have become so
emotionally invested
growing up on the edge of arnold in my
gatling constituency i saw hand at this
with nottingham one of england's
greatest cities on my doorstep but a few
hundred yards up the road were the
hobbits an area of woodland and hedgerow
an open countryside beyond it
some of that has been built on and while
there is now a hobbuck's nature reserve
protecting some of the land under
getting boring council's local plan
further areas have been allocated to
housing and similarly on the other side
of the constituency in getting village
residents worried it developed means
they will become subsumed into a greater
nottingham clinician and bridging this
conflict is a key challenge of this
government if not the key challenge of
our generation and i welcome the
inclusion in the korean speech of
several items of legislation on this
and i suggest that perhaps one way in
which development might become slightly
more powerful to the general public if
is if what is proposed looks nice and i
start from a rather cynical position
that most if not all post-war
architecture is ugly and that were all
post-war buildings removed our towns and
cities would look no worse in fact i
think some might well be much improved
and i therefore welcome the renewed
emphasis on designing beauty and locally
i particularly welcome the money that
gedlinberry council has received to fund
and support a 12-month programme for the
council and neighbourhood planning
groups to enable them to produce
exemplar design codes i haven't yet had
details on the council on how they will
spend that money but i hope that it
results in better more beautiful
building in gedling
but i would like to speak also on a
matter about a problem that affects some
of those who have brought their houses
and that's estate rent charges
it is relatively common to private
estates with freehold houses to include
a provision in the deed of transfer
which places a duty on the owners to
contribute to the maintenance of the
estate's communal areas and facilities
such as green spaces or play areas or
raids but problems arise as i've found
when speaking to residents of the spring
park development in mapley when it's
thought that the management company
isn't offering value for money or doing
the work that is required
freeholders rights are limited in this
area and indeed they do not have the
equivalent rights to leaseholders now
the government has promised to take
action on this there was a promise to
give new rights to homeowners to
challenge unfair charges in the 2019
queen speech and the promise was
repeated in the written answer in
february this year but so far as i can
tell nothing is so far coming in this
screen speech and i
i cannot say that the problem is going
to be addressed addressed in the current
draft of legislation so if i am right on
that i do hope that the government does
consider reform in this section of in
this session of parliament and i'll look
forward and i will be looking to to
explore this issue uh in more detail in
this house
but if i might just conclude on a on a
slightly more positive note i welcome
the announcement that reforms the
planning system will
in the government's words give
communities a louder voice making sure
developments are beautiful green and
accompanied by new infrastructure and
affordable housing and i look forward to
scrutinizing this further in particular
in relation to houses of multiple
occupation
in netherfield in my constituency local
residents are concerned that developers
are turning victorian family homes into
hmos for several people with a
consequent increase in traffic and a
reduction in family housing stock
i've asked the council to make an
article full direction which would
subject any such conversions to a
planning commission application but the
council has demeared citing possible
legal challenge so if these proposals do
allow the people netherfield to take
back control of their neighborhood that
will be for the better so broadly
speaking i do very much welcome these
proposals in the queen speech and i look
forward to scrutinizing them further in
the current session
dan jarvis
thank you and for the first time in four
years madam deputy speaker i will not be
declaring an interest
i might have like to take the
opportunity to congratulate my successor
the new labour man oliver copper i know
will be a tireless champion for our
region
madam deputy speaker working with a
dedicated team to improve people's lives
was an immense honor
and a great privilege and i'm proud to
say that south yorkshire is in a much
better place than it was when i was
elected back in 2018
we created a half a billion pound
renewal fund we set up our ownership hub
the very first of its kind anywhere to
support co-ops and employee ownership we
invested heavily in cycling and walking
as part of an integrated accessible and
sustainable transport plan we gave young
people affordable bus fares and began
the work of bringing our bosses back
under public control we agreed a
groundbreaking flood prevention strategy
and started work on a housing retrofit
program
but for all the good that we achieved
madam deputy speaker i also saw just how
much potential is being wasted
after a while you learn to read the
small print in all of the promises
the flagship shared prosperity fund will
eventually reach 1.5 billion a year but
not until 2024 making it worth
significantly less over its lifetime
than would otherwise have been the case
meanwhile the leveling up fund which
replaces the local growth fund again
will be at a reduced level
the government promised three billion
pounds for bus renewal but delivered
just a third of that south yorkshire got
nothing at all but then so did the
majority of places that applied it's
leveling up for the lucky few
all of this comes against a baseline of
deep cuts to council coffers and that
right there is the reality behind the
rhetoric
as for devolving control most cash still
goes through
inadequate politicized short-term
competitive pots
it makes strategic planning impossible
and waste precious time and limited
resources
now it's only fair to say that leveling
up white paper did set out some welcome
albeit modest aspirations
no one on these benches will oppose
efforts to increase life expectancy or
eradicate illiteracy but as it stands
those aspirations are just that
aspirations and with no detail on how
they're going to be funded we will not
get to where the secretary of state
wants us to get on the current
trajectory now he's not in his place but
if the right honourable gentleman the
secretary of state for deloc wants to be
this generation's michael hesseltine
then he needs to change course
now i accept that none of this is easy
we're dealing with entrenched
socio-economic problems decades of
chronic underfunding and layer upon
layer of patchwork approaches but it
will take a lot more than a commitment
to ensuring that everyone can benefit
from alfresco dining however laudable
that may be to transform our economy
so
in the spirit of being constructive
here's what i think needs to change
funding if the secretary of state needs
an example of where leveling up has
succeeded then he should look to german
reunification it's estimated that two
trillion euros were spent on the project
between 1990 and 2014
most east german federal states are
still
the largest recipients of investments
from central government despite huge
progress east germany has still not
fully closed the gap with the former
west germany but its gdp per capita
is now higher than yorkshire's
control we need an increase in fiscal
devolution and a major shift towards
allocating central funds according to
automatic
genuinely fair formulas
let go of the purse strings and trust
local decision makers to make the
decisions
powers we need to step change in
devolved powers with skills
transport and policing among the
priorities
regional governments need to be in the
driving seat a local industrial strategy
that does not mean one size fits all
greater power and funding must be
integrated with wider reforms here at
westminster so the center also reflects
the place of both regions and nations
and locally to enstraw ensure stronger
local and regional government is held
accountable and finally democracy we
need basic safeguards for the continued
solidarity and redistribution between
nations and regions that makes us
a united kingdom and against a race to
the bottom on standards or tax
madam deputy speaker if we can do that
then we will we will have built not an
empty facade but a solid foundation for
our futures country
tom hunt
madame dr speaker it's a pleasure to
speak in this uh debate
um
the i think it's very
it was correct the prime minister placed
uh cost of living
uh so central to the queen's speech and
um
i appreciate that some steps have been
taken by the government already i
appreciate that the
situation is
challenging the fiscal position the
government faces is challenging but i do
am overview that more does need to be
done and i'm glad that the prime
minister machado have indicated uh that
this will be the case and i'll be
watching the situation uh with interest
because you know like many colleagues we
would have docked on huge numbers of
doors across our constituencies or other
local areas over the last few weeks and
we would have had those conversations
with people who are struggling to get by
at the moment and of course that would
also be supplemented with our surgeries
and our case work so i think we really
do need to grapple that um there was
much i welcomed in me uh queen's speech
um
one of the other issues that always
comes out of me is our town center uh
it's of great concern for many of my
constituents you feel as though uh
the town centre has gone downhill it's
our main civic place and it's something
of great um passion for and and the most
frustrating thing about the town centre
is at the moment it doesn't quite seem
to work
even though we have so many brilliant uh
small independent business people and
entrepreneurs
um trying to make it work and just this
monday we i was fortunate enough to have
uh the chance of exchequer in ipswich um
and he met a number of those
business owners who went to micro shops
on car street
which is a uh basket pop-up facility so
local people who've got an idea
can get a can get a foothold try it out
if it works it works if it doesn't it's
it's less high risk
for most of them and has worked and
actually 17 uh small independent
businesses are now in there and a number
have actually got uh other premises in
the town are expanding so it's really
i was very pleased the chancellor was
able to to meet them um there are too
many buildings uh significant uh
buildings in ipswich which are empty and
have been allowed to collect dust for
far too long uh it's very pleasing to
see that the old post office building
that has been empty for years has now
got the botanist which is a quite a
high-end
sort of cocktail bar has opened up and
on the top of alfresco with lovely
outdoor seating spilling onto the corn
hill
and i was
very pleased to be able to attend a soft
opening a soft launch and a hard launch
uh on the first one i had completely
non-alcoholic cocktails on the second
one i was convinced to have one
alcoholic cocktail and i would very much
advise everybody to go there if they're
very nippy switch
so the measures with regards to the
compulsory rental auctions uh that um
powers that local authorities can use um
i i welcome because we sadly it has been
too difficult to try and get many of
these important buildings you know back
onto the you know and as much as i'd
like to just blame since the palm you'd
be tempted to blame the labour council
for all of that it would be wrong for me
to do that because it's far more
complicated than that because often it
is that the owners of these buildings
who frankly you know haven't done enough
and actually i am the owner of the the
the building on car street which is now
home of microsoft's deserve credit for
showing the initiative to get that going
it's just frustrating but initially that
has taken so long uh to get off the
ground but also in terms of our town
center though to get that thriving again
we do need to look at um and try and
address my
constituents concerns about anti-social
behavior in the town center that is
persistent
and
you know there are many of my long-term
ipswich residents who don't go into a
town centre particularly at certain
times of night because i don't feel safe
i don't feel secure so having a good
high peace presence and key parts of the
town is important and
quite frankly there are large groups of
if there are large groups of um
invariably young men
gathering in groups
drinking alcohol uh when they ought not
to be doing that and making
inappropriate
lurid comments uh to to um women of all
ages going into a town centre when i
think we need replays to be incredibly
hands-on and interventionist to just
disperse and disrupt those groups and
enforcing no alcohol zones as well which
hasn't been happening to extend but i
would like
that desperately needs to be addressed
our town center of immense importance uh
to my constituents in terms of
what another key point was mentioned in
the queen's speech was to do the issue
of uh the small boat crossings which i
you know i think was i was pleased to
see him in mcqueen's speech you know i
think it is it is right that as a
country we are being uh as generous as
we are uh to uh refugees fleeing from
ukraine and like we did from afghanistan
and there are a number of constituents
who have actually uh taken in ukrainian
families and would be the same for uh
colleagues across this house and you
know that is a tribute to them but of
course you know this will uh is the
right thing to do but of course it will
place significant pressure on many of
our public services it's just a reality
we've already got quite a long council
housing waiting list in the borough and
the pressure on that over time will
likely go up as a consequence of this
but it is still the right thing to do
you know the extra money we provide for
school places right thing to do but that
challenge is made much more difficult
when we have a parallel illegal flow of
invariably young men arriving here
illegally from another safe european
country and the reality is that those
individuals who are coming here
illegally and not claiming asylum in the
other numerous safe countries they've
come through they are working directly
against the interests of some of the
most desperate families who are
fruitfully in persecution and i think
the more we can state that the better
and that is very much my view and i
think it's important that the government
have gripped that and actually i think
it's a view of most of the country who
make the distinction between those
fleeing
fleeing
areas of persecution
and coming here and those who have um
refused to apply for asylum in france
and other other safe countries uh and i
think it's important that we've drawn
that distinction i won't be taking an
intervention about topic from the smp
um
i'm so terrified of your logical
arguments i couldn't possibly counter
them um so i think it's impo it's
important we do
and i think in terms of the
movement away uh from the uh you know
human rights act something else i think
is is very welcome i think the british
bill of rights is a step in the right
direction and frankly if there is an
international treaty if there's an
international treaty that we are
subscribed to that prevents us from
being able to control our borders and
therefore be a sovereign country then of
course we need to review our membership
of it i understand that the labour party
will find that difficult to understand
because of the fact that i think that
the labour party most of the members
opposite support open borders and do not
believe in border control but i think
that is when most of my constituents
are at in terms of fee also want to
quickly touch upon the public
order act uh which is um i think uh it's
building on the police and courts and
crime bills so i think it is i was
immensely frustrated with these just off
oil protests like most of us and this at
least on this side of the house would
have been
i think we had
people trying to get to work trying to
go about their daily business which was
disrupted by the um self-righteous uh uh
individuals who who have had no concern
for what their reckless behavior was
having on others and i i really
struggled to explain and
to my constituents why it is the case
that when you have individuals um
carrying out criminal damage and petrol
stations sharing themselves to public
buildings etc why we can't just our
police force can't just get in there and
immediately remove it why are we dancing
around pretending you know we just get
on with it so frankly as strong as we
can be in this area the better the
public order act is the right thing to
do of course it would be voted down by
the opposition uh benchers who do not
support that and i think most probably
side with a reckless behavior that we've
seen from those individuals i mean i
know for a fact on that day uh that uh i
mean easter eastern region was one of
the worst affected uh parts in the
country with these recent protests uh i
myself had to go because only the
seventh petrol station actually had
petrol because of its behavior i had
constituents contacting me whose
vulnerable constituents whose carers
couldn't actually get to them um because
of the fact that their carers couldn't
fill up their motor vehicle to get to
them so we should be completely
intolerant of these reckless protesters
and i'm pleased that public order bill
gets us closer to that on a final note
i was pleased to see
the point about education and
opportunity for all i think that is a
objective that i
believe in and i think it's an objective
that
the vast majority of um members of this
place believe in on the topic of special
educational needs
we've obviously had the green paper that
has been published
uh i've heard it been referred to by
some as a very very green paper
uh which of course took a very very long
time uh to bring forward i think the
send review i think took too long
but we are where we are we've got a
green paper in front of us and there are
there is much in that green paper that i
think is is positive and but my desire
now is for that to happen as quickly as
possible so my
i would urge the government to place a
huge priority
on the send green paper you know getting
the consultation talking to the
stakeholders but getting those uh the
action in place as soon as possible
because you know certainly in suffering
other parts of the country there is a
postcode lottery when it comes to cell
division and too many young people with
great potential but with learning
disabilities are being let down so that
is one area you can never put you can
never put enough money to send as far as
i'm concerned it's always an investment
it's always an investment so on the
whole uh mr deputy speaker i welcome
this queen's speech
ellen morgan
deputy speaker
um it's an honor to be making my first
contribution to a queen speech debate
since being elected in her majesty's
platinum jubilee year
and i'm very much looking forward to
celebrating the fascinating jubilee
celebrations with my constituents
now the topic of today's debate is
fairness at work empowering communities
and i'm going to be focusing as i'm sure
you would expect on rural communities in
particular
now i'm incredibly proud of my rural
community of north shropshire
on sunday i was lucky enough to attend a
a concert in oswego street called songs
for ukraine involving nearly 200 local
school children
brilliantly hosted by ukrainian sixth
formers lisa and meera showcasing the
amazing talents of young performers from
across north shropshire and bringing
together hundreds of families to raise
over 11 000 pounds for vulnerable people
feeling fleeing a dreadful war this was
definitely north dakota at its best
but it's abundantly clear to me that
rural communities like mine and so many
other up and down the country from
shetland to somerset feel taken for
granted by this conservative government
leveling up is the catchy slogan we've
heard time and time again but there is
very little of substance in that slogan
for those in rural areas and the queen's
speech i'm afraid has offered nothing to
help them
in fact the government managed to
compile a 140-page background briefing
note to the to the queen's speech but
the only mention of the word rule was on
four occasions and two of those were in
the list of government departments
now let me describe the situation in the
lovely town of market drayton a
fantastic place to visit if you can get
there it's it's a pretty medieval town
with attractive buildings and fairly
recently a large amount of housing
development
but market drayton has only one very
infrequent bus service and this year
this service is being reduced and by the
end of august at the weekend there will
be no bus service at all
for those that don't drive if they have
an outpatient appointment at the
hospital in telford they must rely on
the car with friends or family for the
25 minute journey a taxi would be more
than 50 pounds and on the minimal public
transport available the round trip would
be in excess of four hours
it may as well be an island
young people here struggle to access
work let alone achieve fairness when
they get there
now limited and reducing public
transport is not unique to market
drayton across the market towns of north
dropship and in the rest of rural
britain isolation from work from social
opportunity and from health services are
limiting opportunity and limiting the
quality of life for rural communities
they need access to reliable bus
services
now colleagues may be thinking that the
government is on this they've committed
after all to bust back better
but i'm afraid to report that this is
yet another catchy slogan with no
meaning
how many times does the briefing paper
to the queen's speech mention buses have
a guess
the word bus or buses appears once
it highlights the complete disregard
this government have for rural
communities like mine who are seeing
their local public transport cut to the
bone
the bus back better funding as with
other leveling up funding has been
allocated via a bidding process in which
money is apparently allocated with very
little direct reference to need and
there has been nothing for shropshire
now much of the time i've spent on the
floor of this house since being elected
in december has been on the subject of
ambulance waiting times and i'm not
going to repeat the shocking stories of
dangerous delays again today
but i do note that a report by the appg
for rural health and care and the
national center for rural health and
care has found stark levels of
inequality between rural and urban areas
when it comes to health and social care
services and this resonates strongly
with the emails in my inbox from
concerned constituents struggling to
access gps dentists and even domiciliary
care in what is an increasingly
centralized model
so there's a theme emerging for rural
communities in which critical
infrastructure whether that's public
transport adult social care community
ambulance stations banks post offices
swimming pools and even driving test
centres are being shut down centralized
and removed from where they are most
urgently needed
in our market towns and villages if we
need anything we're expected to get in
our petrol cars because there aren't any
electric charging facilities and drive
to reach the most basic services
and those that can't whatever their
reason are being isolated in these rural
islands they are far from empowered and
i'm afraid that voting on their
neighbours extension will not compensate
for waiting 17 hours for an ambulance
when they need one
the conservatives have taken rural
britain for granted
the farming industry forms the backbone
of the rural economy producing our food
protecting our countryside and gluing
rural communities together
but this government is dicing with its
future
offering trade deals to countries with
lower standards and phasing out the
basic plant payment scheme before its
replacement is in place would be bad
enough
but there's been no response at all to
the rising cost of feed the cost of fuel
and the cost of fertilizer that are
leading farmers to shut up shuffle
together
at a time when many of these critical
businesses are facing the biggest
challenges for a decade the
conservatives are cutting their lifeline
taking their votes for granted and
refusing to consider other options even
in the short term to save this critical
industry but they have cut taxes for
banks
that shows you all you need to know
about the conservatives commitment to
rural britain cuts for farmers shortages
in health care cuts to public transport
tax breaks for
bankers 140 pages thousands of words and
barely a mention of rural britain and
the problems facing it
my liberal democrat colleagues and i are
proudly championing rural britain we've
tabled an amendment to the queen's
speech which focuses specifically on
ruling issues
we're calling for the government to
protect farmers for the effect from the
effects of new trade deals which would
lower environmental and animal welfare
standards
we're urging them to use this queen's
speech to reverse the closures of rural
ambulance stations and urge the
government to do far more to tackle the
chronic shortages of gps dentists
consultants nurses and other clinical
profession professionals that we so
desperately need
we're calling on the government to
protect our rivers by preventing water
companies from dumping raw sewage into
them damaging our wildlife and reducing
our access
now i'm proud to represent the royal
constituency
sorry constituency of north rupture and
in my very biased view the best world
constituency in britain
the people there are caring they are
creative and they are extremely
resilient
but the conservatives are taking the
good hard-working people of royal
britain for granted
far from levelling up they are risking
decline i urge them to think again and
act now to prevent this from happening
act on the crisis in rural care of which
dire ambulance response times are simply
the symptoms act now to save our farming
industry and improve our food security
act now to improve the services and
transport infrastructure critical to
growing the rural economy
and act now to give rural constituencies
the fair deal that they deserve
thank you
okay green
thank you very much mr deputy speaker
and it's a pleasure to follow the
honourable lady speaking in her first
queen speech debate
mr deputy speaker there was a gaping
hole at the heart of the speech on
tuesday as it failed to address the
desperate circumstances of families
facing frankly destitution
yesterday's report from the national
institute for economic and social
research showing the devastating effect
of soaring bills and real terms benefit
cuts
should be a wake-up call for the
government i really implore ministers
and especially the chancellor of the
exchequer to take the emergency actions
that are needed now to protect those
families from poverty
of course government will say that work
is the best route out of poverty and of
course i agree it should be for those
families who can work
but low wages and job insecurity mean
that for many it isn't
that's why the failure to include an
employment bill
in the queen's speech is so
devastatingly disappointing it leaves
pregnant women new dads unpaid carers
those need to work fully to work
flexibly people from minority
communities disabled people without the
protections that they should be entitled
to it allows unscrupulous employers
to continue with fire and re-hire
practices that even the prime minister
claimed he found unacceptable
so what we have is the rhetoric of
leveling up it's inadequate action to
support our local communities
regenerating local economies is
essential to achieving the government's
leveling up ambitions enabling them to
attract and retain successful businesses
and creating good jobs for local people
and education and skills as other
colleagues have said today
will be absolutely essential to ensuring
people are equipped to take those jobs
and i therefore particularly like to
speak about two of the bills which are
relevant to this the school's bill and
the higher education bill the school's
bill paid the way for all schools to
become part of multi academy trusts most
secondary schools in my constituency and
almost all primaries are not in maths
currently so this implies a lot of
structural upheaval
now i'm all for families of schools
supporting one another to raise
standards and narrow attainment gaps but
we know that it's the quality of
teaching and school leadership not
structures that drive school improvement
so how will ministers ensure that we
have the local infrastructure in place
to support local school leaders
rightly the government's leveling up
agenda focuses on the importance of
locality
and i acknowledge that some large maps
have shown that they can work in
partnership with local organizations and
communities
but how will ministers ensure that all
national multi-academy chains are
responsive to all the local communities
where each of their schools are located
and this goes to questions about
accountability and transparency
for example mats can pool their funding
reallocate it to different schools right
across the chain put it into reserves so
how are we going to secure the
accountability to local communities that
they serve and ensure that funds reach
local pupils
like other colleagues i welcome the
focus on the school's bill on attendance
and i am very pleased that colleagues
across the house and indeed in the house
of lords um have uh had their pleas uh
for a much more rigorous approach to
children missing from school
being put in place
but we can do more than simply act to
register children the commission on
young lives has pointed to the need for
an inclusion approach to supporting all
young people to succeed in school with
schools working in partnership with
youth and community workers and
community organizations
a local community-led approach to
keeping children in school
mr deputy speaker i want to turn to the
higher education bill and put on record
first my interest as a member of the
governing body of manchester
metropolitan university
our universities
are
vital to our global reputation
and
fundamental to the success of our local
economies where they're located and not
just in our traditional
university cities
so there will be much interest in local
communities
in the details of the lifelong loan
entire entitlement and i have to say the
devil will lie very much in the detail
it will be particularly important that
students can obtain the advice to make
the right substitute choices at school
to plan their route through their
post-18 education and to use their
lifelong loan entitlement to access the
right courses as their career needs
development but it will also be really
important
that our skills strategies and higher
education strategies for those
communities
are aligned with the way in which
students make their lifelong entitlement
choices
meantime the government has sought to
reassure that minimum entry requirements
and student numbers caps and the
reduction in funding for foundation
courses will not disproportionately
affect students from disadvantage
advantage backgrounds black and ethnic
minority backgrounds or universities
catering predominantly to commuter
students yet the ifs and indeed the
dfe's own impact assessment has so did
the alarm that this is exactly what will
happen no one wants students to
experience poor quality teaching or
leave university without the skills
they'll need to succeed at work or in
life
but if students of all backgrounds have
the opportunity to access and make the
most of university education it will be
really important that the government and
the office for students develop a very
careful approach to address
the concerns that exist about course
quality and outcomes that means
understanding in detail what's happening
for individual courses and student
destinations protecting the university
foundation courses that are an integral
first step in the adequate undergraduate
journey for some students
and recognizing the impact that failure
of a local higher education institution
would have
on local students and on the wider
economic position of that community
mr deputy speaker i echo the comments
that have been made today about housing
supply
and i particularly do so in the context
of my own borough of trafford where we
have a desperate shortage of housing for
local families extremely high private
rents by the standards of the north of
the country
far too many families still living in
overcrowded or substandard homes and too
many
in unsuitable poor quality temporary
accommodation
we desperately needed a holistic
strategy to securing the housing supply
we need for today and into the future
instead what we get again and again
are stop go approaches on targets on
planning law
and on developer obligations
and i hope that the government will
listen very carefully to the pleas made
by the chair of the select committee
this morning and others to secure both
the right strategy and the right funding
to enable local authorities like mine to
secure the housing that we need to meet
the needs of local families
finally mr deputy speaker i'd just like
to say a little about the economic crime
bill and i was glad to have the chance
to raise this with the minister in the
opening speeches
i'm pleased the bill will provide
companies house with more effective
investigation and enforcement powers and
that the registrar is to become a more
active game keeper gatekeeper this will
of course also require more resources
can i particularly emphasize the need to
strengthen the approach taken by
companies house to compulsory strikeoff
too often used by unscrupulous directors
to avoid complying with their
obligations by allowing a company to be
struck off for non-compliance with
information requirements and then those
same directors going on to establish new
companies again and again to carry on
their business i'd very much like to see
a much more proactive approach from
companies house
where they ought to be aware of numerous
and repeated failures by companies with
common directors to file the legally
required documents
and i hope the economic crime bill will
give us an opportunity to address this
very much andy mcdonald
thank you mr deputy speaker uh it's a
pleasure to follow my honourable friend
from stratford and armstrong
mr deputy speaker the queen's speech
contains
the most dispiriting program of
legislation that i've known during my
time in parliament
following a pandemic which is ripped
through our communities
killing upwards of
175 000 of our fellow citizens
and now
as we face a cost of living crisis
with people being left in the dreadful
situation
of having to choose between heating
their home or eating
this government has proposed a program
that will do absolutely nothing
meaningful to help
instead they decided to spend the next
year enacting what can only be described
as some of the most reactionary and all
authoritarian legislation in living
memory and it follows a raft of recent
laws passed at the very end of the last
session designed to drive a coaching
horses through our civil liberties at
the elections act containing measures to
deter people from voting the police
crime and sentencing a courts act
banning noisy protests and criminalizing
gypsy roma and traveller communities and
also the nationality and borders act
which gave the home secretary powers to
strip dual citizens of their british
citizenship without notice
and in contravention of the uk's
international obligations
criminalizing many of those seeking
asylum who now risk being shipped
off to rwanda thanks to the home
secretary's cruel and inhumane
scheme
now the government has said it intends
to bring forward yet more draconian laws
to stifle our democracy
the orwellian bill of rights is pure
double speak
a terrifying attack on our hard-won
human rights laws the public order bill
is an outright assault on peaceful
protest and tries to push
through a matter that has already been
voted down by this parliament
and the boycott's divestment and
sanctions bill which seeks to
criminalize a legitimate form of public
political dissent whilst also smearing
the campaign for palestinian human
rights
ought to worry any person who cares
about this issue
or other human rights abuses
climate activism the arms trade or
indeed any expression of solidarity with
oppressed people struggling for justice
across the world
none
not one jot or sin tiller of these bills
will do anything to support hard-pressed
families facing the cost of living
crisis including the many thousands
living in poverty in middlesbrough and
they will be sick to the pits of their
stomach as i was to hear from the
benches opposite yesterday that their
crises are of their own making and
because they can't budget cook properly
and manage to live on 30 pence a day
mr deputy speaker one thing that could
have been of help to working people
would have been the introduction of the
long promised employment bill
since this legislation was announced
three years ago ministers have committed
to bringing it forward no less than 20
times
yet when it came to the queen's speech
on tuesday the bill was nowhere to be
found
and whether it's the lies about
widespread law breaking under the prime
minister's own roof
or the hollow promise
to make britain the best place to to
work
why should the public have any trust in
a word that conservative politicians
have to say
so it appears that measure measures
which were announced such as the
creation of a single enforcement body
offering greater protection for workers
making flexible working the default and
extending redundancy protection to
prevent pregnancy and maternity
discrimination have all since fallen by
the way side as the government is
clearly
more focused on attacking those
protesting against the climate
catastrophe or the crime of apartheid
than they are about caring for those who
are most in need across our country
the strengthening of employment rights
and protections is critically urgent yet
the government is simply not taking the
necessary steps to address the stark
imbalances of power in the workplace
and the sorry situation we now find
ourselves in was made plain for us all
to see in march of this year with the
unlawful and utterly disgraceful
decision of piano ferry bosses to make
almost 800 of their own workforce
redundant over zoom in a pre-recorded
message having chosen
to break the law and not consult or
engage with trade unions as required by
the 1997
trade union act
these loyal and hard-working seafarers
some of whom have been with the company
for decades
were removed from the vessels by
security guards with handcuffs whilst
agency workers on as little as one pound
eighty an hour were brought on board to
replace them and the harbours seafarers
remuneration bill has been heralded by
ministers as a silver bullet to protect
seafarers from these bully boy tactics
on the part of rogue employers
yet mr deputy speaker the british ports
association and the trade union congress
have dismissed the plans as unworkable
or insufficient and the announcement of
a consultation process
means there will be further delays all
the while as the government kicks the
can down the road it's freely admitted
that piano ferries have got away with
forcing out its unionized workforce
either by making them redundant or
through the pernicious practice of
firing and rehiring these seafarers on
less favorable agency contracts back in
march
the prime minister said his government
was taking legal action
against piano ferry bosses
well we're two months on
so where is it
ministers could
and should have immediately taken
concrete action
to seize the vessels
reinstate the workers
and impose unlimited fines on the
company
instead
those on the benches have sat on their
hands as hundreds of lives and
livelihoods have been turned upside down
because when it comes down to it the
only thing that matters to them and
their fat cat friends is profit not
people
this in action
hasn't just let piano ferries off the
hook
it's given the green light to other
businesses to trample other workers
rights and it will continue
so long as the situation exists in which
law breaking is good for a company's
bottom line it's the
break the law and pay off people later
bullying club mentality that runs
through the upper classes and
establishment in our society
be it the bosses of big business or the
prime minister
they know that they can get away with
acting unlawfully either because they
won't get caught
or held to account or if they do they
know they'll still come up trumps with a
system that always has their backs
if the current situation is allowed to
go on without correction it won't just
be operators across the maritime
industry that feel compelled to follow
suit which will spell
an end to any residual uh uk maritime
workforce will also see
a race to the bottom across the economy
as businesses
take the lead from p o
knowing that they can blindly commit
crimes of corporate thuggery
decimating workers rights protections in
the process
mr deputy speaker
if we asked to see an end
to this corrupt
immoral system
what we need in the first instance is a
strengthening of employment rights and
protections including
the total outlawing of the fire and
re-hire tactics
legislation must be passed that would
stop such injurious industrial practices
from being profitable
the fact that the government stood in
the way of the private members bill
brought by my honorable friends from
brent north in the previous session
and their failure
time and time again to vote in favor of
motions to outlaw the practice has done
much to create create a culture of
impunity amongst predatory exploitative
businesses who will use these
greedy good
opportunities to steal a march on those
good
and decent businesses who behave
ethically and who care for the people
who work for them
if we are to rebalance the economy
improve wages and save working people
and those most in need from bearing the
brunt of soaring inflation then what we
need now more than ever
is a new deal for working people
as we set out
in
the
green paper published last year not only
would this program outlaw fire and
re-hire toxic tactics
it would transform the world of work
treating people with dignity and respect
and addressing the imbalance of power
by unshackling our trade unions to do
their jobs
bargaining for and protecting their
members
but i'm gravely fearful that this
government plans to move in the opposite
direction
and further weaken working people's
rights and protections the the
provisions that have been outlined
regarding the so-called brexit freedoms
bill to amend repeal or replace retained
eu law
including i expect those laws that
protect work workers rights are deeply
deeply concerning
so i'd like to offer uh the minister oh
she's gone uh the opportunity
to intervene
and stay categorically
that they will not permit the regression
of a single piece of employment
legislation be that relating to the
transfer of undertakings regulations or
on working time
we'll get no answer mr deputy speaker
but this is a very dark and desperate
moment
and i can only assume that by the
government's continued refusal to rule
these measures out that our fears are
well founded
in which case this is now
the moment for working people
across the country to realize that far
from representing their interests
this government
is coming after their rights
that generations have fought so hard to
win
if we can come together
in opposition
across these benches and hopefully with
some members opposite then we stand a
chance of defeating these devastatingly
draconian plants
and the betrayal of working people
that lies within them
harold clark
thank you mr deputy speaker mrs deputy
speaker my constituents in enthus north
want a government that delivers for them
they want the financial security they
need in the face of the cost of living
crisis
they want the prosperity of a thriving
high street
they want the respect of properly funded
local services that can deliver for them
this queen's speech offered none of
these it is wrapped up in an empty
slogan that provides nothing to the
people of my borough
a borough which has the eleventh highest
rate of child poverty in this country
and where one in five workers are on low
pay
it is also it also has the highest rate
of private rental evictions of any
borough in london mainly due to
section 21 which the government have
been promising for years to reform but i
failed to do so
yet still we are ignored
it has become abundantly clear that the
that the government will not be leaving
up leveling up this country
it's max of total arrogance to talk
about uh of a melissa's style uh
renaissance of our town centers when
inflation is at a 30-year high
only by getting money back into people's
pockets will high streets and town
centres like mine in enfield north be
able to thrive again
mr deputy speaker when it comes to
leveling up it's as if enfield is the
land that time forgot for this
government
since 2018 enfield council budget has
been cut by
70.2 million pounds
the council have tried to work with
central government to help make up some
of this shortfall through applying for
uh towns funds um through the level for
the leveling up fund and the community
renewal fund
the result
a grand total of zero extra funding for
enfield
not a single penny
and frankly after the emptiness of the
queen's speech what hope do we have of
that changing anytime soon
with over 88
of pounds fund being allocated to areas
with tory mps
is it any doubt that people in my
borough are somewhat cynical about the
government's agenda
the leveling up bills in the queen
speech are still desperately lacking in
ambition and as thin as the white paper
the substance amounts to little more
than the government's marking its own
homework and has nothing by way of new
money or new ideas
power could not be further away from the
communities who are having to compete
with each other over sporadic pots of
funding hannibal or not in the case of
enfield by tory ministers
if leveling up means anything
it should be about empowering local
communities to take to make decisions to
take decisions in their own interests
under this government it means paying
lip service to communities up and down
this country
whilst continuing to hold horde power in
whitehall
enfield like the rest of the country
cannot carry on
with more of the same
we need action to deal with the cost of
living crisis now
we need a far more fundamental rethink
of our economic settlement
with real power handed to communities
we need much better than what this
government are offering the people of
enfield north and the whole country
mr deputy speaker as i mentioned this
government have been talking about
abolishing uh section 21
for many years they're still waiting um
and we still have thousands in enfield
north being evicted out of their homes
for no good reason putting huge pressure
on local
local council housing lists so with
thousands on the housing waiting list it
was very surprising to have the
secretary of state for transport
intervene and stop the housing
development on a car park next to a
station to protect parking facilities it
is absolutely beyond belief mr speaker
not only does this government not have a
plan to tackle the housing crisis it is
actively preventing local authorities
from actually dealing with a crisis it's
really disappointing mr speaker
this government continued to fail
enfield north residents on everything
from i said from housing from leveling
up finally mr deputy speaker local
councils including mine are doing a
great job delivering public health
prevention programs
however the funding formula for the
public health um for public health and
local authorities was devised in 2013
and has not been reformed since
and it means that boroughs like mine are
being not getting the funding they
desperately need to deliver prevent
preventative measures and for their
communities it is unfair that a
borough-like mine still receives 39
pounds per head
in enfield whereas the burrowing next
door to us receives 139 pounds per head
the disparity is ludicrous and there is
no good reason this was an opportunity
for the government to make sure that the
residents of enfield were being weren't
being let down but it's failed to do do
that this government as i said had does
not fail to disappoint at all uh and
again uh webex has said the leveling up
bills um do not deliver for enfield and
it is really disappointing uh everything
that's been set out in this query speech
christine
thank you mr deputy speaker it's a
pleasure to follow the honourable member
for enfield north and i will be
concentrating a lot of my remarks on
employment which is quite ironic given
the collective industrial action that
appears to be taking place
in the conservative benches i just hope
that they
i just hope that the the ballot was
conducted in a a in a legal way but i am
disappointed mr deputy speaker that the
honourable member for ipswich
i may be alone in this but i'm
disappointed that the honourable member
for upswitch is not in his place because
um the anti-immigration rhetoric he was
using mr deputy speaker as you were
taking the chair
i think is in stark contrast to the
reality
of the situation
now because i do not believe mr deputy
speaker that any human being
is illegal
and i think when we use words like
illegal towards our fellow human beings
we're in dangerous ground and territory
indeed
and what i start contrast it is mr
douglas speaker i've been in tears of
joy
over the last few days and it's not the
queen's speech i can assure you
it is
um i'm delighted to see
the great news that we had in the
council elections now as you know mr
deputy speaker the good people of
glasgow south west are among the most
sophisticated electorate in these
islands and in the greater pollock ward
they hit it out the park
because they have elected
the great
rosa sally
the first
refugee
elected as a councillor
in scotland
what a wonderful achievement that is for
someone who frankly is a brilliant young
woman i as the first minister of
scotland said this is someone who has
served with distinction in the glasgow
south west constituency office so good
she's been promoted twice mr deputy
speaker currently the office manager and
she has served
uh and helped serve constituents
diligently i believe she will be a
fantastic counsellor but isn't it
something when we hear the rhetoric from
some of the government benches
about immigrants
and the anti-immigrant language when you
have a brilliant young woman uh who is
now serving a a and engaging in public
service and that is why mr deputy
speaker i want to see asylum seekers
being given the right to work
because i think this was a mistake that
the blair government put in place when
they stopped asylum seekers having the
right to work i think it's absolutely
scandalous that we allow asylum seekers
to be living on the equivalent
of what i was earning as a youth trainee
with strathclyde regional council 30
years ago
it is not right and i think asylum
seekers after a period of time maybe six
months should have the right to work and
make their contribution in this economy
and i'll give way to my good friend from
honduras
i'm very grateful for giving away um
he's absolutely right to focus on this
issue uh and of course the government's
uh scheme for the homes you for ukraine
or korean refugees has a lot to
recommend if it would only work properly
for everybody but at the heart of it
that ability for people have recourse to
public funds and the ability to work is
absolutely the right one but surely that
should apply to every refugee why it
shouldn't sink simply be uh restricted
to to one particular car and i'm
delighted to have that but shouldn't it
go across the board universally
i do agree with that because i think
that people who seek sanctuary in this
country want to make a contribution and
they want to make a positive
contribution to this
across these islands and so i i do agree
with the honourable member for
middlesbrough uh or on that basis this
should be the right to work and i'll
give her something
i thank um i thank him for giving away
um i wanted to uh i want to associate
myself with the comments he's made about
his office manager who's been elected to
glasgow city council i believe i was on
a trade trade union delegation united
delegation that many years ago so know
her well
the point he's making about refugees and
asylum seekers does he agree with me
that the home office
has serious issues when it comes to
dealing with these people and not just
the current home secretary but the
former home secretary former prime
minister the architect of the hostile
environment against people of color and
home office has had long-standing issues
under this conservative government and
it needs a root and branch reform
yes i thank him very much for that and i
should if i hadn't already said that
rosa is indeed a united activist and
former member of the stuc general
council scotland's workers parliament as
well and
was indeed in cuba with uh
the the uh honorable gentleman a and a
delegation but he is absolutely right
the home office must be i think one of
the most dysfunctional and i know it's a
competition but the home office is
probably one of the most dysfunctional
government departments there is in yemen
need to ask people who are looking for a
passport at the moment uh to to to ask
that i very much associate myself with
the the comments made by my honorable
friend for aberdeen north who was quite
right about the challenges
around eu law and the eu workers
protections because i'd mentioned strata
regional council earlier
when the tory guard decided to abolish
strangle regional council it was i
remember when two p was good legislation
i i i did a a a
protect workers on that basis now i want
to focus my remarks mr deputy speaker
on my first intervention to
the parliamentary under secretary of
state and the fact that the government
picked the under secretary of state to
lead for the government on fairness at
what i think tells you a lot about the
priorities
now many honourable members have talked
about the promises in the employment
bill so i'm going to quote directly the
delegated legislation committee of the
25th of january not a date that you can
forget if you're scottish the 25th of
january bums day at 10 46 a.m
the under secretary of state said
clearly the employment bill is the
honorable member for glasgow southwest
knows its primary legislation
it will be announced when it comes
forward in parliament time in the
queen's speech
so that is and well hansard a hansard
exactly i believe
the record's not being corrected in any
way so that tells us mr deputy speaker
that an employment bill is not a
priority for this government and i want
to know why it's not a priority for this
government because as as many uh
honourable members have said
and as
as we hear regularly at the department
of work and pension select committee the
impact i
on women and and brainworkers of unfair
working practices and indignities
at work and that starts with zero
contracts we had the parliamentary under
secretary of state
simultaneous timelessly telling us that
zero our contracts are a good thing but
are also exploitative well they can't be
both
mr deputy speaker and i think that
i think we should perhaps
take on this argument new zealand
contracts are a good thing and people
want them so let's only allow them
where there's a collective agreement
with a recognized trade union and then
we'll find out how many people actually
want zero
contracts or not no legislation for
short-term shift changes as many
honorable members have said where people
turn up to their work sometimes they're
told expecting they have a five-hour
shift to be told that they've to work 10
hours that day or even worse they turn
up at their work and told that there are
no hours for them to work that day and
they have to pay out transport and
childcare costs so we really need
legislation to tackle that and to make
sure well that does happen that it's
double time for a workers a around those
issues no a
no protection where a company ceases
trading
a good example we had
i
in scotland was a hairdresser
operating out of a hotel who then
upped and left to portugal left the
workers with no wages and they had no
protection at all because they went to
the hotel and asked for wages and the
hotel said not our responsibility i want
to see legislation to fix those sorts of
issues because that is the reality of
what's happening and the pandemic
amplified these issues these issues
didn't go away uh with the pandemic the
pandemic i emphasize those issues and
i'm sure my friend from middlesbrough
will agree because we've proposed uh a
little legislation similar on this we
really need to sort out the status of
workers in the country there are far too
many
i believe workers who are bogusly
self-employed
and that actually has the double head of
people being caught up in this one
charge scandal as well because they
don't they they think that they're
they're directly employed and i'm not
and frankly you know we'll be promised i
i remember sitting here
the private members bill on fire and we
hired a performance there would be a
better way of doing it and i don't see
that either i'll just say
concluding two quick things mr deputy
speaker
i am concerned at the government's
changes announced just before the end of
the last session
which will make sanctions easier on
benefit claimants
i think that's going i think that's
going the wrong way and i also believe
it's going against what the government
had promised
the government had promised that they
would start initiating warnings
before they would sanction people and we
were given commitments that that was
going to be the case and those
commitments seem to have
disappeared and i'll i'll give away can
i handle a friend for giving way and for
the excellent speech that he is making
right now but on on the subject of
sanctions does he not agree with me that
all the evidence shows that sanctions
and conditionality do not actually work
especially when it pertains to disabled
people and frankly this government
should be seeking to actually scrapping
the sanctions regime
i do want to see the end of the
sanctions regime and i agree that
conditionality is not working but i
think it's a bare minimum they could
introduce a yellow but what's known as a
yellow card or a warning system before
someone is sanctioned
and not people just turning up and being
sanctioned because they were five
minutes late i mean there are people who
we we're politicians we're late for
meetings all the time aren't we because
that's just the way the world works that
were like you know so would we be
sanctioned for being five minutes late i
don't think so i want to join others a
lastly mr deputy speaker in supporting
the principle of freedom of peaceful
assembly
and in the year and it was a year ago
that that fellow glaswegians along
myself on ken muir street to stop the
home office
from taking away two people and an
immigration van and
i congratulate the good people of
edinburgh for stopping at an immigration
red
last week
the principle of people being able to
assemble freely and peacefully must
remain
in these islands as far as i'm concerned
so mr deputy speaker i support and join
with my friend in aberdeen north we need
employment law devolved to the scottish
parliament
where this government will not act
because if it will not act the people of
scotland when they get a choice
and they look at employment law will
choose independence over them any day of
the week
very gartner
thank you mr deputy speaker and
i want to pay tribute first of all to
her majesty the queen
and it was a great sorrow to me that she
was not able to give the gracious
address
uh earlier this week
in person
we have been privileged to live
in the elizabethan age
most members of parliament serve many
sovereigns and we have had the privilege
of only serving one
and that age began as an age of upheaval
after the second world war it became an
age of opportunity and equality with the
labour government and the equalities act
of the 1960s
but now mr deputy speaker it's becoming
an age of insecurity
security of income
in security and housing
in security and health
in food
in work
since the prime minister boasted last
year that the uk was
the fastest growing economy in the g7
the uk has become
the slowest growing economy
in the first quarter of this year and we
now find that we are the fastest
shrinking economy
we've gone from 0.8 at the beginning of
this year growth
to 0.1
minus
that is a shrinking economy
the bank of england project 10
inflation by the end of the year whilst
real wages have been falling
and 2 million people
are going without food
they're going without food
for more than a day
sometimes because they don't have the
money to buy it
sometimes because they don't have the
money
to cook it
and sometimes
because they don't have the will to take
it out of the mouths of their own
children
it is shameful my honorable fan says
from a sedentary position it is shed
yeah
we are the
the fifth richest economy in the world
and it is shameful
so let's examine
these insecurities
i believe that the
queen's speech this year
from any government with any compassion
would have put at its center at its core
a right to food
as my honorable friend from liverpool
has been calling for
for months darby
sorry
um
did you want it no no no no
liverpool western yes indeed
um
i believe that that should have been at
the very center
of the gracious address
because we cannot
feel that we are doing our job as
politicians
i hope that government ministers feel
that they cannot be doing their job as a
government
when there are people
facing
hunger at that scale in our country
when so many millions of our fellow
citizens are reliant upon food banks
this is not the britain
that we should aspire to be part of
and it is certainly not the britain that
any government minister should aspire to
be a minister in charge of
so the insecurity
in income
is extreme
and it's been exaggerated by the fact
that even by the government's own
figures 900 000 individuals many of whom
have disabilities
will become worse off
as the result of the transition from
legacy benefits to universal credit
and that's why
the government should have had at the
heart of the gracious address
the need to restore the 20 pounds cut to
universal credit
to protect the income
of those adversely affected
and to make sure
that any
recovery was not on the backs of the
poor
insecurity and work and today
this debate is titled fairness at work
and power in
communities well
so many of my colleagues have spoken
about the
the gaping lac the gaping hole at the
center of the bill that there is no
employment bill promised 20 times by
government ministers
um
no
solution no legislative solution and you
know
i almost felt sorry for the minister of
employment who sat at the dispatch box
because
it was it must have been obvious to so
many of us that he was embarrassed
he was embarrassed because he knew that
what had been committed to what had been
promised
had just
slipped away
and he knew he had no power to do
anything about it
but there are people in government in
the cabinet who did have the power to do
something about it and they failed
that's right
absolutely right and these are the
choices
these are the choices that should have
been made in that queen speech
to protect people in work
127 people this week
at the richmond upon thames college the
entire teaching staff told you're fired
unless you sign a new contract taking 10
days off your holiday entitlement go
away think about it
of course because of the trade union
legislation it's not possible for for
the union to fight back immediately they
have to consult they have to ballot they
have to
notify
but they have balloted oh yes they have
88 turnout and a 97 vote in favor of
strike action
because it's disgraceful
and yet what's happening is that the
management of that college is calling in
those workers now one by one
putting pressure on
telling them that
you know what are you going to do if you
don't have a job what are you going to
do if if actually at the end of this
week because you're failing to sign this
new contract
you can't pay your rent you can't feed
your kids you're one of those people who
needs to use food banks
that's the pressure that is being put on
people by insecurity in employment and
that's why
all the things that my honorable friend
talked about all the things that he put
together in the employment rights green
paper
so vital so vital if we want to have
equality if we want to have
fairness at work
as the title of this debate says we
should we don't have it
we need it
but there's insecurity in health
i tabled a motion mr deputy speaker and
amendment to the queen's speech bill in
which i talked of 6.1 million people who
have been referred to a consultant and
who are waiting for treatment
today that figure was uprated by
300
000
6.5
million people now
having been referred to a consultant and
yet still waiting for treatment over 2
million of them waiting more than the 18
week maximum period
and 300 000 waiting for more than a year
and
when the minister sums up when when we
hear at the end of the debate
let not them stand up and say
well this is because of the pandemic
because we know that this was building
up it was 4.43 million before the
pandemic even started and that was
because of a decade of underfunding of
our health
services so we have insecurity of income
we have insecurity work we have
insecurity
in health
and we have insecurity
in housing
and how many times
have we had to stand in this chamber
and talk about the plight
of those trapped in accommodation
where there are known fire stopping
defects
unable to move on with their lives
unable to sell
partly because of the ews one forms but
not only that
unable even to get insurance on their
properties
and being charged through the nose by
unscrupulous managing agents
for scaffolding
or for
waking watches
and for
the weight
to get on with their lives just to get
on with their lives or to to have a new
child they can't because they have a
bedroom space they can't even separate
if they want to get divorced they can't
move to go to a new job
their lives are frozen
because of the failure by the government
to act
the insecurity that climate change
puts over all our lives
is something that needs to be tackled
but it needs to be tackled in a
comprehensive housing policy
because
for all the talk and we can talk about a
windfall tax and we should
but for all to talk about a windfall tax
the cheapest energy is the energy that
you don't use
so insulate the homes that need
insulation
19 million of them that need insulation
the government has known this for years
every select committee in this house has
told the government what to do
and there has been complete inaction
and where where in the the gracious
address
is the real sense of commitment to
tackling this as part of the housing
crisis
38
rise in street homelessness
a net loss of 22 000 social homes across
england
we need the government to tackle the
housing prices
and i
just looked to the
second line of the debate's title
power
in communities
how do you give power to communities
you give power to communities by making
their lives secure
by enabling them to stand up for
themselves that means having security of
income it means having security of
health it means having the security that
you have a home that you are confident
in
that you don't feel that you are trapped
and in danger
but power
is something that resides
in land
it is extraordinary
that a thousand years on from the
doomsday book in 1086
we still have today
in this country
half of the land of the united kingdom
owned by fewer than 6 000 individuals
half of the land of the united kingdom
owned by fewer than six thousand
individuals
and that is why we urgently need land
reform
and
i was delighted when the
honourable member for north
somersetshire this morning agreed with
me
that actually we need to see
a reform of the land compensation act in
1961 so that councils are able to buy
land
closer to their existing value
rather than
at their hope value
that would free up land in this country
four houses
but we need to go much further
we need to look at what milton friedman
again quoted by the honourable member
for north sundance
this morning what milton friedman
described
as the least
bad tax
the land value tax is what he was
referring to
because unless we challenge
the thousand-year
land ownership
that has given so few people in this
country
the power over their communities
and i noted that
earlier
one such magnet was speaking in the
debate
unless we give that power back to the
people
by a genuine program of land reform
we will not have the right
to talk
of power in communities
and fairness in our society
martial
uh thank you uh mr deputy speaker and
can i say what a pleasure it is to
follow my honourable friend for brent
north who gave an outstanding and
incredibly uh powerful
speech
now mr deputy speaker the queen's speech
was a real opportunity for the
government to reset
and deliver legislation that would
increase living standards create
communities of opportunity
and remove social inequalities
instead the government decided to put
political and party interests over the
interests of people
but the public clearly see this and they
are tired of this out of touch
government
and that's why the conservatives
suffered losses in last week's local
elections including losing conservative
flagship councils including onesworth
council which was won by the labour
party and this has provided us with the
opportunity to show how a labor run
administration can do things differently
being ambitious for everyone and i know
that the new labour leader of wandsworth
council and councillors will do an
excellent job in serving the people of
battersea and wandsworth
the government speaks about leveling up
in reality it is leveling down growth
has stagnated under the conservative
since 2010 and meanwhile inflation is is
predicted to rise to 10 percent later
this year
and we know research by the resolution
foundation found
found that average earnings are forecast
to just be two pounds a week higher than
they were before the financial crisis
leading to this parliament being the
worst on record for living standards
across the country people are seeing
their household incomes and purchasing
powerful and many people our fate are
falling into poverty especially
disabled people and women and we know
that many of these groups are actually
experiencing some of the worst impacts
of this cost of living crisis
and just recently this week the national
institute for economic and social
research said that a further 250
000 households face destitution which
would take the number of people in
extreme poverty to 1.2
million
london our wonderful city
is one of the most precious
i would say it is most prosperous
regions in the uk
however there are a lot of people that
are still struggling with the high cost
of buying or renting the high cost of
living which is reflected in the high
levels of poverty especially children
stuck below the poverty
redline
in my own constituency of battersea
people are experiencing huge increases
in their energy bills we know that 55 of
them are spending more on transport 69
more on groceries
and we know that with the tory's
national insurance tax rise this is also
set to hit people's incomes as well this
is the reality for so many people not
just in my constituency but people that
are facing this across the country
now mr deputy speaker a pro-growth and
in-touch government that governs governs
in the people's interests would have
changed direction
and introduced an emergency budget that
included a windfall tax on those oil and
gas companies
but this government isn't serious about
helping people and it is clear that it
is not committed to actually leveling up
and it is shown through them leaving out
a vital piece of legislation in being
the employment bill
this would have protected the rights of
workers it would have outlawed bad
practices such as fire and rehire it
could have even introduced proper
mandatory pay gap reporting for disabled
people and for people from black asian
and ethnic minority backgrounds or
choices
and it's a failed promise that this
government has made several times
the leveling up bills also lack ambition
and are incredibly thin on detail
communities will have to compete for
small pots of money handed out by
central government and i have to say if
they were really serious about trying to
tackle inequalities and level up this
country it would really seek to give
real power to communities
we know that there is already evidence
across all areas that leveling up isn't
happening
look at the government's policies on
brexit industrial strategy unemployment
housing
education
and equality
as for the brexit freedoms bill
research and many many conversations
with my constituents show that brexit
has created more tape regulations which
is hurting economic growth and impacting
on business and people's lives the
government the government must be honest
with businesses
they must be honest about the true cost
of brexit
why won't it publish what we've been
calling for a real economic impact of
brexit and furthermore when the minister
is going to respond she really should
they need to reassure the house
that this brexit freedoms bill will not
seek to roll back on those hard-fought
rights that many of us have fought for
when it comes to business we see support
for businesses like those in my
constituency who are key to local growth
to innovation and to investment in our
communities
but the queen's speech showed that
businesses can't afford the
conservatives there was nothing on
dealing with the high cost and the
soaring energy bills for businesses and
the government should follow what labour
have been calling for and what labour
policy would be to scrap business rates
as we know it is now outdated
on regeneration of our high streets
there was no mention of how the
government will protect essential
face-to-face services
which many of my constituents really do
rely on especially disabled people
since the conservatives took power we
have seen over 6 000 bank branches close
including in my own constituency leaving
thousands of people without access to
banking services but we also know the
role that high street banks can play on
our high streets
now mr deputy speaker on the housing and
regeneration bill this will only be
successful if reforms
delivers high quality zero carbon
genuinely affordable new homes in places
where they are so desperately needed
now we have seen the government roll
back
on its target of three hundred thousand
now we don't know is it or is it not the
case that they are going to stick to
this target or are they just throwing
another promise down the drain
but when it comes to social housing and
those commitments whilst they can be
welcome
it's really important that when they
introduce this social housing
regulations bill the devil will actually
be in the detail as to whether it will
lead to better standards in social
housing especially after
decades of under investment by the
tories in battersea and wandsworth
and will the bill ensure that tenants
really tenants voices are really going
to be heard and provide them with effect
with effective redress
it is also
good that the government has committed
to renters reform bill including a ban
on no fault evictions but again the
devil will be in the detail and it
really will be be the timeline as to
when that will be enforced as we know
that there are over a million more
people now in private rent living in
private rented accommodation
now mr deputy speaker we are five nearly
five years on from the grenfell fire
but yet again this queen's speech there
was no protection in law to protect
those leaseholders who are having to pay
tens of thousands of pounds in fire
safety remedial costs now the government
have missed two opportunities to address
this shortcoming
in the fire safety act and the building
safety act there was nothing
to tackle this injustice and really help
so many leaseholders many in my
construction constituency but
leaseholders up and down the country who
are living
in homes that are unsafe who are unable
to move on with their lives so unable to
sell their properties or even just enjoy
family life
one minute but carry on now in terms of
education the school's bill contain no
plan to really support children's
recovery from the pandemic
and we know that targeting action
targeting the disparities that black
asian and ethnic minority children and
disabled children face especially when
it comes to exclusions and off-rolling
has not been addressed
now we know essentially that
after the pandemic and if they're really
serious about actually leveling up this
country it would mean so much more if
this queen's speech had actually made
reference to the disproportionate impact
that the pandemic and the cost of living
crisis is having on black and asian and
ethnic minority communities women and
disabled people but yet again there was
nothing to protect those groups of
people
now finally instead of empowering people
the government have focused on taking
away hard-fought rights through the
public order bill and replacing
the human rights act introduced by the
last labour government with a british
bill of rights now that ran alarm bells
in everybody's ears particularly on this
side of the house as we know that that
would just be steps to try and reduce
our hard-won and thoughtful rights
i will say it again this is not about
leveling up it is leveling down the
leveling up agenda is a myth it has
nothing to do with removing inequalities
or tackling the many many burning
injustices
it has division and culturals written
all over it and it aims to divide our
country into rural versus metropolitan
or london versus red wall areas
the queen's speech has shown that this
government is all about gluster and
empty promises
very glindan thank you mr deputy speaker
the announcements made by the queen it
made in this queen's speech do nothing
to increase the trust that the people of
north hindsight have in the tory
government nor to alleviate their
concerns about the rising cost of living
which is starting to bite really hard in
no time side
i've heard from so many of my
constituents hurt and angered by the
antics of number 10 during partygate
while they rigidly followed covert rules
unable to be with relatives in hospitals
or in care homes and worst of all for
some not to be with them in the last
hours of their lives
then to add insult to injury included in
the estimated
4 billion pounds of fraud in the
furlough scheme
is north high side conservative party
with a furlough claim for a member of
party staff who continued to work during
lockdown
and when i raised the story state of
affairs at pmq's with the prime minister
he simply brushed the issue aside
fortunately that is now be the incident
is now being properly investigated
in north tyneside we have an excellent
labour council led by our outstanding
elected mayor norma redsburn and thanks
to the hard work of norma her cabinet
and council officers the council has
fought hard to keep many important vital
services in place
despite fierce cuts from the government
as a result of government policy since
2010 north hindsight has had to make
131 million pound savings
the core spending per dwelling is only
1984
compared to the average
of 2155
per dwelling
and in this financial year the council
received
63.5 billion of revenue support grant
and emmy a cut of
81.4 percent since 2014.
why
while the government is making much of
its leveling up leveling up agenda in
the queen's speech the reality is that
in north hindsight where employment runs
at 6.5
almost 2 percent above the naval
national average
they have given
us a category two
status while the chancellor's leafy
richmond constituency has been given a
category one status in the leveling up
um
plan
our area also missed out on the
potential of 60 000 new jobs and 2.6
billion
in new investment with the treasury
refusing us
freeport status and that affected
the area from blithe down to rear side
something that i will never
get over when i think of the missed
opportunities nor will people in our
area either
and of the 45 towns that received the
townsfund 39 were in tory areas leaving
behind towns like killing with and walls
end in my constituency
the tory government has already failed
the northeast on transport cancelling
the hs2 northern northeast leg refusing
crucial upgrades to the east coast
mainland and scrapping northern
powerhouse rail
and alongside the northeast chamber of
common commerce i lament the fact that
the transport bill has no good news for
our area
we all know good transport links are
unquestionably
a key to job creation and investment and
surely should be part of any leveling up
agenda
despite promises the government has not
given us cast a cast iron guarantee that
the electricity cables over the time
will be buried below the water or raised
to allow
world-renowned companies in wall's end
and along the rest of the time to bring
in potentially millions more in
contracts and thousands of jobs
smolders in war's end employ 600 people
it's desperate to have something done
about the cables and we've been making a
plea to the government since
2017 again no leveling up or in the case
of the cables leveling down here
far from leveling up in the northeast
the government is leveling down the
region as in total we receive less from
the leveling up and the shared
prosperity fund than we did from the eu
per year
so many doubts and so many concerns
about levy enough perhaps the government
should listen to the chief exec of ippr
north
who was who warns the government that it
must prioritize turning leveling up into
reality and that people need to feel the
benefit of ambitious actions with full
accountability
on this
critical agenda
the ipr
is urging the government to make itself
fully accountable
by including in the bill
a new independent body
outside of london to hold the whole of
government to account against legally
binding leveling up missions
i hope to see that there will be some
degree of leveling up and
i want to see a social and economic
level playing field not just for north
townside but for the whole northeast
will we get that in this leveling up and
regeneration bill
i doubt it
but what we will hopefully see in the
not too distant future is a labor
government that will deliver for our
area and keep its promises to the
northeast
it's norris thank you mr deputy speaker
and we meet today with
our constituents struggling more than
they have in my entire lifetime
and that comes off the back of what's
been a very very difficult decade or
more for people in my community
with anemic growth in the economy
virtually no wage growth
stagnant pay
and of course bills ever increasing
and millions of people across the
country have been just about managing
for a decade whether that's not going on
holiday whether that's not buying things
whether that's hand-me-down clothes
whether that's parents missing out so
their kids can eat they've just about
been keeping their head above water for
a long period of time
and that has now changed uh with
startling speed over the last six months
of that entire category of people
millions of people in this country very
many in my community have been have seen
their viability blown away by the
increase in their bills whether it's
inflation whether it's in the energy
bills whether that's at the petrol pump
and you know i don't like the cost of
living crisis as a frame it doesn't i
don't think it nearly states just how
serious this is this is a poverty crisis
and we should have seen in the
government's legislative agenda has set
out this week
um
a helping hand for working people to get
them through in their hour of need but
yet again true to form the government
have not been able to meet that moment
they could have introduced a windfall
tax on oil and gas companies and taking
hundreds of pounds off the energy bills
of millions they chose not to they could
have taxed online retail companies
fairly and given our struggling small
and medium entities a discount on their
business rates they chose not to and
they could have finally done the right
thing and cancelled the national
insurance right and again they chose not
to and what we've got is more of the
same in its place high taxes high
inflation low growth low pay
and low pay is a disease in my community
last friday i attended an event at
jubilee lead academy in bilbao in my
constituency and the inspiring young
students there had asked me to come to
hear about
their campaign to secure the real living
wage the proper one for care workers
many have parents who work in care and
saw the toll that hard work coupled with
poor pay has taken on their lives many
have have got relatives that are
recipients of care and saw just how hard
life is for those who made sure their
loved ones were looked after they wanted
to see those care workers looked after
as well they're fighting for better pay
and the government should listen to them
it shouldn't take this is a primary
school this is six seven eight-year-olds
well ahead of the adults that have
chosen to leave the country and instead
we get a promise of jam tomorrow and i
tell you there is no value in jam
tomorrow when there is not bread today
and and as just as pay is a core part of
decent work so is security it's now five
and a half years as we've heard since
the taylor report two and a half years
since the 2019 conservative manifesto
promised employment legislation in in
this place as we've heard 20 times the
government ministers have promised an
employment bill the minister in opening
the debate said that their commitment
was undiminished well i say gently
because he's a good man who i like a lot
you cannot make 20 promises of an
employment
act
fail to deliver one in the queen's
speech and then say that your
commitment's undiminished that's simply
beyond imagination and you know where
was
i'm old enough to remember the
commitment for the uk to being the best
place to work in the world where was
that where is that in this queen's
speech and still this vulnerable friend
of brent north has raised so
passionately we're stuck with fire and
re-hire a victorian practice but alive
and kicking and in two years we've seen
it used on a large scale three times
british airways british gas pno and
three times the government have missed
the opportunity to do something about it
we should be very cheered uh to have
seen news this morning that the the
deliveroo and the gmb have reached a
recognition agreement it shows once
again that the timeless
and
long-standing values of trade unionism
are as relevant as ever in the modern
economy and that will be good for their
staff and it will be good for their
business it is a partnership and one
doesn't come
one does not come at the expense of
others but we should have seen we should
see the government bringing forward
employment legislation rather than just
hoping that the answer is for people on
low in low paid work just to work longer
and harder to take more jobs operating
in a wild west of zero hours contracts
of bogus self-employment as colleagues
have raised and not really knowing what
they'll be earning from one week to the
next and according to the tuc the
failure to act in this area is costing
the treasury 10 billion pounds a year
what could we do with that 10 billion
pounds with people in regular employment
paying tax not relying on on social
security where you could meet forty
percent of the social care budget with
that alone
and we should
we should be chasing everyone so about
fairness at work we should be chasing a
more resilient economy one that is less
and less volatile to the markets and
through that one of my passions and
again you know colleagues to look at my
register of interest is by by building a
co-operative economy a new model uh of
ownership because we know that they're
more resilient and we you know we we got
very little hope very little optimism
through the queen's speech but we can
look outwards to find that in the
cooperative economy because those
businesses are at the coal face of this
current crisis cooperative and mutual
enterprises are putting people before
profit and supporting the vulnerable
while the government does not do their
bit it's them who are building a fairer
and more inclusive economy and they need
help you could do so much more we ought
to have a minister in government that
leads for co-ops we should strengthen
the credit union movement and support
our building societies providing
affordable and accessible banking in all
communities we could have had a british
macora law like the one they have in
italy so that when a business is on the
verge of collapse workers have the right
to buy that business out and so instead
of you know money being spent on
employment benefits resilient businesses
who pay well could be putting that
financial firepower back into
communities retaining good jobs keeping
the economy going and thriving and
instead of money going to non-descript
distant disinterested shareholders
actually would give a say to millions of
working people over their own lives and
the services that they use i think
that's a very exciting future in the
cooperative economy we do so much more
in that area but instead we see more
that's given us this lost decade of
growth at a national level in the
aggregate you know i i'm less excited
about gdp than i am what's in the
pockets of my constituents because their
pay packets they've see they're taken in
real terms less and less and less every
month and that's changed that's grown
exponentially in the recent months we
should have had action to help them
instead of these vague promises of help
in the future those won't do it's not
good enough and that's why i think
there's been the level of anger that has
on these benches we have to do better by
our constituents thank you
vinder mishra thank you speaker on
international nurses day i want to thank
all nurses in stockport and across the
world but particularly the members of
stockwood unison branch the health
branch which
i have a very good relationship with i
refer the house to my
my
register
of
the rest of interest particularly trade
union membership yeah
i just want to start off by associating
myself with the comments made on this
side of the house regarding the cost of
living crisis energy bills have gone up
significantly people on low income are
impacted uh disproportionately and it's
those people that need the most support
and
this this government is is failing
failing our communities
i was in blackpool last week on monday
for the usudo conference the the retail
workers trade union usd conference and
just before i cover the issues that some
of the retail workers
mentioned to me and i'm a former retail
worker myself i want to thank my good
friends the member for nottingham north
on all his work that he's done regarding
the freedom from free campaign that osto
has been running to protect shop workers
from
verbal abuse physical assault and all of
those terrible things that happened to
shop workers
retail workers tend to be some of the
lowest paid people in our economy they
tend to work long hours they tend to do
they often tend to be employed on zero
hour contracts and i'm grateful that
those door represents them just two key
points that usd has sent this to to
members of parliament a survey for from
retail workers regarding the cost of
living and two of the key
recommendations that the trade union is
making is a reduction in v80 from 20
percent to 17.5
and is also calling an urgent and
fundamental overhaul of universal credit
several members on this side of the
house have already raised issues with
universal credit and how it is having
a negative impact on on several on
several people so i hope i hope that the
minister will listen i hope the members
on opposite ventures
will listen and do something about about
that
issue just on the theme of cost of
living um
su supec from stockport car scheme wrote
to me recently
in case
members aren't familiar with local car
schemes stockport car scheme
particularly my constituency in heat and
more is a door-to-door transport service
for people living in stockport who
struggle to access public transport
community transport schemes like
stockport car schemes are always for
social purpose and never for profit
they support people who have mobility
issues cognitive impairments
disabilities long-term health conditions
and sensory loss they use volunteer
drivers who source their own cars to
take people take people to their
destination stockport car scheme is
calling for an immediate review of the
approved mileage rate that can be
claimed by volunteer drivers
there's been a significant increase in
fuel costs coupled with the inflation
and this is having a negative impact on
volunteer recruitment and retention
although the approved mileage allowance
payment amap
was set up was sort of last reviewed in
2012 at 45 pmil the rac foundation is
saying that the cost of motoring has
increased by 25 percent since 2012 and
that is before you take into account the
increase in fuel costs because of the
invasion of ukraine the crisis
in ukraine by russia's invasion
the higher fuel prices are having an
impact on
stockport car services now i'm sure
services across the country as some
drivers feel they're unable to continue
volunteering uh due to the extra cost
burden on them so i hope uh i hope that
the government will will review will
review this i'll move on to the issues
with waiting lists that has also been
raised significantly
there are several charities including
cancer research uk and macmillan that do
very important work when it comes to
supporting cancer patients families and
communities but actually if you look at
cancer service provision across across
the uk it often can be a postcode
lottery where if you live near a
hospital that has had the capital
investment you if if sadly you have
cancer or loved one has cancer they will
be treated with the latest equipment
latest medical equipment however if your
hospital is older then perhaps you won't
be that lucky so we need to tackle that
cancer research uk has conducted
research recently and
they informed me that 65 000 people 65
000 people
in england are left waiting to uh find
out if they have if they have cancer and
that's just that's just simply not
acceptable in one of the richest
economies in uh
in the world and on the waiting list
issue i want to tackle the issue around
nhs dentistry because nhs dentistry has
been deliberately underfunded by this
government pushing people into
completing remedies at home diy remedies
often in a lot of pain and yet again
it's a postcard lottery where in some
areas of the country you might be lucky
enough to find a slot or two with your
local dentist
on a nhs placement otherwise you have to
pay an extremely high amount of money
that not everyone can afford if you'll
allow me mr deputy speaker i want to
read out a piece of case work that that
i received regarding dentistry
and i'm quoting word to word i have gum
disease to the point all my teeth are
very loose i've tried and tried to get
nhs dentist as i don't work due to
mental health issues
i stayed in my bedroom for six years i
just couldn't get out to go private they
want 64 pounds from me just to be seen
then so much for my teeth to be taken
out and then dentures i've started to
get get out with the help of my sport
dog if i lose my teeth i will not go out
again i've phoned so many nhs dentists
and got nowhere i'm on the list at
king's gate house but that could take
years i really appreciate the waiting
list but i will not have any teeth by
them i would really appreciate your help
i phoned all the people i can i just
don't know which way to turn i hope you
can help me it's actually quite
upsetting to read that and speak to that
person and dentistry is is a very
serious issue it has an impact on your
physical health but also mental health
we need to see the government come
forward with the plan the british dental
association has done really good
research on this issue i urge the
minister and and her government to pay
attention to this issue and to tackle it
properly housing crisis has also been
covered by several several colleagues
colleagues here the local housing
allowance is simply not adequate enough
for for for the current rates in
stockport stockport's a fantastic place
to live but if you can't afford the
mortgage i mean the house prices have
significantly increased anyway but if
you can't afford a mortgage rents are
extremely high as well and the housing
allowance from the government is simply
not not enough i want to um mention that
uh 33 000 fewer socially rented homes
were built last year compared to 2010
and a huge increase in private renting
with households paying even higher rents
and rough sleeping up by 141 percent
i'll go back to what i said earlier mr
deputy speaker
the uk simply can't afford a
conservative government
these these stats are terrible there is
a there is some positive news on housing
i've got two local charities that do
some excellent work mr jonathan billings
from egg engage grow go he set up that
charity recently and he's a
long-standing campaigner and worker in
the homeless sector in the housing
sector and he's set up a local charity
and he's doing really good work on on
that so i'm really pleased to to have
his uh have his uh
guidance and support also wellspring a
local institution in stockport has been
helping homeless people and and
supporting them for for several for
several decades
there are so many cases there are so
many cases i can mention i'll just
mention one briefly i know
others want to get in as well
this is from from from a person a woman
sadly she was recently bereaved her
partner passed away and she's lived in a
one-bedroom apartment for 44 years i'll
read out the casework to you she and a
late partner live in a one-bedroom
apartment since 1970s therefore it is a
protected tenancy she informed the
landlord of the death of a partner and
the landlord immediately tried to
increase rent by 86 percent the landlord
son of the original landlord did not
realize that to increase rent in a
protected tenancy he would have to apply
to the rent office for consent and
valuation there is no progress on this
case yet but she's lived in that in that
property for 44 years
very little work has been done to the
property or maintenance and
in her own words it's a hovel
she's very worried that she's currently
paying only 350 pounds a month and
there's no way she could afford the new
rent or even rent on social housing what
are people like this supposed to do mr
deputy speaker when they can't afford
the rent the the waiting list for my
local housing provider for stockport
homes has over 7 000 households it's
going to take several years for her to
get anywhere where are these people
supposed to go
um
i have lots to say about buses usually
mr deputy speaker so i'll i'll keep
myself uh i'll i won't i won't go down
that rabbit hole but the rmt union is
running a campaign currently to protect
ticket officers because several uh
several places are seeing attacks on on
on
transport workers and ticket offices i
think the current prime minister when he
was in his former role closed down
ticket offices in the in in in on the
tfl network but we need to protect these
jobs because
we need to make sure that there's
support and help available for people
perhaps with mobility issues perhaps
with health issues that can seek support
if they need that support at
platforms there is a significant issue
with the lack of
disabled access and lack of safety tiles
at train stations
network rail have said that there are 41
stations across the state uh country
that will see a change there are a
couple in my constituency that
are going to be having this work done
but progress isn't uh quick enough in
the northwest the the software
constituencies in the northwest region
only 16 of train stations have
accessible ticket machines the worst in
the uk similarly only 18 of our ticket
offices are accessible compared to the
national average of 21
and only 8 percent of station toilets
are national key toilets compared to the
national average of 18
i'm i'm these figures are simply
shocking that there's the government
does talk a lot about decarbonization
and leveling up but when it comes to
supporting people to go onto public
transport network it simply doesn't
doesn't do enough i want to put on
record my i will i will happily give way
yes i thank i thank the young member for
giving way on that point and league rave
station in my constituency in newton
north is in exactly the same position
1.8 million journeys made from that
station before the pandemic and no lift
access no accessibility at all and it's
about time that we saw leveling up of
our stations as well as our towns
it's a very important point less public
relations exercises from the government
and more investment in our communities
it's it's needed and uh just on the
point on buses i i welcome the fact that
greater manchester combined authority
led by mayor andy burnham is introducing
bus franchising which will mean lower
fares more reliable services and
it will mean that private bus operators
don't cherry pick the most profitable
routes and leave communities
disconnected so that's that's that's
very good news uh with regards to going
back onto the trains mr deputy speaker i
i will finish i show you in
very very shortly um
stockport train station the only
mainline station in my constituency with
trains to manchester birmingham london
is victorian and it's pretty much
falling apart it's crumbling when it
rains heavily the platforms flood lift
is often broken it makes life of
passengers uncomfortable but also the
staff have a difficult time so i hope
the government can announce significant
investment in northern stations in
addition to train stations in in in
luton um but north first mr deputy
speaker that's okay i will conclude on
the point that um
there are several maintained nursery
schools in my constituency i'm proud to
have three maintained nursery schools in
stockport constituency hollywood park
lark hill and fresh fields they do a
really important job
communities across our country benefit
from
our maintained nursery school system
sadly though research by national
education union reveals that there are
only 389 such schools left in england
and many of which are located in the
most deprived areas of the country i
want to pay tribute to the hard work of
our good friend a former member for
birmingham erdington he led the campaign
to protect maintained nursery schools in
birmingham but across across england
the solution is they need
targeted support they need to be the
government needs to come forward with a
funding formula that will support these
schools going um
you know for the next decade rather than
year-on-year solution which creates
uncertainty and stress for for for the
for the community i could i could say a
lot more mr speaker but i don't want to
disadvantage other speakers so i'll
leave it there and i thank you for
calling okay very much graeme morris
thank you very much mr deputy speaker
and um i would uh i would also like to
concentrate my remarks on their fairness
at work and i'm more than happy to um
declare my entries in the register of
members interests and
very proudly
a member and indeed chair of the united
parliamentary group
and an associate member of many trade
union groups and i'm proud of that fact
i i believe mr deputy speaker that our
working conditions are a reflection of
the power balance uh within society and
indeed fairness at work is a similar
reflection
and i do recall just before parliament
before prorogation
the chancellor had reacted angrily to
questions about his own family's
finances
but at kitchen tables in my constituency
in the northeast of england
they're not talking about offshore
trusts and bank accounts in the cayman
islands
that the talk with kitchen tables of
families in east durham it is about
increasing fuel prices
the cost of living
higher prices for food for staples
and for staple items
uh having to pay more tax
there doesn't seem to be much discussion
about hiding assets in offshore tax
accounts
but of course the government could help
but they choose not to
and politics
and party politics in particular is
about choices
and i was quite
impressed with the government's
statement in the gracious address
to make to make this the united kingdom
the best possible place to live and work
but unfortunately the facts
kind of belie
that that we've had over 12 years now of
conservative government and you know
many government mps
and refer back to the last labour
government but i think it's a reasonable
assumption that given 12 years
if there was any intention of actually
improving the quality of life
particularly for working people then
there was there's ample evidence to have
achieved that over that path over that
period
i was incredibly disappointed that
despite numerous assurances given to
myself
and my good friend the honourable member
for southwest
glasgow and
my good friend
the member for middlesbrough and
indeed
the member for brent north that we would
have an employment bill in the
um in in the queen's speech i'm afraid
we haven't we're at 38 bills
and uh sadly
and nothing i am
on
nothing for workers
i think fairness at work means getting
paid enough to be able to participate in
the economy
it means being able to buy your own food
and not to be dependent on food banks
when when my parents were small
i might say my mother's celebrating her
86th birthday at the dinner
there weren't food banks there were soup
kitchens
you know and they've been replaced now i
don't feel that food banks were a sign
of economic success i think they're a
sign of economic failure
and and and sadly they also confirm
that work doesn't always pay there are
many people who are in insecure law paid
work who sadly are having to rely on
food banks
in order to put food on the table and
feed their families
and i think job security means being
able to turn on the heating without
being worried about
whether or not you can afford the bill
or to give your child access to decent
clothing
a housing
or even the internet
that these really aren't luxuries they
are the basic essentials
of a functioning modern economy in the
21st century and i certainly believe i
mean as a trades unionist good
businesses and there are many many
examples of good businesses
should be
standing side by side with their
employees as budget pressures and higher
inflation
is likely to lead to more
industrialistic disputes and higher peer
demands as people who are in work
obviously trying to secure better pay
rises
there have been opportunities for the
government to act
um
my honorable friend's no longer in his
place but
the the the minister who led the debate
on many occasions condemned the bully
boy tactics
of fire and rehire and unsc
unscrupulous
unscrupulous employers
but then
incredibly he himself
talked out the private members bill put
forward by by my friend the member for
bread north and i'm delighted to learn
and that in the other place
and the noble lord uh woodley and has
been successful in the private members
ballots so that where there'll be
another opportunity to to raise this
this issue
so
we've had we've had strong words from
government but sadly no action
the disgrace of the piano furries
and sucking british work where workers
breaking our laws
and hiring private security firms to man
handle
seafarers off the ships it's a disgrace
and
you know the
the the queen's speech delivers
um the seafarer's remuneration in
harbors bill
but one thing it has been able to do
it's united unions and indeed ports and
the employers
in criticizing this plan
um as being ineffective and unworkable
when the transport secretary said he
would stop at nothing
um in order to take piano furries to
task for their blatant disregard of uk
employment legislation i don't think any
of us actually expected him to do
nothing i thought we actually thought he
would do something
but it does seem to show that the rich
and powerful
can break the law with impunity
it's the same whether it's the
um senior management of piano or the
prime minister
because it seems to many people that the
system is built to protect the powerful
and ignore their wrongdoing
meanwhile many working families in
communities like mine in asington are
struggling
police officers whose retirement plans
are in tatters because of government
pension changes
or indeed the prison officers
leaving their job every day
because of terrible peer
and reducing and awful terms and
conditions
honourable member for watford who's in
his place at the moment um expressed
regret about the government's failure to
support his tips bill
well i also want to express regret that
the government
did not support my bill on prison
violence which was aimed to place a duty
on the prison and probation service
including private operators to minimise
violence in the workplace
i'll i'll
um i'd just like to clarify that uh the
government and the minister for small
business actually has been incredibly
supportive on my tips bill and i know
that there's continued work to make sure
that that will come through so but i
appreciate the the nod in the mention
thank you and i appreciate it
thank you
well well the honourable member is very
kind and i appreciate the tip i was
actually under the impression that
ministers were very supportive of my
bill because they were nodding as well
but unfortunately
that wasn't the case but um anyway i
wish him i wish him every success in
that um
but but in terms of the way the
government have treated prison officers
that the government ignored the peer
review and board
the expect prison officers to work until
year 68
and they ignore the issue of workplace
safety
in fact they seem to normalize or be
normalizing workplace violence and so
many prison officers are leaving the
service the ministry of justice
themselves have estimated that almost 87
000 cumulative years of prison officer
experience have been lost since 2010.
the loss of knowledge and experience a
problem replicated across many other
aspects of the public service it's
making workplaces less efficient and
more insecure and if we need any proof
in this
ask anyone any constituent who has
reported a crime applied for a passport
has sought to renew a driving licence
has reported anti-social behavior of the
council or is an urgent need of an
ambulance
there are many examples of the
government's mismanagement
a lack of investment and a single lack
of care for many of our communities
under the conservatives the purists are
expected to work harder and longer and
receive less this is a government that
seems to reward bad businesses
like piano furries
where those who cheat deceive and refuse
to pay their taxes are rewarded thank
you very much thank you very much dj
brock
mr deputy speaker uh in looking at the
uh issue of power in our communities
from a scottish perspective
this government's clear hostility to
devolution in scotland and the return of
sun powers to our country cannot be
ignored they've clearly forgotten it was
devolution that revived any sort of tory
presence in scotland after they lost all
of their seats following the 97 general
election nevertheless in 2020 we hear
the prime minister told a group of his
mps the re-establishment of the scottish
parliament had been a disaster and a
mistake the minister for brexit
opportunities stated he believes the
constitution was vandalized with
devolution and that the tories must undo
it
so no surprise then i suppose that this
program for government includes more
outright assaults on the devolved
settlement take the ironically named
brexit freedoms bill which seeks to
remove and restrict retained eu laws
this bill we're told is to extend and
apply across the uk but many of these
retained laws are actually incorporated
into acts of the scottish parliament
many indeed focused on the standards
this uk government seems so determined
to gut
so surely it should be for hollywood to
decide on their future not this place
and certainly not this government
now that eternal quest of most
conservative governments that fabled
bonfire of red tape promised so often
but never ever really delivered uh
indeed we've seen that
that bonfire of red type that uh pile of
red tape multiplied many times over with
brexit-created snarls
but it's now being promised for retained
eu legislation by the prime minister now
that will see standard slump as the
tories rip away legislation which has
protected scottish interests for almost
50 years
now brexiteers have never shied away
from hacking at workers rights and
certainly the tories haven't either
we've heard that from numerous mps today
members of parliament today and we in
scotland certainly don't trust this
government to even maintain our current
standards in areas such as these food
and the environment
and indeed
exactly
why that should be we've heard from
front benches opposite today this is the
government remember who appointed former
australian prime minister tony abbott to
the board of trade who apparently
previously bragged he was able to
fast-track international trade deals
because he wasn't sidetracked by details
like environmental standards and workers
rights
devolution and the power it returns to
our communities in scotland is being
further eaten away at by this government
so-called leveling up agenda in january
the house of lords constitution
committee's report on the plan said that
the uk government is simply ignoring
devolution and the calls for greater
transparency on funding decisions the
scottish government has no role in
deciding how this funding is allocated
and so which projects might align with
its priorities to deliver maximum
benefit this runs completely counter to
the principles of devolution and the
fact it's created by a government of a
political cue we in scotland have not
supported since the fifties with
priorities and values that we in
scotland do not embrace
surely illustrates again why the power
to make all our own decisions is the way
forward for our country
now what guarantees can the minister
give us that the scottish parliament
will not be forced to amend retained eu
eu law within its legislation the
scottish government intends to stay as
closely aligned to eu legislation as
possible what power does the government
scotland's parliament and ultimately
scotland's people have if those
decisions are stripped from their hands
and decided by westminster
and why by the way is the uk government
now concerned about retained eu law not
having received full democratic scrutiny
when it certainly wasn't bothered about
say international trade deals returning
to this chamber to be considered by
members before signing another one of
those questions i fear we will get no
reply to from that dispatch box now we
were also told that lost eu funding
would be replaced with equal if not
greater funds now that i'm afraid was
just more fibs from the cast members of
vote leave the scottish government
calculated 183 million pounds per year
was needed to replace different eu
funding streams
that scotland had previously received
this should mean scotland receiving 549
million pounds over the next three years
but we're only getting 212 million
pounds through shared prosperity funds
a 60 percent cut in real terms and
leaving us all with real fears for the
future of numerous community groups
across my constituency of edinburgh
north and leith and scotland
a particularly alarming admission i must
mention is the lack of any replacement
for one of the most valued eu funding
funded schemes in scotland the leader
program which supports more than 900
projects across rural scotland including
400 initiatives for young people and
disadvantaged groups the shared
prosperity fund doesn't replace it nor
can we see obvious opportunities for
access to similar support
now when questioned at the scottish
parliament on the rationale for
levelling up fund priority groups the
secretary of state for levelling up said
the conclusion about whether funding has
been distributed equitably will come at
the end of the process
i find that an absolutely extraordinary
admission from a government minister
surely allocations should be
continuously reviewed evaluated and then
reported and i'm pleased to hear that
the member for basing stoke who's no
longer in her seat in her place agrees
with that shortfalls in this funding
will likely mean the end of many
organizations and services that have
created
that have provided vital services to
communities for years or even decades
damaging even further the fabric of our
society in the midst of a cost of living
crisis and the biggest fall in living
standards in recent memory the
government's flagship policy to
rebalance power and resources swerves
scotland's
elected parliament and leaves our
communities with many many pounds less
in funding than we have with the eu how
can this be justified in a country where
every single local authority all 32
rejected brexit
not to mention of course outstanding
questions which i won't go into in
detail but i could about what appears to
be politically motivated choices
made around those funds
the people of scotland trust the
scottish parliament to make these
decisions the prime minister and his
wrecking crew of brexiteers seemed to
think that devolution was enacted merely
at the whim of a previous administration
and that it can simply be reversed with
a wave of their aristocratic hands they
have clearly forgotten so i will remind
them that in the 1997 devolution
referendum almost three-quarters of
voters backed the re-establishment of a
scottish parliament it was as david
cameron acknowledged the settled will of
the people and in the years since that
supporters mushroomed with polling from
2019 showing 93 percent of the scottish
public were in favor of the parliament's
existence that demonstrates clearly the
continuing support from communities in
scotland for power being returned to
them after more than 300 years of it
being locked away from them down here
policies like
free prescriptions for from everything
for from hrt to medicines for those with
long-term conditions
and tuition-free university education
have broken from conservative ideology
at westminster and met real benefits for
the people of scotland while tory
government free marketers stubbornly
refused to meaningfully support people
amid the
amidst the cods cost of living crisis
the scottish government has used its
limited powers to take measures such as
increasing scottish social security
payments by six percent and doubling the
scottish child payment to 20 pounds per
child per week with plans to increase it
further by the end of the year and
mitigate the impact
of hated uk government policies such as
the bedroom tax and the benefits cap at
a cost to the government of hundreds of
millions of pounds per year
every day the uk government fails to use
its reserve powers to tackle the cost of
living crisis it shows again quite
starkly why independence is the only way
for scotland to build that fairer
society we all want to see it's no
wonder that in last week's council
election the fortunes of the snp and the
conservatives were so contrasting um the
tory suffered their worst results since
1990 the s p won its 11th election in a
row
and following
consecutive emphatic election wins as
well as a clear majority in the scottish
parliament for another independence
referendum the mandate for that second
vote should be beyond dispute
further to that a new report into last
year's hollywood election by scottish
elections study carried out by six
academics across the uk concluded it was
independence what won it
for the snp government the study shows
that
the s p not only holds broad support
across a number of demographics it won
more than half of the constituency
ballot amongst voters voters born
outside the uk as well as a plurality of
those born in england surely a testament
to our outward looking and progressive
vision for scotland's future now just
finally uh mr deputy speaker it would be
remiss to talk about empowering our
communities without some remarks on the
online safety bill which if amended
could play an important role in
protecting and enhancing democracy at a
national and local level there's much in
the bill that we in the s p can support
but it does disappoint in its lack of a
credible plan to tackle online miss and
disinformation which is doing so much to
weaken our democracy
we think the online safety bill should
include robust measures on missing
disinformation the uk government should
follow the example of countries such as
sweden finland and latvia in building up
national
information resilience programs now the
government might point to
self-regulation by online platforms via
the ad transparency center but we have
learned tens of thousands of ads went
missing from facebook facebook's ad
archive in the final days of the 2019
general election
there are requirements for businesses
charities and public sector
organizations to communicate honestly
with the public about their online
activities and products but no such
provision exists for political parties
or campaign groups neither the
advertising standards authority nor the
electoral commission have the powers to
enforce basic standards of honesty in
electoral online advertising currently a
bad actor can run up a huge volume of
misleading online events
adversary invest large amounts of money
in breach of electoral law and if they
don't report it all their activities
aren't uncovered and reported there
would be no record of that advertising
having been placed
and various campaign groups established
as unincorporated associations which
sprang up like weeds just before the
last scottish elections used facebook
ads in particular to push political
links and it wasn't possible in most
cases to establish who paid for those
ads or the group's political
political links so i think that loophole
must be
closed that allows donations under the
spending limit or made directly to
political candidates um must be
looked at and closed by the government
so i would urge the government in
closing just to take this issue much
more seriously than it has examine
closely the dark side of political
advertising and take some real action
democracy is under threat like never
before and without democracy there is no
real power for our communities
thank you mr deputy speaker i'm grateful
for the opportunity to speak in today's
debate because whilst the government can
talk abstractly about leveling up the
country and addressing the housing
emergency it's people in my constituency
and constituencies across the country
who are paying the price of years of
failed policy and government in action
this queen's speech
proposes the rental reform and social
housing regulation bills i see these as
once in a generation opportunities to
build a new system in which everyone's
rights to safe and secure housing is
protected respected and guaranteed in
law
it is vital that this opportunity is not
squandered and i'll be holding the
government's feet to the fire to ensure
that it isn't because i am so sorry to
say their record today has hardly been
inspiring
we saw throughout the pandemic ministers
willingness to cast aside people in the
rented sector
the covert crisis only confirmed what we
already knew that rents are too high
and too precarious
um
renters rights are too precarious and
that too often rented accommodation is
unsafe or in poor condition
since i was elected in 2019 not a week
has gone by in which i haven't heard a
horror story
after horror story from people in chef
in my sheffield constituency about mold
damp exposed asbestos broken appliances
rats vermin
and many many other issues
tenants are afraid of speaking out in
case they face eviction or can't resign
their contract the following year
renters who are being gradually priced
out of areas by landlords that are
unchecked unchallenged and feel no
consequence for their actions
one family that i've been working with
can't put furniture against the walls as
this causes cavities where black mold
builds up this isn't enough just in a
handful of properties according to the
report by shelter
across the city in sheffield 28 of
private rentals contain category 1
hazards
such as excess cold or risks of falls
and 4
of those are in social rented
sector
to make matters worse my constituents
are often unfairly blamed for the
hazards themselves i constantly hear
people being told that black mold in
their properties is because of their own
ventilation problem that they need to
open their windows more and bleach their
walls
these are often families that i know
have been sitting in the cold with their
windows open all year round running
dehumidifiers at great cost constantly
and even a family who have been
innovatively but suddenly using sticky
back plastic on their walls that they
replace every three months to remove the
mold
with the rising costs of energy this is
all the more concerning the impacts of
this are far-reaching i've seen numerous
cases of new or worsening asthma in
children and adults
formally recorded by doctors as likely
to be linked to living in moldy or damp
housing conditions other families are
reported repeat infections
we are quite literally running returning
to the 1800s
and it's not only my constituents
physical health that is paying the price
every single person i speak to with
housing issues is experiencing some sort
of poor mental health as a result living
in conditions unfit for human habitation
is devaluing it makes people feel like
they don't matter the stress of having
to constantly complain and chase up
repairs is costing people literally
because they're having to take multiple
days off work to try and resolve these
issues and protect their families
our housing market market is
fundamentally broken this isn't a new
emergency but the covered 19 pandemic
has made it even more acute exposing and
worsen worsening cracks in the private
rented sector and pushing more people
into the long-term crisis of
homelessness debt and prosperity
in sheffield we see we saw a rise of 46
in the number of private renters
claiming housing benefit to help pay for
their rent during february 2020 and 2021
and nearly 3 000 households were made
homeless or threatened with homelessness
in the same period we know that the main
issue of affordable housing
uh that there is there isn't enough
being built
as shelter's recent report makes clear a
key part of our solution must be to
build more new good quality social
housing
investing in social housing will deliver
homes that local people can afford and
thrive in because genuinely affordable
social rents allow people to save and
build their lives between 1946 and 1980
an average of 126 000 council homes were
built every year
as of 2019
just
6826 were built
my city once famed for the constructions
of great public housing works including
the streets in the sky design of park
hill and the radical gleedless valley
estate now faces a year-on-year decline
in social housing stock largely as a
result of thatcher's right to buy
between
march 2015 and april 2020
1812 social homes were sold in sheffield
through right by and only 229 were built
but it's not just about the
affordability of rents it's also about
the quality of the housing and the
affordability of day-to-day bills
i'm pleased to say that sheffield labour
group has pledged to spend 350 million
to improve the quality of council
housing to upgrade all homes to epc ban
c retrofitting homes to make them warmer
and greatly cutting energy bills and
emissions our council now have plans to
build
3100 new council homes to the highest
energy efficiency standards but
unfortunately is nine nylon impossible
for local authorities to build enough to
maintain the rates let alone carry out
the
investment and maintenance that is so
desperately needed to improve council
stock as shelters leveling up with
social
housing reports states in order to truly
level up the city of sheffield we need
to provide be provided with the funding
to ensure sheffield can build the good
quality genuinely affordable social
homes it needs but to date the
government's ambition and leveling up
have stopped far short of the action we
need to see even
more done to maintain our current stock
of social housing and let alone provide
genuinely affordable warm homes a new
build as time ministers stepped up to
the challenge my constituents are tired
of poor quality housing they're tired of
high rents and struggling from paycheck
to paycheck to pay their rent and bills
we need a housing revolution and i'll be
fighting for that to ensure that this is
what these two bills provide
i'd also just like to pay tribute to my
honorable friend the member for fancy
central for his work as the
mayor of south yorkshire i think it's
incredibly brave for people to put
forward themselves for permission
for election and i'd like to
congratulate uh oliver copper for being
the new mayor and all candidates up and
down the country who've taken the brave
step to represent and build power in
their communities i think there's a lot
in this queen's speech which is missing
and i know that colleagues today have
outlined very eloquently
um the issues of not having the
employment bill we have seen today lots
of issues raised about taking away the
ability of people in our communities to
live independently and be empowered to
get the best out of their lives and i
think it's incredibly
telling that we see what i'd call a
yorkshire mix
of bills which is a bag of boiled sweets
which are all different from this
because i don't know what the ideology
of this government is because it seems
to be in different departments there's a
different flavor of right-wing ideology
going on and i think that that is very
confusing to people up and down the
country who are facing a cost of living
crisis when their clear demands are to
live well live healthily live in warm
homes have good quality well-paid jobs
backbench contribution kirsten oswalt
thank you very much mr deputy speaker
people across the nations of the uk have
had a difficult couple of years and i
fear that these difficulties or at least
as the uk government calculates it
provide a perfect cover for the prime
minister's current chaos and his
government's failure to deliver on
promises stay out in his party's
manifesto he did however deliver a
severely undercooked brexit which
scotland didn't vote for but for which
we are all now paying a high price
so this week was the prime minister's
opportunity to chart a way forward
if he intended delivering on his
promises
but instead the queen's speech showed
him for what the people of scotland have
long known him to be
so instead of measures of substance to
help people in challenging times we have
a queen speech of missed opportunities
and what we don't have is anything that
seriously addresses the themes of
today's debates which are fairness at
work and power in communities
of course if the uk government had any
interest in delivering fairness at work
in properly thinking about the future of
work the long-promised employment bill
would have been amongst the bills in the
queen's speech it was a conservative
manifesto pledge in 2019 after all but
despite the numerous promises yet again
it's nowhere to be seen
and that's a great shame because for too
many people the labour market in the uk
is broken as was demonstrated during the
pandemic
millions of the self-employed and
directors of small companies got no
support because their place in the
labour market didn't fit the treasury
model some of the most vulnerable
continued to work because statutory sick
pay leaves people in poverty and many
just stopped receiving takes calling to
them to shifts and found themselves in
limbo with nowhere to turn
this was the uk government line in 2019
and i quote the prime minister was clear
that he's determined to make the uk the
best place in the world to work
once brexit is done we will continue to
lead the way and set a high standard
building on existing employment law with
measures that protect those in low paid
work to coin a phrase madam deputy
speaker what a load of baloney that has
all proved unsurprisingly to be nonsense
so where are the measures to improve
employment where are the measures to
improve fairness in the workplace where
is the right to flexible working they're
all missing where is the stronger legal
protection for pregnant employees for
new parents for carers these things are
missing too where's the single
enforcement body to protect employee
rights it's missing
the queen's speech should have featured
reform of the chronically failing shared
parental leave scheme recent figures
show just two percent of new mothers use
the scheme to transfer some of their
paid leave to the child's father now no
one defends that scheme no one pretends
it works it's been under evaluation by
the uk government since april 2018
but evidently addressing that undisputed
failure doesn't merit legislation
piano ferries stacking 800 workers
without notice should have been a
wake-up call for wider reform of
employment law and for urgency in that
regard but instead the uk government has
focused solely on the narrow issue of
pay for seafarers through the harbours
seafarers remuneration bill
these plans have been called feeble and
likely unworkable by francis o'grady of
the tuc and the bill leaves and address
the wider issues of fire and rehire
and the thing is the parliamentary
calendar being what is any interventions
in the labour market not started this
year stand little chance of ever seeing
the light of day so without the
protection of eu law much of which it's
the intention of this government to
strip away uk workers
face greater unfairness in the workplace
not less
an echo what my honorable friend has
said today she said that the labour
party must step up and support our calls
to devolve employment law don't enable
this tory government which scotland did
not vote for to sell our workers short
and have to say to this house that the
people in scotland didn't vote for this
future at all
we in the snp are committed to making
sure they have that opportunity to
choose a different future and an
independent scotland
where delivering fairness is not just an
electoral sound bite
so i also challenged labour party and
liberal democrats to recognise the right
of the people in scotland to choose that
better independent future instead of
once again siding with the tories in
their race to the bottom
and the other stand of debate today
madame deputy speaker is power in
communities i must have a different
understanding from the uk government of
what community means and i see little
sign of a community focus and approach
adopted by them either in response to
this cost of living crisis or in the
proposals or the missing proposals in
this queen's speech and i see that the
prime minister's adopted the simple
tactic of denying the link between the
actions or inaction of his government
and people's very understandable anxiety
about their bills that won't wash voters
can see for themselves that the uk
government is actively choosing courses
of action which affect their lives in
the most challenging of ways
so this uk government is choosing to
load on tax rises it's choosing to cut
universal credit by over a thousand
pounds it's choosing not to upgrade
benefits by something closer to the
current rate of inflation
just contrast that with the scottish
government's prompt action to operate
the limited number of benefits it
controls to support families via the
groundbreaking scottish child payment
contrast the uk government approach with
their missing employment bill to the
scottish government's focus on fair work
and the uk government is actively
choosing to damage communities in other
ways too they're taking a wrecking ball
to human rights and the dignity of the
individual
having closed off legal routes to reach
the uk in an emergency the uk government
moved on to its important nationality
and borders bill criminalising those who
use another route and now they've
adopted the inhumane policy of paying a
third country to take those who make it
to the uk off their hands
so not only is that policy morally wrong
and a shocking waste of taxpayers money
there are serious questions about the
safety of those sent including lgbt
people
under this plan
and i must reflect my honorable friend's
remarks in terms of the contrasting
approach to refugees between the
scottish and uk government and like him
i very much welcome the election um of
rosa sally
and think that the the way forward will
surely be one where more people are
included in our democratic systems but
that's not the approach that this uk
government's taking their decision to
continue with their hostile environment
instead of building an immigration
system founded on community on decency
and unfairness is the same a fear of
what's to come
and the safeguards and the human rights
act are an essential feature of our
democratic society and our commitment to
the rule of law and whether the uk
government likes it or not they're also
as we've heard from my honourable friend
from edinburgh north and leaf at the
heart of the devolution settlement and
changes must not be made without the
consent of the scottish parliament
looking at the report of the independent
review of the human rights act it's
difficult to disagree with the quote
since its passage the human rights act
has faced a steadily escalating series
of attacks designed not just to
undermine the act but at times the very
concept of human rights a genuine case
can be made that the act has faced a
series of attacks without president for
a piece of legislation in one
piece of legislation in modern british
history and the queen's speech was the
next in that series of attacks it should
really bring shame on the uk government
but having heard some of the remarks
from members opposite today their
approach to rights
is
to deny that they should exist
and the uk government should also be
ashamed by the way that they have
treated the issue of conversion therapy
in the queen's speech
there's no conversion practices which
are acceptable and provisions put in
place must be trans-inclusive and they
need to get a move on too given the
serious harm that these practices cause
in this house on the 30th of march the
responsible minister the member for
finchley and golder's green said both
the national lgbt survey of over a
hundred thousand lgbt people and the
in-depth coventry report demonstrated
that violent and harmful talking
conversion practices continue to take
place that's why we need to act but
shamefully within hours it became clear
that the uk government would not use its
proposed ban to protect trans people and
in fact it took a public outcry to get
them to roll back on what looked like a
refusal coming down the line to protect
anyone at all
and their excuse for their decisions
there was the need to clear the
legislative decks for the cost of living
crisis and the ukraine war
but it's now clear to all of us looking
at the queen's speech that there is no
significant bodies of legislation being
brought forward on these issues so that
excuse doesn't wash what is the fig leaf
for that discriminatory decision
so it's a dark road that this
government's traveling down in many ways
with skirt regards can't regard for
people that are struggling to manage
because of this tory cost of living
crisis a race to the bottom on rights a
willful disregard for workers and i
would repeat again what my colleagues
have said today that the people of
scotland deserve better and they have a
right to reject this
shadow minister lisa nand yeah yeah
thank you very much out there in the
country a crisis is unfolding we have
the biggest fall in living standards
since the 1950s pensioners boarding
buses to keep warm food banks are
handing out cold boxes to families where
both parents
grind for a living that pays so little
that they can't even heat the food that
is handed out to them by charity when it
should be given as a right
we've had an uprising across the north
of england demands for more power in
scotland in wales in the midlands and
the south we need to rewrite the script
ditch old orthodoxies end the injustice
of whole communities written off and
written out of the national story by
governments with far too little ambition
in every corner of this country people
are crying out for change and this
government's big idea
is referendums on street names and an al
fresco dining revolution is this it
seriously is this
it
can't they see
how absurd it is to tour tv studios
talking about a medici style renaissance
of our towns villages and cities when
high streets are falling apart and many
town centres in every part of this
country are now no go areas for people
who live there
when homes as my friend the member for
sheffield hallam said a cold and damp
and communities are broken apart by
policies that force people to move into
insecure housing miles away from friends
and families
and while they tour the country reading
out lists of leisure centres that have
had a lick of paint
funded by a small refund of our money
that has been taken from us over a
decade on every measure wages homes
transport life expectancy the gap is
growing and britain is going backwards
aren't they ashamed to stand there and
say they're getting the country firing
on all cylinders spreading prosperity
widening opportunity when bloomberg this
week showed that in nine out of ten
constituencies the salary gap is
widening
almost everywhere homes are unaffordable
and public spending has fallen behind
london in every single region of england
in the two years since this government
was elected
and took office with a promise to level
us up are they not ashamed
i thought it was pretty brave of this
government to enshrine the leveling up
missions in law given that appalling
record but then
i read the small print
and it turns out they're not even doing
that the big flagship promise and
they're not even delivering that tucked
away in this
325 page bill it says the minister may
revise the current statement of
levelling up missions so as to change
the mission progress methodology and
metrics or target date
madam deputy speaker this is exactly
what we've come to expect they say
they'll build 300 000 houses a year and
then they they don't they promise
northern powerhouse rail 60 times 60
press releases over seven years and then
they ditch it they've given more money
to fraudsters than the whole of the
north of england in the last year
the bus subsidy as the member for
stockport said quite rightly was quietly
halved when no one was watching
they've closed dwp offices across our
regions and remember that promise that
when we left the european union we would
take back control and the money that
used to
flow freely back to us through brussels
would be protected that promise thrown
in the bin the cabinet is meeting in
stafford today and frankly madam deputy
speaker i do not know how they have the
nerve stafford is one of those places 35
million pounds has been lost from
stafford because of this government's
decision to hold on to money that
belongs to us a billion pounds taken
from communities in england i'm starting
to think they're just incapable of
keeping any simple promise after all the
talk all the spin the only people that
seem to have taken back control are a
small group of ministers in whitehall
any government worth having would have
used this queen's speech to get money
into people's pockets scrapping business
rates bringing in a winful tax on the
big oil and gas producers to get money
of people's energy bills
madam deputy speaker it's not just that
they don't back us
when
companies are making record profits and
we're struggling to heat our homes it's
that they're actively working against us
this is the only government in any g7
economy to put up taxes on workers
during a cost of living crisis now i
gave up looking for this government's
moral compass a very long time ago but
the economic stupidity of this is
breathtaking
next year we're forecast to have the
slowest growth of any g7 country that's
why leveling up matters more not less at
a time like this we should be turbo
charging this program and investing in
our communities in the nine years
leading up to the pandemic almost a
decade of tory rule only two of the 38
oecd countries invested less than
britain and this is how you get high tax
and low growth and a cost of living
crisis because it turns out if you slash
solar you ban onshore wind and you
degrade gas storage you get an energy
bills crisis it turns out that when
you're the education secretary and you
axe the scheme to build schools fit for
the future you end up with an 11 billion
repair bill and one in six kids in
schools that are falling apart now he
tells us that he wants to raise school
standards and enshrine them in law give
me a break you see the difference
between us and them is that we believe
in our communities and we're prepared to
back them we would invest 28 billion a
year every year for a decade to bring
back the good jobs that underpin our
local economies so kids from barnsley to
aberdeen have choices and chances to
leave if they wish and to stay and
contribute if they can so that geography
is no longer destiny remember that
phrase and young people don't have to
get out to get on madame deputy speaker
this is not a plan this is a
325 page obituary of the government's
leveling up program
this press release that i have here
promises real power but i think we've
learned by now not to trust the spin
because remember the secretary of state
who promised to throw open doors to
welcome refugees from ukraine but he
didn't did he
two hundred thousand families came
forward in britain to provide a home to
people fleeing vladimir putin only
twenty six thousand of them have been
able to make a home here after years of
delay in agony for leaseholders he said
he'd make developers pay but he didn't
did he
because we got a meeting and then
another press release but for all the
agony the agony continues so what does
this promise to implement the biggest
shift of power from whitehall in modern
times actually amounting well first of
all the right to a better home that was
published literally i'm not joking while
the secretary of state was on tv
abandoning his commitment to actually
build them what on earth is the point of
the right to something that doesn't
exist an announcement to make it easier
for councils to bring boarded up
properties back into use an idea so good
that when we called for it back in
september they said
it was a rehashed and failed policy
first proposed by jeremy corbyn i didn't
realize that the secretary of state took
his advice from jeremy corbyn it goes to
show they went on that labour have
absolutely nothing new to offer to our
country i'm pleased to see they've come
round to our way of thinking
but seriously how many times do they
think they can do this the flashy
headline grabbing offer and then you
look at the small prince
so what is this power a share of the
infrastructure levy but only if you set
up a town or parish council
more powers but only if you take them
there and only if you live in an area
that the chancellor has deemed
economically viable and not written off
like large ways of the country and even
then only a privileged few friends of
the secretary of state seem to get any
of the powers that they need my
honourable friend the member for
barnsley central was an outstanding
mayor for south yorkshire but imagine
what he could have delivered for the
people of south yorkshire if he had had
the powers that he was clamoring for
throughout his entire
time in office and you know what madame
deputy speaker right as i went through
this bill
it turned out that the only thing that
we actually get the right to decide for
ourselves is what our mayor is called
i'm not joking three pages i'm actually
not joking three whole pages in this
bill are dedicated to giving us the
right to pick a new name
for our mayor a medici style renaissance
this is not in fact it's just
patronizing nonsense or as the member
for east renfrewshire said a load of
baloney
the secretary of state bragged in his
quote that accompanies the press release
that he's going to allow every part of
england which wants a london-style mayor
to have one can i just say gently again
to the front bench on the other side
that not everywhere in this country
wants to be london we're proud of london
we love london but not everywhere wants
to be the same i certainly will i think
the right-wing remember to give away um
on the topic of london i'm sorry labour
labour mayors
i wanted to know if the writers will
remember shared my concern that the
labour mayor who came in shrimp is
currently under investigation for
bullying um a huge number of staff of
that authority
i would be very careful if i were him to
try and give our side lessons about
bullying given the allegations that were
found to have merit against the home
secretary and many other members of his
front venture i think you know you
wrestle with a pig you get covered in
stuff and i would just be very careful
if i were him at using this place to try
and throw mud at us if only the
secretary of state had come to us and
said that he couldn't do it if only just
said to us look the treasury has blocked
it number 10 has ditched it the cabinet
officers laughed at it if you'd come to
us and said work with me because
together we might achieve this we would
have been far more sympathetic today but
instead what we get is 325 pages
that marks the death of the government's
leveling up agenda well if they won't do
it we will like my friends the member
for easington said
we will proactively depend
defend and support the people who power
this country we won't stand aside when
workers are thrown on the scrap heap
it really does make a nonsense of claims
to level up when you have a shower of
ministers who don't lift a finger to
help hundreds of piano workers until the
news is made public today gmb and
deliveroo have shown that the jobs of
the future can be jobs you raise a
family on
dignity security and respect
and as the member for watford who is
here
uh to listen to these winding up
speeches said he's run an admirable
campaign to protect the tips of
hard-working staff from unscrupulous
employers
but where is the employment bill that's
been promised 20 times seriously where
is it
we will put money back in people's
pockets through a windfall tax so they
can spend on our high streets and our
town centres can thrive again again
we'll aggressively chase down the jobs
of the future not an empty procurement
bill not a government that promises to
bring renewable jobs to britain and then
awards a contract to build wind farms in
five to a yard in indonesia but a real
strategy to make buy sell more in
britain will close the gap that's seen
only two regions of the uk prosper in 19
of the last 20 years and 12 years of
managed decline of our nations and
regions under the tories by investing in
good jobs transport digital skills
entitled hydrogen solar and wind we will
rebuild our coastal and industrial
communities these are places that were
once the engine room of britain they're
within living memory we powered the
world and we will do again
whether it's shipbuilding in glasgow
textiles in preston and burnley mining
in wales and wigan or fishing in grimsby
the people that make our great towns and
cities were the people who drove britain
forward and they deserve so much better
than this
those jobs may have gone but what
remains is a fierce determination that
we will contribute again not to the
history books but to our future
we deserve a government that shares that
ambition our ambition for our
communities and for britain and that is
why labour will do this with the best
asset that we have our people
if i've learned anything in the last 12
years it's that people who have a stake
in the outcome and skin in the game try
harder they work longer they think more
creatively and they do more because so
much is at stake that is why this bill
should have been the moment to hand real
powers to our communities so that no
longer are we forced to go begging cap
in hand to whitehall for loose change
and small powers that we know will work
for us every community in this country
has the right to make a contribution to
the national effort not just some
and it was george orwell who is forever
associated with my town through the road
to wigan pier who said that this is the
country that lies beneath the surface
and it is time for that country to take
charge of its own destiny it is time for
this tired government out of energy out
of ideas to get out of the way so that
we can build it yeah
minister comey
thank you madam deputy speaker and it's
my pleasure to close today's debate on
behalf of the government and the
department for leveling up housing and
communities and i'd like to begin by
thanking honourable members on all sides
of this house who contributed to today's
long and lively debate following her
majesty's gracious speech earlier this
week but before i say more on how we're
delivering on our pledge to strengthen
communities to rebalance our economy and
level up parts of the country i first
want to address as many uh of the points
that were raised by honourable members
during today's debate
so i will start with the member for
sheffield south east who asked uh where
is the money i don't think that he is in
his place but i would like to thank him
for his substantive engagement with the
issues far more pretty much than anyone
else on the opposition benches um i'm
pleased that he found some things to
praise in uh in the set of bills that
we're bringing forward unlike his
colleagues although i also saw that he
was uh
also claiming credit for the policies
that he did agree with i'm not quite
sure
whether that is the case or not but he
did he did ask uh where is the money and
the point that i want to make i know
quite a few people um will be making
this throughout the coming speech is
that leveling up needs more than money
we have been uh we have been providing
funding but it needs more than just that
and clearly um funding alone has not
eliminated regional equality so clearly
other types of actions are required and
the member for barnsley east actually i
agree with his anecdote when he talked
about western east germany and the
trillions of pounds that were spent it's
not just about pouring money into areas
that is not going to deliver leveling up
alone i do disagree with the point made
by the member uh for um
for sheffield south east uh leveling up
means taking from welfare areas to other
areas it is not a zero-sum game i also
um
i found his idea of devolving every
single decision um down to the most
local level interesting i think if we
did take this radical idea as he's
described it he would then be
complaining about postcode lotteries as
well but just to answer um his question
on what new powers will combined
authorities have and what i would say is
that the final package of powers will be
bespoke depending on the needs and
proposals from
from local areas so mayors could have
increased powers over budgets employment
skills transport health and social care
and policing but what the leveling up
and regeneration bill does is it
streamlines the process for a combined
authority proposing additional powers so
what it's doing is it's making it easier
to devolve more powers to existing
mayors by making the process easier as
long as they agree to take on uh greater
greater responsibility so it's a
flexible choice which is why the detail
which he was um looking for won't be
that it will be dependent on the on the
proposals that are brought by the mayors
themselves um many uh members raised
really good points the member for north
somerset asked questions about the
inflationary shock global commodity
prices and monetary inflation which i am
not able to answer i'm sure treasury
ministers will do so but he also made a
really good point about conflicting aims
which arise uh when we're trying to
deliver housing and i hope that he will
take part in further debates at second
reading which hopefully should address
those issues the member for beijing
stoke talked about the need to have
effective monitoring of leveling up i
think that will be found in the um
leveling up or and regeneration bill or
the lerb as we call it we have embedded
the missions in there we recognize there
is a need to help everyone everywhere
because there are pockets of deprivation
all over the country not just in um
entire regions and i look forward to
hearing her further contributions on
that the member for mitchum and morden
talked about the secretary of state um
uh saying that we did not have a housing
target anymore i'm afraid that is not
true that is a straw man he did not say
that he simply said that the housing
target is not the only way we are
measuring success we're also looking at
issues like beauty and infrastructure
the environment and neighborhoods that
doesn't mean that we don't have a
housing target anymore and the member
for huddersfield complained that the
secretary of state was not here to
yes yes of course i'll apologize for
being a little bit late getting back
i've been speaking at the housing
conference so i had rushed back uh i'm
deputy speaker uh just on the target
which was mentioned before
right the government's got a target mrs
just said could mr confirm that the
target is to build 300 000 homes a year
before the end of this parliament
i confirmed that we have not changed
anything about our targets but we are
looking we are yes well i'm agreeing
with him we are looking at other things
beyond targets it's not just the
statistical it's not just a statistical
number and the member for christchurch
uh raised a point about vaccines and
vaccine payment damage again that's
another issue which i'm not able to
answer at the dispatch box but i know
that the vaccines minister would have
heard his comments and i hope that he
will be uh receiving a response on that
shortly he made wider points about the
economy um which i think will be
addressed again
next week during the debate uh around
energy uh the member for south dorset uh
made many points which i agreed with
including um on employment and i just
wanted to recognize what he was saying
about um risk takers being the employers
themselves i think that is something
that we do often forget when we talk
about employment
the member for middlesbrough complained
about the legislation in this session
and the last session the fact is the
legislation that we're bringing forward
were in our manifesto there were
manifesto commitments and we won an
election on those manifesto commitments
so what he should do is ask himself why
he is at odds with the wishes of the um
the electorate the member for bretton
north made a passionate speech as usual
but as usual i disagreed with most of it
um the memphis talked about ethnicity
pay gap reporting she and i have
discussed this
many times what i would say to her is
that there is a review coming about
gender pay gap reporting and how
successful it has been i think it'd be
quite interesting for us to have a
conversation to look at yes yes i'll
give way on that point
of point of order okay
the honourable lady had just mentioned
myself as a member of huddersfield she
was interrupted i think she was about to
say what a wonderful speech i'd made and
the key points and she was interrupted
but quite legitimate even my colleague
she never actually finished
talking about me
as the
horrible gentleman knows perfectly well
that is not
a point of order for the chair it is a
point fishing for compliments
he's not going to get one from the chair
[Laughter]
nor i fear from the minister i'll go on
camera
a point of order
now i just may i just balance the
equation because i did try to get in
having been mentioned in the house i
wasn't allowed to so i'm feeling like
the old member just the same the same
might
make the same same point it's the same
for both sides
yes i thank the honorable gentleman
he's not going to get any compliments
either
that's it now let us return to the
subject of the debate
minister
thank you madam deputy speaker i think
the member for huddersfield was just
begging for a shout out just there and
so i'm happy to give him one his points
were wonderfully bonkers and i disagree
with most of them but i'm very happy to
give way to the member for battersea
can i thank the minister for giving me
when she rightly talks about the issues
around gender pay gap and ethnicity
pay gap reporting does she agree with me
that it's also time to now review
disability pay gap reporting so that we
can address the disability employment
gap but more importantly we can get that
data impairment specific data that will
really highlight some of those flaws
that we have in relation to disabled
people and employment
minister i think she raises a good point
um on disability pay gap reporting the
metrics which we would be using would be
quite significantly different um there
are
issues around ability which means that
disabled people are at a serious
disadvantage compared to others but i
think that that's something that we are
exploring already it's certainly
something that we keep under review and
of course i'm happy to take those
conversations offline um
and discuss them later uh the member for
sheffield hallam talked about social
housing regulation she made some good
points and i think uh when my colleague
uh the uh minister for homelessness and
rough sleeping is taking that bill
through the house there'll be many
things that he'll be able to answer
which i cannot do at this point um the
member for watford spoke very movingly
about loneliness and has been a powerful
advocate for fairness in the workplace
and his tip spill and mental health uh
first stage in the workplace ten-minute
rule bill are evidence of this i also
note the points made by the member for
gaddling i think you'll find that
they'll be addressed in the renters
reform bill and we can provide further
details on that in due course i was
amazed that the member for enfield north
said that the white paper the leveling
up white paper was dead it was nearly
400 pages i mean this is proof that
labour mps don't bother to read anything
um with 400 pages of policies and ideas
it's quite frankly um insane to pretend
that that white paper is thin i would
encourage them to engage with the
content
now the fact that the majority of this
debate has consisted of members opposite
asking where is the employment bill
simply shows the paucity of their
arguments we have promised an employment
bill but the vast majority of
legislation to improve workers rights
does not need to come in a package
titled employment bill i was in the
treasury when we implemented probably
the greatest employment protection
scheme ever devised in this country the
furlough scheme it did not need any and
it no i'm not giving away on this point
because many members have risen i think
they should listen to the point i'm
making rather than interrupted the fact
is the greatest employment protection
scheme ever devised in this country
country the furlough scheme was done it
was an example of how this government
acts innovatively nimbly and quickly to
deal with the serious issues of the day
since then we have already
i'll give away i'll give away the
minister for a giving way she can't have
it both ways you can't i i i give
opposition members any trouble saying
all the bills tabled this time our
manifesto commitments an employment bill
was in the 2015 conservative parliament
my party manifesto 2017 conservative
party manifesto and the 2019
conservative party manifesto so when is
the government going to table an
employment bill we should promise in
january this year
what they're
madam deputy speaker is that you don't
need an employment bill to deliver
employment legislation and we are still
committed to one but the fact remains
that we have already made progress on
legislation or order order
the honorable gentleman thinks i didn't
notice that he wasn't here at the
beginning of the minister's speech he
may not intervene when he wasn't here at
the beginning of the minister's speech
minister
the fact remains that we have already
made progress on legislating to
strengthen workers rights we've closed
the loophole which saw agency workers
employed on cheaper rates than permanent
workers we quadrupled the maximum fine
for employers who treat their workers
badly the fact is on this side of the
house we measure how well we are doing
not by the title of legislation but by
the fact that we have delivered record
levels of high employment and
moving to the points made by um the
honorable lady on the front bench she
criticizes us for not doing enough on
the cost of living but i will remind the
house that the last autumn budget when
she and all of her colleagues had an
opportunity to reduce the cost of living
like the rest of them she voted against
measures in the autumn budget to reduce
the universal credit paper reduction
which effectively would have given a
thousand pounds tax cut for low-income
families something which would fail to
support those on the lowest incomes so
we don't buy their argument that they
are interested in the cost of living
because when the legislation comes
forward they vote against it she also
criticized the leveling up and
regeneration bill just as she did the
leveling up white paper i remember her
comments during that debate they were
all sneering and no substance from
someone who clearly again had not taken
the time like remember for enfield north
to read it she is constantly playing
catch up because her immediate priority
is to criticize instead of engaging with
the policy detail and that's why the
five-point plan that she wrote in
january consisted of five recycled
policies we're already carrying out and
some sour finger pointing that is not an
action plan the fact is we have done
quite a bit on the cost of living we're
supporting families with the cost of
living with 22 billion pounds worth of
support in 2022-23 and delivering the
biggest net out to personal taxes in
over a quarter of a century our plan for
jobs as i mentioned earlier is bringing
unemployment back below pre-pandemic
levels we're delivering 9.1 billion
pounds energy rebate with 150 council
tax rebate we're increasing the value of
the warms homes discount to 150 pounds
and expanding eligibility to cover
nearly 3 million households we're
protecting i'm not giving away because
they don't want me to list these things
we're protecting the vulnerable
including pensioners with winter fuel
payments of up to 300 pounds and cold
weather payments of 25 pounds a week we
delivered a record cash increase in the
national living wage meaning a thousand
pound salary boost for new full-time
workers we've raised the national
insurance threshold from july saving an
average worker 330 pounds a year we've
cut field duty by 5p for 12 pounds a
month and as i mentioned we've cut the
universal credit taper rate no i'm not
giving way because the selective amnesia
of members opposite never ceases to
amaze me they refuse to acknowledge the
policies which they know we've carried
out which they agree with they pretend
money isn't being spent when we have
spent it and of not just spent but spent
unprecedented amounts so there is no use
giving way for them just to repeat the
same arguments that they have been
making over and over during the course
of the debate now i will move on to the
comments made by the member for barnsley
central um he talked about leveling up
leveling up funds and um
and money for local government as a
local government minister he knows that
this is something that i care very
passionately about and i do know that
i'll be working i know he's no longer
the the mayor but i will be working with
um local government leaders across the
country we've boosted funding to
councils by 3.7 billion pounds this year
an increase of over 4.5 in real terms
which will ensure councils have the
resources they need to deliver key
services and the poorest areas will
receive 14 more uh per household than
the least deprived areas so um in terms
of who got leveling up with um who got
leveling up funding the truth is all of
this is based on the quality of the bids
we can't guarantee that every bid is
going to be worth um it's going to be
something that we can fund compared to
what's um being presented by by others
the other thing um that uh members
office it says that we've done
absolutely nothing for the last 12 years
just to remind them again that in the
last three years the last three years
alone we tackle the greatest public
health emergency in a generation we
delivered a historic funding boost to
the nhs we've ended the cruel lottery of
social hair social care costs with our
36 billion pound health and social care
plan we've led the world in the fight
against climate change with our clock 26
presidency and we've also tackled crime
closing over 1500 county lines um we've
delivered for the whole united kingdom
madame deputy speaker securing vaccines
for all four nations and agreeing the
largest funding settlements since um
since devolution i'll give way thank you
for giving way if the conservative
government have done all of these
wonderful things how come my
constituents can't afford to eat
i'm afraid um the honourable lady is
being disingenuous um with with her
[Applause]
with her question with with the way
she's presenting the argument she knows
she knows um
i will withdraw the remark um i will
draw the remark madam deputy speaker she
knows that i do not know the specific
circumstances of her constituents what i
can tell her is what the government is
doing i would ask her given that we have
devolved so much policy to the scottish
government is what is the scottish
government doing to help her constituent
and i will go back to saying what it is
that we have been doing um in this
country and uh the fact is we have
delivered for the whole united kingdom
securing vaccines for all four nations
and agreeing the largest funding
settlement since devolution and it is
also ridiculous for us to be criticized
for not devolving more by um labour
members opposite in 13 years of labor
government there was no devolution
except in london we created so many
devolution deals we even provided jobs
for three labour mps including tracy
brabant andy berman and until recently
the member for bardsley central and they
say that we're doing nothing on um on
employment um i'm afraid uh i'm afraid
uh madam deputy speaker that many of the
claims they're making are simply not
credible but um in conclusion i would
just like to say that um the queen's
speech set out the government's
ambitious level order this is just
getting a bit too much i can't hear the
minister look
it is a fact it's obvious honorable
members disagree with the minister
that's what they're here for they don't
have to make so much noise about it we
have to hear what the minister has to
say
minister
thank you madam deputy speaker it's
because they don't like it up and then
they know that the points are making or
hitting her
so this queen speech sets out the
government's ambitious legislative
agenda to grow and strengthen our
economy ease the cost of living for hard
working families and level up
opportunity in all parts of the country
it includes a leveling up and
regeneration bill that will transform
struggling towns and cities supporting
local leaders to take back control of
regeneration and the blight of empty
shops in their high streets and deliver
the quality homes that communities need
a renter's reform bill that will deliver
the biggest change to rental law in a
generation improving the lives of
millions of renters by improving
standards in the private and socially
rented sector and a social housing bill
that will shift the balance of power
towards tenants strengthening their
rights and creating a robust regulatory
framework that drives up the standards
of social housing everywhere i am very
proud madam deputy speaker that my
department is contributing five bills
towards the government's ambitious
legislative agenda and it has been a
pleasure working with ministerial
colleagues pps's and officials on these
policies not least our uh secretary of
state who manages to be both
conservative and radical at the same
time so madame deputy speaker um the
bill set out in her majesty's gracious
speech meet the demands of the moment
our plan recognizes the sacrifices that
have been made by the british people of
the past two years and allows us to
return to our central mission of
leveling up communities and creating a
stronger fairer more united country
thank you the question is that the
debate be now adjourned especially that
opinion say aye
uh
just one moment i have neglected to
allow the whip to ask for the debate to
be adjourned i beg to move that the
debate be now adjourned and now the
question is that the debate be now
adjourned as many as that opinion say i
or the contrary no i think the eyes have
it the eyes
have it
point of order angela rainer
thank you madam deputy speaker i'd be
grateful for advice from the chair
following the publication of the humble
address regarding the appointment of
lord lebedev
as you all know on the 29th of march the
house approved the humble address
compelling the government to release to
us critical information concerning the
prime minister's involvement in the
appointment of lord lebedev of the other
place the evidence provided has been so
heavily redacted it is utterly pointless
in the written ministerial statement
accompanying the publication of this
humble address the minister suggested
that it would be quote
for the government
to consider what documents are suitable
for release
i am sure the chair would agree that
this sets an extremely dangerous
precedent and can the chair confirm that
what the government says in the company
and statement is incorrect and it is up
to
the government whether they are
transparent about information requested
by the democratic will of the parliament
parliament
thank you
please thank the honorable lady
for her point of order
and it is a point of order for the chair
and uh she makes it very well
um i do recall
the matters to which she refers
but i cannot give her an answer to her
question now from the chair because
if the honourable lady is asserting as i
think she is the government response as
published today to the address of
the 29th of march doesn't satisfy the
terms of that address
um
she will wish to consider whether that
actually amounts to a complaint of
privilege
it's the practice of the house that a
complaint of privilege must first be
raised in writing with mr speaker
this is set out in ersk in may at
paragraph 15 32.
so i can't deal with the matter
now but she raises it quite properly and
if as i think she probably is asserting
it is a complaint of privilege
um she ought to make such a complaint
after careful consideration of the
written ministerial statement and the
return to the address of the 29th of
march
which has just been published and she
should then write formally to mr speaker
setting out her concerns i'm sure she
will do so and it will be for mr speaker
to determine whether or not the matter
should be given precedence for debate in
the house
being a matter of privilege
thank you
i beg to move that the highest in china
i beg to move that the debate in our
journal we've done that one it's i beg
to move at the house you know a journey
to move at the house do now adjourn
the question is that the house do now
adjourn
margaret ferrier
thank you madam deputy speaker
i i would like to thank mr speaker for
granting this important adjustment
debate i know that those of my
constituents that have been affected and
other members will be grateful that this
situation has been recognized with due
seriousness
on the first day of easter recess my
constituent patrick hughes called my
office
following the collapse of safe hands
funeral plans who had gone into
administration the week before
he was quite understandably extremely
anxious about what was going to happen
next
some years ago mr hughes had bought a
policy or plan with safe hands at an
initial cost of around six thousand
three hundred pounds it was a
significant investment but it was worth
it he was paying for peace of mind that
his family wouldn't have to worry about
finding the money for a funeral when the
time comes
funerals don't come cheap and we all
want to be able to give our loved ones
the best send off we can
a key attraction for mr hughes and so
many like them was the security they
were being offered nothing could go
wrong they were assured this is a smart
investment your plan is guaranteed your
family will be grateful they won't have
to worry about this at their time of
grieving
to date mr hughes has been contacted
exactly once after the business went
into administration the initial letter
informing him of the collapse
like the many thousands of policy
holders finding themselves in the same
boat mr hughes tried to make contact
with safe hands or other administrators
to try and get some answers about what
would happen next
his letters went unanswered the phone
lines wouldn't connect or would just
ring out panic began to set in
customers had been told that the company
were uncertain that the funeral plans
will be able to be fulfilled
and to consider their plans terminated
with immediate effect
people were realizing that it was
becoming very likely their life savings
had been lost
safe hands were not regulated by the
financial conduct authority and
anecdotally i understand were regarded
as cowboys in the wider funeral industry
a reputation that didn't reach their
customers in time for them to reconsider
their investments
the thing is plans like these are
provided by reputable companies and
regulated properly can be immensely
beneficial they really could give some
peace of mind that's why along with the
sector and colleagues i wholeheartedly
welcome the government's plans to bring
funeral planning services under the rima
of the financial conduct authority in
july this year
the plans which include assessments of
providers fund protection measures
stricter advertising rules and bans on
cold calling will hopefully protect
future customers from falling victim to
the scams of unscrupulous companies like
safe hands
i appreciated the letter the fca sent to
me in advance of this debate
which sets out how the regulatory
reforms will work and i look forward to
taking up their offer of a meeting to
discuss in more detail
i'm happy to give you i'm grateful
tomorrow benjamin for giving me and
commender for securing this debate as an
example of the kind of advertising this
company have been doing and she
mentioned the fact that they promised
that the customer's money would be kept
in an entirely separate independent
company is she aware that the trustees
set up a company called called shft
properties limited and that every single
person who's ever been a director of
that company was also a director of safe
hand plans limited does she share my
frustration that the directors of
companies who can repeatedly tell such
blatant lies in order to corner
customers are allowed to carry on being
directors of other companies to this
very day despite the chaos that is left
behind in the wreckage of safran's plans
i'd like to thank honorable friend for
his intervention and i have more
specific thanks to give him a little
later in my speech i completely agree
with the points he's made and i know
that the government intend to bring
forward legislation around economic
crime and impropriety this session and i
hope the minister can confirm that this
is something they are seriously
considering as part of that
i was particularly happy to see the
clear focus on consumer protections and
i fully agree with that approach that
looks to make sure customers pay a fair
price the plan meets some needs the
money is looked after responsibly and
they have all the information they need
to make an informed decision
unfortunately though that announcement
is just too little too late for many of
safe hands customers
i'll provide some context about how safe
hands worked customers money was put
into a trust and then reinvested these
funds are supposed to protect customer
investments and indeed that's how it was
sold to my constituent mr hughes the
trust should be overseen by independent
trustees whose job it is to make sure
funds are not misappropriated
and are ring fence from the funeral
providers business assets when safe
hands suddenly left the market after
withdrawing their application to be an
approved seller under the upcoming fca
rules administrators found a significant
shortfall between the value of this
trust and the cost of the funeral plans
it would need to finance
seemingly what administrators found is
that the trust's assets had been wildly
overvalued
even more concerningly that most of the
assets were actually owned by third
parties as the honourable member
mentioned earlier
reports indicate that over 60 million
pounds of the trust reported 64 million
pound valued assets for high risk
investments based over offshore and if
true we're talking about fraudulent
misappropriation of the trusts assets
i will refrain from speculating who
might have benefited from all of this
which can only be described as a scam
it is likely that a number of other
similar small i'm happy to give way to
the honourable gentleman
the honorable lady from uh brother glenn
in hamilton west forgiving way i think
she's making a very important point
constituents from
many many uh colleagues will be affected
by this i'm for example i've been
contacted by a mrs
a mrs hall of nesboro who is caught up
in this issue
does she agree with me that it's
absolutely critical that funds which are
supposedly secure are managed in an
effective way where we have protections
for human protections regulatory
protections so that those who are
looking for certainty uh what will be a
very difficult time for their families
will be able to ensure they get that
certainty
absolutely i thank the honourable
gentleman for that intervention and as
he said
many members
in the chamber have been a fa many of
their constituents have been affected
right across the uk and it's really
important that people get that certainty
because it's an extra worry for them
it is likely that a number of other
similar smaller funeral plan providers
will be shortly exiting the market ahead
of regulatory measures becoming
effective they may be unwilling or even
unable to meet the requirements for
regulatory approval and that has the
potential to leave customers all these
companies in the same situation that
those that went with safe hands find
themselves in now no plans and no
guarantees about retrieving the money
the putin
i know that this is also something the
fca are looking at preemptively
with the aim of minimizing risk to
people that have already invested in
plans with such firms hopefully the work
they are already undertaking will
mitigate any potential further harm to
vulnerable consumers however for
customers of prepaid funeral plan
companies that will shortly be exiting
the market the proof will be in the
pudding
i'm happy to give away i congratulate
the honourable member for obtaining this
debate which does affect so many
constituents does she share with me the
concern that as she has said there were
plans in the offing for the fca to have
a role with the companies such as the
the
safe hands company does she showed me
concern that more was not done to warn
people because this had already been
flagged up and it doesn't seem to me
that enough had been done in that
interim period so as she says we could
see even more people attracted now by
other companies going a similar way yeah
thank you honourable member for that
intervention and absolutely agree i
think it was too little as i said too
late and i think more people you know
that need to be aware of these plans and
what it may mean and i look forward to
the fca as i see bringing in that
regulation at the end of july not too
far in in the future
um
so for customers of safe hands there is
the potential of some support in the
form of dignity plc one of the uk's
largest providers of plans
dignity have put a plan to the
administrators that would allow them to
step up and cover some of the shortfall
left by safe hands providing immediate
support where it's needed most urgently
and planning to work with other
customers and their families in the
longer term to find solutions that won't
leave customers with nothing in place
they believe that because of their
business model as a planned provider
with a wide network of funeral directors
they are uniquely placed to offer their
support and they have already fulfilled
and full the funeral plans of all safe
hands customers in the four weeks
following the collapse of the firm they
are also already preparing for the
regulation requirements that will
shortly come into effect but even as of
last night at my last check the
information being offered by
administrators through the frequently
asked questions page and the safehands
website was insufficiently clear or
reassuring
they make numerous references to
dignity's offerings but reiterate that
customers should consider their plans
cancelled with no guarantees around how
much money customers will see returned
if any at all there is a lot of options
being explored
and updates will be provided by a
disappointing lack of commitment
in fact my constituent mr hughes really
only has one immediate plea some clarity
some willingness to proactively engage
with customers maybe it isn't possible
for administrators to provide
reassurances
in the true sense of the word maybe the
financial realities of the situation
just won't allow for that but how
difficult can it be really to make sure
victims of this unfortunate situation
are kept abreast of updates
to let them know periodically how work
is developing that they have not been
overlooked or forgotten
mr hughes has explained that there is so
much information so much speculating so
many customers shouting in the hopes
they'll be held that he struggles to cut
through the noise what he needs is some
reliable clear information to understand
what has happened why it's happened and
what might happen next
not only for him but his family and his
children
he worries about the worst happening
while all of this remains unresolved the
additional distress this uncertainty
will cause
when people decide to invest in a
prepaid funeral plan it is often in the
back of an event in their life that has
made them come to terms with their own
mortality
maybe they're just reaching old age
maybe they've had a worrying medical
diagnosis maybe they recently lost a
loved one
that means that they are emotionally
vulnerable and it means that they need
to be sure their investment is protected
particularly when you consider that the
majority of those that will choose a
prepaid plan are doing so because the
estate might not leave much more than
the cost of a funeral for their children
or family if it would even cover that
much
we are in a cost of living prices at a
time when people are struggling with the
stress of paying their energy bills
putting food in the table or meeting
their general living course
is absolutely unthinkable that resulting
from the collapse of safe hands some of
those people will face the added stress
of trying to finance the funeral of
someone they care about a funeral that
as far as they were concerned was
already paid for either partially or in
many cases in full
of course i understand that any business
needs to turn the profit it's the nature
of the game and a highly emotionally
charged market like this based on one of
the few guarantees we have in life death
sensitivity is required
to pray on this customer base is
absolutely disgusting while safe hands
certainly do not represent the standards
of the industry as a whole whether
intentionally or not we already know
other firms have put their customers
money and funeral plans at risk by not
seeking approval ahead of regulations
for reasons i hope they understand i'm
cautious about enthusiastically throwing
my support behind any company within the
currently unregulated prepaid sector at
the moment but i would like to thank
dignity for proactively reaching out and
sharing some information with me ahead
of this debate i would also like to
thank the appg for funerals and
bereavement and the chair the right
honourable member for south holland and
the deepings i know they continue to
engage with the treasury on this matter
to try and ensure dignity is maintained
and another thank you to the honourable
member for glenn rothers who organized
the cross-party letter to the secretary
of state for business energy and
industrial strategy last month which
provided a coordinated display of the
feelings held by constituents i hope the
minister will be in a position to
provide the assurances safe hands and
their administrators have been unable to
and i would urge the minister with his
colleagues in the treasury and across
whitehall to find a way to make sure
that these people who have lost hard
damned money don't miss out on a
dignified goodbye when that time sadly
comes for mr hughes and the 46 000
others like him for their families and
friends and the people who love them
most in the world
thank you uh just before just before i
uh ask the whip to move the five o'clock
adjournment
i uh
i refer back now to the decision taken
by the house a few moments ago to
adjourn today's debate
and i will ask the quip to please name a
day on which today's debate shall be
resumed
monday the 16th of may
monday the 16th of may
thank you
now we will get a german please
beg to move this house do not adjourn
the question is that this house do now
adjourn
honorable men
i am martin deputy speaker thank you for
bringing me in and my apology to the
minister who wasn't anticipating me
bobbing up for two minutes so i hope he
will allow him can i command the younger
lady for uh to go in the debate i know
her one that i was going to intervene to
get exactly more of an intervention than
she perhaps anticipated and like her
i've had numerous constituents
contacting me who have had safe hands
policies and are in deep distress over
what is occurring many some of them have
relatives very near the point of death
unsure what was going to happen to them
like i welcome dignity's proactive
approach to this but i remain deeply
deeply concerned that there will be many
more films in a similar situation
withdrawing from the market before fca
regulation takes full effect i'm not yet
clear that dignity has the capacity to
cope with that level of demand nor the
industry as a whole has the will power
to address this issue and that reminds
me to such extent that the fairfax
scandal of about 10 years ago but those
are relatively small sums compared to
what we're looking at for those that
have been invested in funeral plans i
represent
one of the most deprived communities in
the united kingdom the cost of a funeral
for families in my constituency can be
one of the largest unexpected bills that
they face
and many of them will have invested in
these plans not just for the emotional
security but for the financial security
too
and they will risk as an alternative
hoping to resort to very dangerous
lending practices from loan sharks and
on the doorsteps so i urge the minister
to try to explain what more he can do
can i also urge him i know he's working
on this to accelerate the pilot schemes
and no interest loans i know he is
working on because to me that is the
perfect vehicle i think for trying to
deal with these large unexpected costs
that allows the state to provide as an
interim solution to give people more
financial stability
this is a genuine worry from dozens if
not hundreds of people to cross my
constituency and are joining my lady and
looking forward to hearing what the
minister has to say thank you modern
deputy speaker
minister john glenn thank you very much
uh madam deputy speaker
and let me firstly uh thank the member
for rutherglen and hamilton west for
securing
this important and timely debate on what
is an incredibly
subject and i i thank colleagues from
across the house for the contributions
that they have made
the member for glen ross the honourable
lady from clenethlete
i will come on to address the point uh
specifically made by the member for
blackpool and uh north and the
clevelands and i thank my honourable
friend the member for harrogate and
nesboro for raising his constituents uh
case
but i'd also
at the
outset like to take this opportunity to
remember our former colleagues david
amos he was a friend to many of us here
today
and someone who cared very much about
helping people manage the financial
impacts of funerals
and i would also thank members who have
campaigned over the last few years in
support of regulation
and i recall conversations with neil
gray
who first tabled a private members bill
to this effect in 2016
former member for airdrie and schutz
finally i would express my gratitude to
members here today for
the points that they've made i will be
able to address i think many of them and
anything that i haven't addressed i will
i will write to members
as has been said funerals are madam
deputy speaker painful experiences
but they can also provide people with a
degree of mental closure because they
help us to adjust to the reality of the
loss of a loved one
i think we all very much agree that at
such a moment mourners should be able to
focus on their memories of their loved
one and on their own emotions no one
should be consumed
by money worries
clearly therefore safe hands entering
administration as the honourable lady
very accurately set out it's very
distressing for its customers and their
families and as obviously she mentions
very eloquently the case of mr hughes
and what he has experienced in recent
weeks
and our thought should be with those who
have recently lost someone close to them
and now find themselves
affected
by safe hands failure
now as has been referenced
the
dignity one of the uk's largest funeral
plan providers have stepped in to
provide funerals on behalf of safe hands
customers in the immediate period after
the firm entered
into administration
and i would echo the honourable ladies
words in expressing gratitude that they
have stepped up to the mark and they've
agreed to do that for a further six
months
um i regret the fact that she that her
constituent doesn't have clarity on
exactly where
that leaves him
but of course safe hands themselves will
be entering the administration process
and that will need to be concluded
before wider issues can be
looked at but i met with dignity just
yesterday with my officials in the
treasury and they
reiterated their commitment for the next
six months
it's been
very welcome to see a funeral plan
provider taking that responsibility for
protecting the the sector's customers
and upholding the industry's reputation
and i had the privilege of meeting with
the honourable member for south holland
and deepings and members
of the appg industry a few weeks ago to
discuss what was happening with this
very difficult case
while the financial conduct authority
does not yet regulate funeral plan
plan providers it is currently
supporting the industry and
administrators as they look to find a
longer term solution for safe hand
customers
and i'm very hopeful that customers
won't need to wait too much longer
before they see further progress
in relation to this longer term approach
however i strongly believe that what has
happened to safe hands is clear evidence
of the pressing need for a better
regulated funeral plan market that will
provide customers with the stability
they need at such a difficult time and
will allow us as members of parliament
with constituents who've been affected
by safe hands
demise the reassurance
and confidence that we can
see them not worry in future
because while the sector provides a
valuable service there is still some
distance to travel when it comes to
ensuring all funeral plan customers are
shielded from harm
indeed major reports and work carried
out by the treasury and the financial
conduct authority revealed examples of
consumer detriment in the sector
and as a result last year we legislated
to bring providers and intermediaries
within the regulatory remit of the fca
and this change means madam deputy
speaker that from july the 29th funeral
plan providers will be subject to robust
and enforceable standards for the first
time and these standards will benefit
consumers in a number of ways
for instance by giving them clarity
about what is covered by their plans
and ending high pressure and misleading
sales tactics
in addition for the first time funeral
plan customers will be able to access a
redress scheme which will be provided by
the financial ombudsman service
ultimately we believe a well-regulated
market will promote effective
competition and drive better long-term
consumer
outcomes
and i would
recognize that this industry does have
an important role to play the the uh
demise of safe hands will be
dealt with through the administration
process and there may well then be um
further examination of what happened but
my determination is that we will
get this regulation right and we will
provide the security to the industry uh
the vast majority of uh
firms in that industry
are doing the right thing presently and
once they've adjusted to that new regime
i'm clear that we will be able to have
confidence going forward
but the government recognized that this
new regulation presents a major change
for providers
and that's why we introduce an 18-month
transition period before the new rules
came into effect and this has given
businesses time to take the right steps
to familiarize themselves with the new
requirements and to
help them to prepare to adopt them
of course we recognize that it is
paramount that we minimize any
disruption to customers because of these
changes and that's why madam deputy
speaker the fca has said that providers
that decide not to obtain authorization
or cannot obtain it should transfer
their plans to a provider that will
operate under the new rules
alternatively businesses should wind
down an orderly way before the
regulation comes into force
and on that note members may be also
aware that last month the government
made a supplementary statutory
instrument this will make it easier for
that transfer process for funeral plan
providers seeking to exit the market
to transfer their existing funeral plan
to a regulated funeral plan provider and
that was something i discussed with
dignity yesterday they welcome that and
it should ease that that process for the
relatively small number that will find
themselves subject to a plan where the
provider will not go into regulation and
they'll be able to port it to one of the
bigger industry providers
now clearly there is a possibility when
bringing a sector into regulation for
the first time that some providers will
be unable to meet the authorization
threshold
in addition the process may reveal some
businesses who are unable to deliver on
promises that they made to their
customers
i'm very happy to give away
anyways understandably i'm focusing on
the new regulatory regime that's coming
in and i think he is aware of some of my
concerns about the adequacies of the fca
that's currently set up but there should
have been other regulation who should
have been regulating the activities of
the trust
who should have prevented them from
engaging in wildly speculative insecure
investments directly against the
promises made who should have been
regulating the fact that in the first
two years of accounts for
safe hands plans limited there were
dimensions dementably and very obviously
false statements and those statements
that were never picked up by company's
house and so does he accept that
regardless of the changes to regulation
of funeral plans companies there appear
to be serious regulatory failures
elsewhere again
well i thank the honorable gentleman for
his point he's making some points
somewhat speculatively speculatively but
with some
valid specific concerns over the journey
that safe hands went on now obviously
until that administration process is
concluded uh other investigations will
not be able to take place
but of course the the driver for the
regulations that we're now bringing in
was the fear that existed from members
across this house a few years ago um we
the important thing is that we give
reassurance going forward but there will
be a day of reckoning for uh the the
directors of safe hands to account for
what happened but the administration
process is what must happen first so i
can't say any more on that but his his
very relevant points are noted
i must stress that an inability to meet
these new standards of regulation
due to issues with conduct business
models or trust arrangements
does not mean the regulation is at fault
rather bringing the sector into
regulation exposes the the unsustainable
practices which left unchecked could
ultimately worsen and impact more
consumers
as the famous adage says madame deputy
speaker
sunlight is the best disinfectant and by
regulating in this instance we will turn
the spotlight onto businesses operating
with unworkable models and prevent
consumer harm
at this point i might just refer
to my uh
friend the honourable gentleman for
blackpool north and the clevelanders who
asked about the no interest loan scheme
that we've been piloting that is being
piloted in the south manchester credit
union i hope to visit manchester the
week after next but he's absolutely
right there is a much wider agenda here
in terms of affordable
credit and uh i very much am still
committed to developing uh that
instrument and making it widely
available alongside other interventions
with respect to credit unions that uh
we'll be able to talk about when the
financial service and markets bill comes
to this house shortly
but it is right that the government acts
to protect consumers many of whom will
be elderly or vulnerable with a robust
proportionate regulatory framework
in addition a well-regulated market will
promote effective competition and drive
better long-term outcomes for consumers
as i have said madam deputy speakers
safe hands customers can be assured that
they will be covered for at least
another
six months and i encourage other
providers and market participants to
take further action as dignity have done
to protect consumers of firms that won't
become authorized
but i would like to assure the house
that the government
and the financial conduct authority
continue to work closely with each other
and with the sector i've mentioned those
two meetings that i've personally held
and my officials have also held with
those industry representatives to ensure
that that shift to regulation is as
smooth as possible taking account of the
number of valid uh points that have been
raised this afternoon
because madam deputy speaker we all have
a moral obligation to ensure that
funeral plan customers and their loved
ones receive the certainty that they
need
and deserve
thank you
thank you
the question is that this house do now
adjourn as many as that opinion say i
i think the eyes have it the eyes
have it
order
order
house of commons sound